learn how to build a threads clone uh I
mean a Twitter clone the focus of this
course is not just building the
application but also understanding and
implementing essential development tools
like next.js 13 Tailwind CSS typescript
and super bass key elements covered
include designing the layout with
Tailwind CSS managing the back end with
Super Bass incorporating robust
authentication handling server actions
fetching tweets and developing engaging
features like liking and replying to
tweets this course is an excellent
resource for those wanting to understand
the complete life cycle of developing a
real world application with the latest
tools and Technologies pranjal Sony is a
full stack developer and he teaches this
course let's start learning welcome to
holistic Netflix
in this course we are going to build a
fully step tutor application it is a web
application and the tech history we are
going to use is Nexus 13.4 version with
latest server actions and server
components we are going to use Superbass
for authentication and for our postgres
SQL database we are going to use
something called drizzle orm for our
database orm to make our life easier
with fetching and inserting data in our
database then we are going to use Redix
UI components by shared CN it's a very
great Library if you go to
ui.sharescn.call you will find it's an
awesome library and we will use this
library to build our dialogues and build
our application components other than
that we are going to use typescript that
is obvious part because type is shift
helps us to build our application faster
and it helps us in a lot of Auto
completion so that while developing the
web application our life is very very
easier so if you are excited and if you
want to join this course follow along
this course is absolutely free you can
watch all the tutorials on my YouTube
channel you can watch the whole series
and it will teach you a lot of concepts
of Nexus so thank you very much and I
hope you enjoy watching this course and
the most important part now I will play
a demo on my side you can see this is
the demo of how we are going to build
the application and and how our
application is gonna look after we have
built it so if you have watched the demo
forward application and if you are
excited to follow along follow this
course and learn next year's 13th thank
you so now as you can see I am using Mac
operating system so if you are using
Windows you can use your terminal which
is a git terminal okay so you can
install all the things you can install
visually Studio code I have made all the
videos related to installing
initializing in my past YouTube videos
so you can watch them you can understand
everything related to installing and
setting up the environment we will
directly jump forward and we will start
building our applications so I haven't
prepared anything so you will see what I
do here yeah so for the CSS part I have
forgot to mention that we are going to
use Telvin CSS because I like Kelvin
cssa a lot and it will increase our
productivity at least by 10x so that's
why I love using television CSS and
that's why we are going to use salvances
in this full hack Twitter clone project
so for installing so first we will get
into our folder so now I am in my root
so I will go to desktop I will go to
YouTube and I will clear everything and
I will now use pnpx command so you can
use yarn you can use npm you can use
pnpm but we are going to use pnpm
because it is fast so why it is faster
because pnpm used a mechanism to hard
link all the packages to the code we are
working for example you are using Prisma
Oram inside your one
code folder or inside your one code
repository and you try to install that
into your another folder into your
another project so it will install it
one place and then it will link that
package to every project from a centered
location that's why it is faster and it
will
help us to save our disk space inside
our machine that's why I love using pnpm
but it may sometimes cause some errors
so you can always shift to yarn that is
better than npm so I will go for pnpm
now I will say pnpx
create next
app because we are using next yes so it
is a command to directly install the
next.js so create next app at the red
latest and we will say
just enter and now you can enter your
project name so I will say Twitter clone
so I will call it ultimate ultimate
Twitter Chrome
now it will ask us a few things you
would you like to use typescript yes
yes television CSS absolutely yes
yes and now it will say would you like
to use experimental app directly it is
now experimental but it is a great
chance that when you are watching this
it is into the stable version so we will
move forward with server components
that's why it is the latest and greatest
tutorial on the internet as of now
so we will use import alias
so that we don't have to use relative
Imports so it will make our life easier
also so you as you can see it has
installed all the packages very fast
because they already exist in my machine
and the pnpm just hard linking them to
the center location where the packages
exist
to my project now we can go to our
ultimate
and I have made a ultimate blog
application udemy course so you can see
that thing in my description or you can
visit
the page but as of now this is a free
tutorial and
this is going to be free always and I'm
making sure that it will be the greatest
tutorial on my YouTube channel so as you
can see we are into our folder into our
repository now we can open our Visual
Studio code over code editor where we
will write some code so code spaced out
and enter and now it will open a window
of Visual Studio code
open it and now you as you can see
everything is set up already for us so
inside the source directory
you have this API routes where you can
Define some API routes
you have your layout you have your page
so now as you can see our project is
ready now we will install a few things
which will help us to make our life easy
so now as you can see we are using next
font and here we are using enter so we
will remove everything and first we will
run this application so that we can see
what is happening there so we will run
pnpm run Dev because if you see in the
package.json here you can see to run the
dev environment you just have to run
pnpm run Dev yarn run Dev or npm brand
as you can see we are using App
directory because we will use server
components the latest and greatest stuff
in the react ecosystem so this is my
browser window I will open it in another
tab here and I will go to localhost 3000
and you will be able to see how it looks
so this is our basic nex.js application
running as you can see now as I said we
will use Superbass for everything in
this project because why we are using
Super Bass because it is very easy to
set up authentication to set up database
to set up storage because we will be
uploading images we will be uploading
GIF also for our Twitter post so that it
will be very easy for us to like use
super bass and it will handle all the
complex stuff for us so we don't have to
worry about anything so as you can see
building we can scale to Millions this
video is not sponsored by Superbass if
they have sponsored it I would be very
grateful but it is not I am just
recommending it because this is by far
my go-to tech stack for building fully
stack web application and I love using
super besters so now as you can see it
is totally free by the way you can sign
up for a free account and now you can
click on new project and I will say
ultimate Twitter Club so this is a
database password which you can also
generate afterwards and now I will
choose a reason which is near to me free
account and create a new project now it
will create a new project for us and now
let's see what are the features Super
Bass offers so we will see all the
features so you can see we have database
we have storage we have Edge functions
if we want to do some computation on our
backend side but I think for our project
we don't need any computation but if you
need something like sending emails to
the user running a chrome job or doing
some expensive task like video
processing image processing or some kind
of stuff then you can use Edge functions
it is just like serverless functions or
it is just like using virtual API routes
but it is much more capable of doing
anything and it uses Dino as a framework
of node.js and we also have real time
thing where we can face real-time data
we can get real-time updates so let's
assume you have some leaderboard inside
your fully stack application then you
can use Superbus real-time database to
connect to your database and whenever
you have some updates it will
automatically update your UI and your
users will be able to see all the
results changing in real time and we
will use authentication we will use
database we will use storage these three
things these three things I think we are
gonna need inside our project so it will
take some time to provision the project
let's wait for some time you can see
okay so our project will be deployed on
its own instance okay so let's wait for
some time and we will see how it works
so you can also visit some documentation
here all the documentation is here so
number one thing we can directly create
our database tables here okay so if you
visit Twitter so I don't let me just get
my Twitter account so we are going to
copy this whole thing so as you can see
this is over Twitter and we are going to
copy this whole thing we are going to
copy this model we are going to copy
this sidebar this timeline this trending
section and we I think I am also going
to build this feature which is training
feature who to follow and all of those
things so first first thing first what
do we need we need our database so what
does a Twitter contain a Twitter content
tweets number one thing users tweets and
replies and all that kind of stuff but
for now we will stick to our database so
we will think how should we approach so
let's let me open my escalator and here
we will see what we will do so how
should we approach the whole thing so
here we can do something so first we can
build our layout build our UI build over
layout I think that's the best approach
and that's what I do almost all the time
UI build the whole UI and then what you
need to do now you have the UI you know
what the data you need then you can
proceed and you can design your database
you can design your database so design
the database then afterwards we will
create our tables so let me Zoom it so
you can see now we have our database and
now we will create our tables create
tables and sync over database with over
code so let's assume we are going to use
an orm like Prisma to handle our
database queries and mutations and
handle all the migrations and all that
kind of stuff but we are not going to
use Prisma here we will just stick to
plain Superbass and plain stuff here
with super best directly queuing over
database and directly mutating over data
base from our front end by using the
Super Bass GS library and for our
curious thing we will use react query
and you will see what are the problems
we are facing with plain Superbass with
using custom hooks or if you use a
library such as react query to make our
life easier with loading State and error
States so here we will create tables and
sync our database with our code base so
now we have our database and also
typescript configuration so we need to
do some things with typescript here and
afterwards so when we have did this
thing now we can build our functionality
so now we can build our functionality
build the functionality so what are the
functionalities we need mostly in our
Twitter application so mostly post Tweet
a tweet includes text image video also
or GIF so we will we are going to
implement all of this thing okay so
posted a tweet can include a tweet
includes text images video GIF or all of
that combined so we are going to
implement this functionality so this is
the first thing now we have an infinite
timeline which is infinite scrolling
feature okay so this is the main feature
where we can first fetch the tweets
another functionality we have is user
page profile where we have our users and
users can like a post users can like
bookmark like and bookmark two things we
can and reply to a tweet so it a reply
is also a kind of tweet a reply is also
a kind of tweet so we will see how to
implement this thing and that's all the
functionalities which we need so this is
a lot of work and you will see how we
approach these all things and you will
be amazed how easy is this to build this
application and how easy is this to
build this application using nexjs and
Super Bass and television so first let's
jump right into building the UI part go
as you can see this is our basic Nexus
application starter code which we have
initialize everything in the last video
in this video we will just going to
build the layout section and the whole
UI section of the home page so we will
remove everything here rafc if you don't
have this extension you can install this
here you can install the es7 plus react
reduxe synthetic native Snippets this is
a very useful extension which will give
you a lot of Auto completion if you type
rafc then you can see our load to
completion which it will give you but we
need rafc even so this is so this is our
home page our Twitter home page and now
here we will Design the thing we can
remove this we don't need this thing so
if we go to Twitter we can see how it
looks so this is how Twitter looks like
you can see this is our timeline this is
explore settings but we can create a
fake account for now so I think if I if
I refresh this it will ask us I will
sign up for a demo account for now yeah
so this is the club of folders account
as you can see and now we will implement
this thing first of all we will
understand this layout we will
understand this layout how it works so
first we will go to excalator and here
we will Design our whole UI we will
understand it so this is our home page
as you can see this is our home page and
now we have some fixed width if we try
to zoom out you can see the whole
Twitter page is taking some fixed width
some fixed maximum width and it is not
exceeding its fixed width and it looks
different on mobile but we are only
going to build this whole thing for the
desktop I am not going to make this
layout responsive you can do that so now
this is our whole layout and this is
some fixed width let's assume this is
our fix width and now here we can see
this is the sidebar so first we will
make a division and we will give it
fixed width after that we will make 3D
using inside it sidebar this is the main
layout which you can see this is the
main timeline section and this will our
training section this third division
this is our third division which is our
right sidebar okay and now what we will
do this all our icons this is home this
is exclude notifications all these
things so Dash datash and here we can
write a tweet we will not implement this
for you and following we will just stick
to the basic one this whole where we can
write our tweet which is here home just
like it and this is a section where we
will write our tweet we will compose our
tweet and and now we have all our tweets
here like this Dash and here we have our
trending section what's happening so
this is our twin trending section and
this is who to follow section just like
that so this is the whole UI we need so
this is just a game of flex box and
grids and this is very easy to implement
this is fixed this is also fixed only
this is scrollable and we will do all
these things very easily by using telwyn
CSS and you will see how much easier
this to build this whole layout and this
is our Twitter logo okay so let's start
building this first we will install the
icons library because we need Twitter
icon so we will say pnpm install react
icons this is a great Library which you
can search also react icons dot
github.io this library and here we can
search Twitter and here you can see this
is the exact icon we are looking for so
as I said first we will create this
fixed width thing so we can say class
name is W full H full width and we can
say this is a whole Flex box justify
Center item Center if you are not seeing
the auto completion you can install the
Telvin intellisense so you can install
this so now we have it full H full and
it is item Center and we will now make a
fixed with division inside it so class
name maximum which is screen 1024 pixel
okay this is good we can say with full H
full it it is also a flex we can make it
Flex because okay so these These are
these are fixed you can make it relative
it is also relative you don't need to
specify It Is by default relative but we
are it is not widely for relative I
think yeah so if you want to make he
learn absolute inside this division or
inside this division then you have to
give it relative so the absolute
division will position itself absolutely
according to its nearest parent that's
how it works so now we have over this
layout the whole color is BG black like
that now we have three things here
inside this we have sidebar Tu into
three so this is our sidebar this is our
home timeline and this is over right
section like this you can also do the
section thing here you can say this is
main to make it semantic HTML can make
it section like this and now we can do
all the things so first let's design the
left sidebar so it is class name
now if you give it absolute width it
will poison itself according to this
division but if you make it fixed with
it will position itself relative to the
whole Windows width and height so what
do you think what should we keep it this
thing I think we can position itself
with the whole
Windows height so you can say fixed and
W is we can give it some width let's
find out what is the width of this so
now you can see this is the width of 275
into 836 to 275 pixel with this 275
pixel so you can how 275 which is near
to 64 right things and
70 to yeah it's good and it is a flex
column because inside we will Define all
the navigation items after we have
designed the whole thing then we will
separate all the components into a
different different file because we
don't want our code to not be organized
we want our code to look nice and easy
for anyone who looks at our code so now
we have a fixed sidebar left sidebar so
we can say left sidebar for navigation
or we can say the header it is a kind of
header and it has the height of edge
screen inside it we have home explore
notifications message bookmarks profile
and more so what we can do here we can
Define array const navigation items is
equal to this is the array and we can
then map through them and we can Define
our sidebar so here we have home explore
notifications so we can say that the
title like this the title is home and
the icon is home icon or The Birdhouse
bird house you can insert any icon and
you can choose whichever you like so I
will go with this one okay this looks
better how about we search home yeah
there are this looks similar to The
Tutor House icon so here we can say bi
home Circle and we will import this
thing first so import from react icons
slash Pi like this
now this is explore and this is the
explore icon which is a hashtag so we
can search a hashtag
import from react icon slash hi now we
have notifications
notifications icon is kind of Bell so we
can search bail which looks similar to
the spell icon and I think this one
looks much similar now we have what
messages we are not going to implement
all of these things we will stick to the
basic functionalities you can implement
the other functionalities if you want
for the message we have the envelope so
we can search in the lab yeah so
whichever looks similar yeah this is
good import from react icon slash hi2
okay so import it from BS now we have
bookmarks and profile we will skip them
more we will bookmarks bookmarks and we
have profile for the profile we have the
user icon and for the bookmark we have
the bookmark this one looks good BS
bookmark for the profile we have the
user icon so AI outline user Pi user
whichever you like so I think it looks
good you can import it from here so now
we have all our navigation item and we
can render them if you hover over this
you can see this is the title and icon
and we just need to render it over here
so we can say it navigation items dot
map and this is our item and now we can
say render a division which has a key of
item dot title and we need to render two
things here so instead of division we
can what we can do instead of division
we can render a link over here and we
can say href is also slash item dot
title dot to lowercase like this and
here we can give it some classes I I
will give it busy white of 50 rounded of
3XL painting I will give it padding of 4
and that's good here we will render two
divisions first for the icon so here we
can say item dot icon just like it and
here we can render another Division and
inside this we can render the item dot
title we can make it a flex we can give
it item Center justify Center we can
give space of X of 2 and now save this
and let's have a look at the whole home
page what we have did till now so now
you can see this is what we have
designed and it is looking nicely for
the first look we have forgot to render
this Twitter icon here so what we will
do first we will render the Twitter icon
over here so we can say this is link
href is Slash and this is just a Twitter
icon so we can say PS Twitter now if you
have a look yeah it is looking good we
can comment these two things for now
yeah also what we need to do is we can
give it some class names for now my of
margin of y y means on the vertical axis
so we can give it 4 M by 4 okay so it is
not working why is that because I think
we have to do something here when we
hover over it then we have to show
something otherwise known so we can say
when you hover and this is just 10 and
we will make a transition duration is
let's give it 200 and P4 is a little bit
too much so P2 will work yeah 30. now
you can see if you refresh this it will
work and 30 is bit too much yeah it is
good now we just have to make it to the
left and we don't want to give it a
whole width what we can do here instead
of just if a center we can say justify
start and W is fit now you can see the W
is fit so it is taking the whole content
width and what we have to do now we have
to make it a little bit bigger so now it
is smaller so for that here we can come
and here we can say note here I think we
can directly say so it will this class
will also work on this is item dot icon
we can set text is Excel so it will make
it a little bit bigger and I think it
will 3XL 2XL yeah it's good and we have
to give it little bit more of space so
we can give it six not on the X on the Y
also so as you can see this is flex
column so instead of giving this m y of
4 but we can do we can say space of y o
four and margin of Y of force yeah now
it's good we should also give it P2 so
it looks similar and also text of 2XL
now you can see we have a similar
looking Twitter UI here we just need to
make it a little bit bigger and the
width is also bigger than we have
defined here so instead of LG what we
can do XL yeah it it is exactly similar
to the tutor and when we are on the page
we will render this icon as a bold like
you can see we will fill this icon for
now we can skip that part for now we are
just designing the home UI now at the
bottom we have Club of folders here at
the bottom so what we will do also we
have this tweet button also if you see
the padding of access a little bit
bigger and here we don't have that
padding so P wise 2 and PX is 4 yeah it
is good now I think it is more PX of 6
yes it's good but we have to give the
same thing to this so that it looks
exactly similar to yeah now it is good
also we can give it this thing we have
but I think we can Define it over here
instead of manually doing so we can say
title is Twitter and icon is PS Twitter
like that now we can remove this thing
but here we don't need the Twitter thing
so what we can do we can conditionally
render this thing so here we can say we
don't need to render the title when the
item dot title is equal to Twitter don't
render this when the item dot title is
not equal to Twitter then enter this
otherwise we can say now you can see it
is similar to the whole thing it is
looking beautiful and we have the same
effect as Twitter now we have a one
thing more here we have a tweet button
so what we can say we have a button here
which is tweet we will Design this
button now we can say w is full a
rounded is 3XL Pages blue so we will
copy which color is this Twitter color
so we'll inspect this element yeah so
this is the color we have so we will
modify our utils because we we need this
color for a lot of things you can see
this is the same color which is this so
we will modify our Telvin config so this
is where we will modify so we will
extend our color so we will search how
to do that I don't know so here we can
say command plus K hit command plus K
and search Kelvin config theme
configuration now you can Define the
colors like that so theme inside colors
and you can Define the colors so team
extend inside the colors we can Define
the colors I will say the Twitter color
or we can say the primary color which is
this now it will work because I think we
have modified the Telvin config we need
to reload or let's see BG of primary
yeah now it will work now you can see
how I find a solution which I don't know
how I search into the documentation and
you should always do this okay so if you
don't know anything you can always
search into the documentation and look
for the solution so now we have our BG
primary color now we need to give it
some padding so pux
6py4 would work and the text is also
bigger so I would give it to Excel and
the text is also Center save this yeah
it is looking good
but when we hover over it the BG opacity
we can reduce some opacity we can say 90
and we can also note 90 I would go for
70. now what I can do I can also give it
transition and the duration is 200 so
that it looks smooth and it is not 3XL
it is actually full yeah now you can see
this and I think we have made it much
weaker so P4 would work I think because
we have given full width that's why it
is working yeah it is bigger so that we
need to decrease this to 75 pixel it's
good but I think we need to
let's keep it margin 4 to decrease some
width of the butter now it is looking
good so you can see the messages is
looking a bold here okay so we don't
need this bold thing we only need this
when we are on the message as page so
instead of this hi envelope we need a
outline so envelope we need an outline
envelope so BS envelope will work for us
yeah it is good and now we have designed
this sidebar for the Twitter okay so
this thing is remaining so let's also
design this thing so we have this
section the whole section we can wrap
this whole thing into a division
separate division why we are doing this
you will find now because this is fixed
width and the height of this is screen
we will make it items stretch and now we
can define a division here and this is
at the bottom you can see now this is at
the bottom it should be at the bottom
now it is not W4 let's give it w full so
it doesn't look odd okay so we have to
keep this whole thing here this is a
division this is another division what I
want I want let me go into X skeletrome
so here we have a division so what I am
saying is we are defining a division
here which is a flex column so this is a
flex and now we will say make this port
using justify between so it will stretch
those division through the whole height
so that it will make this division to
the bottom but it is not doing that so
we will see why yeah now you can see
this is at the bottom but the problem is
because of my4 it is not at the bottom
yeah so we will see what is happening
here we will remove this m by bottom
yeah now you can see this is at the
bottom because we are using items
stretch items stretch will stretch this
division to the bottom that's what we
want here what we can do we can M by 4
now it will work yeah we can only give
it to the top here it's as a screen here
we don't need to give it a screen we can
just not give it anything here we don't
need space y it's good but now here we
can give it Edge full so it will take
the whole height here till here and now
here we are at the bottom and now here
we can Define this thing so this is a
logo this is the name this is a username
and now this is a three button or
whatever to say it so this is similar to
this but some parts are different which
I will tell you inside the button we
have two divisions not actually two we
have three division
this is a three dots so BS three doors I
think yeah we have the three dots here
we have the logo which we can just for
now make it rounded full this is
basically author we can make it busy
slate 400 and what we can do here yeah
it's good we can give it w 8 h8 height
and width this is already I think flex
no this is not Flex so we will make it
flex and items Center
Space X of 2 inside we have two
divisions so this is a division inside
we have two divisions first one is the
username so this is the name of the user
so let's see for now Club of quarters
and here we have Club of colors my
username and now you can save this whole
thing and now we will see how it looks
yeah so it is looking a little bit odd
because we have given its PG primary but
we don't need BG primary we need busy
transparent and because of the text to
excel this is too big so we can make a
text XX so extra small now you can see
this is looking good and instead of
giving it text access here we can give
it text access and this is small and we
can make it text to the left here and I
think the smaller is looking bigger it
is not smaller we can make it font semi
bold and these both are extra small text
yeah and when we hover over this whole
thing we can make it VG White and the
open city of the BG white is 20 now you
can see 10 would work just like it yeah
but here you can see the the three dots
are not on the left not on the right
basically so we want to make it the full
to make it to the full width so what we
can do here we can give it full width
and we can tape this whole thing into a
separate Division and we can make it
item Center and justify between so now
the three dots are to the left and here
we can now Define Flex item Center space
of X of 2. now you can see this is good
but here you can see the text speaker I
think so I can give it a small yeah so
now we have designed the similar looking
Twitter sidebar we can make this thing
this Avatar also bigger 12 watt yeah 10
would work so you can see that the font
is not similar to Twitter you can find
whatever phone you like and I would just
stick to the simple one which we have
now and now you can see we have created
the left sidebar for the Twitter layout
so as you can see this is what we have
currently we need this thing so this is
centered first thing first and then we
have this home then we have this Twitter
composer thing where we can write our
tweet and we can tweet this thing and
then we have the border the bottom
border and we have all the tweets
rendered here so let's put this left
sidebar into its own section so in the
source directory we will create another
folder called components inside
components we have our left sidebar dot
TSX rafce and we will copy and paste the
whole thing over here we'll also need
all these things here
yeah
it's now good and we will import the
left sidebar in the main here left
sidebar just like it save this thing and
now we have a separate component for our
left sidebar close everything and this
is our main time line save this and we
will see how it looks so it is currently
being rendered over here why because we
have this left sidebar and it is fixed
so this container which is a flex
doesn't know that we have this for now
that's why so to make sure that it
assumes that it has something over here
what we can do is we can define a
invisible container here or what we can
do we can make it like left so we can
give it margin of left so class name
margin of left of 275 pixel let's assume
we have a lot of low Ram Epsom here for
the demo and now if we scroll this you
can see we can scroll this and it is
fixed it is fixed but we can scroll this
and that's what we need so Ctrl holds it
and now it is good now what we can do as
you can see this has left border this
has right border and this has tweets
inside it and the home so we will say if
this is flex W is we will give it some
width which is how much width it is
taking so let's find out so this has 598
into 53 so it is 598 so we can give it
600 pixel almost the width and the
height is full obviously and it is a
flex column that's all we need and now
here we have H1 and it is home as you
can see on the Twitter and let's give it
text 3XL font bold save this and we will
see how it looks yeah now we need to
also give it powder left border right or
left and right no top and bottom only
left and right border left and border
right and Border color is gray 400 I
think yeah it is 0.5 pixel I think and
the border is
it looks good it is one pixel left and
right border and the height is full as
you can see here the height is full and
the minimum height I think we can give
it a screen so now you can see it is
taking the whole screen for Twitter and
we here to give some padding to it and
3XL is also a bit too much we can give
it some 2XL and let's give some padding
of five six would work yeah it is good
but we need this to be 0.5 pixel for
that what we can do we can say 0.5 pixel
just like it and the same thing here it
is looking better now we need some
padding for it also you can see the
padding between these two so let's go to
or we can give it some margin we can
give it the whole thing margin so
padding and margin of X is 2 left yeah
so we have to give it some padding to it
so let's give it PX of
over six now now it is good you can see
this is over bottom whole thing and it
is a sidebar and this is looking good
and the home is small small a bit so
let's go into the page here you can say
this is Excel this is good and now we
will Design This compose box so for now
here we can come in here you can you can
say class name this also has the Border
top and bottom so instead of this we can
copy the whole thing we can give it top
and bottom we are not giving left to
right but because if we did then it will
be two borders because we have already
given left and right border here if we
give it here it will be two orders and
it will look like a little bit Bolder so
top and bottom so we have top and bottom
for this box and what we need now we
need some height so how much height we
it is so we can give it Like H of 3 32.
let's try this for now we will see what
it is and now it it has a author which
is the user profile and here it is the
input which is what's happening the
placeholder and now here we can write a
lot of things so low Ram Epsom let's
choose some words not like this uh
generate paragraphs yeah so now you can
see Twitter character limits so I think
144 is a character limit of Twitter
Twitter character limit 280 characters
okay so so it has two at the character
limit okay so we can now give it
relative also and now inside it inside
this division we have this Avatar and
author so we can make two revision
inside it first one is for Avatar which
is a W10 h10 height and width is 10 and
BG is Select 400 rounded is full it is
good here we have two things we have
this input box then we have this border
then we have this tweet button this
image GIF this Emoji picker this pole
okay so we will also implement this
thing also this is a cool functionality
and we will try implement this this is
both this is scheduling so if you want
to schedule the Tweet you can do it yeah
so this is a kind of form we can for now
this is a division this is a division
inside it we have two divisions like
this so we can make it Flex column Flex
Flex column inside we have two divisions
this is a input box type of this input
is text and placeholder is what's
happening this has border of bottom
0.5 pixel and the powder color is gray
as as you can see we have already given
the Border color here so we don't need
to give it again and again now we have
this thing
so class name and we can make it w full
justify between item Center to make all
the divisions all the children division
to Center according to the Y axis
because this is a flex row okay so you
can give it Flex row now we have two
inside two divisions and this has all
the things like image icon GIF icon
Emoji picker all the things but we don't
need this thing now we can just skip
this for now and here we can define a
button or the button here and we can say
tweet and it is the similar button to
this thing so we can copy this whole
button for now the classes around it is
full opacity is cool everything is good
now let's see how it looks yeah so it is
looking cool for now now what we need to
do is this input field it knows looking
good so we have to give it some classes
W full H is full BG is transparent and
outline is none border is also save this
now you can see this is cool if we
remove this here this border is the
color border is not working so we have
to I think here also yeah and what we
need to do is we need to give some
padding to it so instead of giving this
thing here we can give it padding bottom
of four or the whole padding is four we
can remove this division round it is
full we can remove this margin for this
spreading is 4 is also a bit weird we
can give PX4 py of 2 W of full let's
give it Max with uh 400 pixel would work
I think okay it is bit much 40 pixel and
the text is bold phone is bold basically
text is 2XL node 2XL LG would work yeah
it is similar to Twitter we have our
button here cool now what is happening
and this is border is overflowing why is
that because I think we have some
mistake over here so let's find out this
is a flex this is also Flex what we can
do is we are giving it border bottom and
top yeah so we can make it Flex this is
flex this whole container is flex and
items are Center space between them is
two and now we need to give it with full
now it is similar to this but here we
need to do something we have to give it
Flex none so that the rounded full works
by default perfectly items not center
items start yeah items are start but we
have to
what about stretch so it will take the
whole Y axis instead of note taking the
advantage of full height and now we can
also give it some padding to Y 4 would
work so I think this is similar yeah we
need to also give some padding after
below the home so we can give it the
Mars into it yeah but as you can see we
have given some padding to it so this
border is not taking the full width so
instead of that what we can do here we
have another option so where we have
given py okay so here P6 so left and
right border P6 if I remove P6 yeah it
it is working
so what I think we can give it py if we
remove the whole P6 we need some padding
we need to give some padding to it so we
can give it here so we can give it PX or
4 now it is good and we need to also
give P 6 to it so we can give it P6 so
it is now looking much similar to the
Twitter you can see the sidebar this is
our home and this is looking good but we
need to make our placeholder look a bit
much bigger so we can design our
placeholder by doing this placeholder
colon and now we can give placeholder
classes so parlays folder is 2XL and
placeholder color is also a bit dark so
placeholder text Gray 800 about 600 yeah
it's similar now it's good you can type
here and instead of giving this whole
thing we can make it yeah so now if you
type something and you can tweet it good
cool now we have our page six but we
have given its a fixed height that's why
it is not working so what if we remove
the height
it is good so now as you can see we have
designed this tweet section now the time
to create the Twitter timeline here this
whole timeline so to design the Twitter
timeline we have to design the tweets
and then we can render them so let's
design this whole tweet so as you can
see first thing first it has stop in
bottom border and then it has some
padding author name username date when
it is published the Tweet text and the
image and video or GIF or something so
what we can do this is our division this
is home and now here we will render our
tweets class name Flex Flex column here
we can say array we can create a fake
array area Dot from the length of let's
give it length of 5 for now dot map
tweet this will create a array of five
length in which each item has undefined
as its value so now we can render a
division as a tweet so key is I which is
index now we can give it top and bottom
border we can give it padding good yeah
so you can see it has a icon here so you
can assume like this is a flex container
the whole container then we have this
container two containers are here first
one is this hole and second one is this
what I'm saying is this is our tweet
inside tweet we have two containers
first one is for the Avatar this
division we have the Avatar here and
another division is this inside this we
have the name here and then the username
here and then the text here and then the
image or all the things here this is how
it works first thing first we will
Define two divisions first second inside
we have author these are in the flex row
Direction inside we have in the column
Direction first one is row second one is
text and third one is image or any media
file so let's go so we can say Flex we
can give some SpaceX of 4 and inside it
we have two reasons first division is
Avatar only so here we can make another
division class name wtain S10 BG slate
200 and that's all we need rounded full
here we have three divisions first
second third two into three first
division has three divisions three
divisions I'm if you are using vs code
this all will work Auto completion and
you can how it is working so I am typing
du into three and then it is giving me
auto completion if I hit Control Plus
space on my Mac keyboard Control Plus
space and if I hit enter this is emit
abbreviation and it will work like that
so it is a name so we can say Club of
coders this is my username Club of
Hoarders and this is one hour ago like
this as you can see programmer humor
programmer humor and this is also we
have a DOT here so we have four
divisions okay so we have four divisions
and here we have a DOT so PS dot just
like it and all these four things are in
Flex column not Flex column Flex row so
we can give with flex item Center space
of X of 2 of 1 1 will work so this is
our first one the second one is text so
we can give its low Ram of let's assume
100 this is a bit much the two it can be
this much longer I think yeah
so this is what we text it is text white
text small and that would work this is
flex column by the way Flex column let's
give some y space to every children and
it will work here we have all the media
file so for the media as for now I will
just render a square thing so I will say
BG of slate of 400 aspect is square W
full height I will give let's give it 96
96 would be good and that's all yeah we
can make it rounded 2 XL or Excel would
work this is media and now here we have
all these things comment retweet like
stats and the share button so five
things we have here so five division
first one is comment second one is
retweet we will select each icon for
that now we have like now we have States
and here we have share and these all
icons are in Flex row Direction and we
have item Center we will give space of X
of 2 we can give it to be full and
that's how we have designed the single
tweet and it should be rendering
whiteweight for us and now let's go and
now you can see all the twists are being
rendered over here cool but we have to
tweak a few things for now we have to
give it the padding of Y axis so here we
are giving padding X we also we need to
give padding of Y so now it is good you
can see this over tweets we need to also
do something we need to make it bold
this text should be bold so here what we
can do we can make it Port font bold and
that's good as you can see these borders
are not looking good why because we are
giving each tweet top and bottom border
which is not needed so to remove that we
only need to give it only top now you
can see we are only giving the top
border not giving the bottom and we can
also keep it bottom border yeah now it
works it works but the problem is if
let's let's remove this for now and you
will see what is happening here so we
have this border that's why we are not
giving border of top here we will give
border of bottom so this tutorial
contain the border of here then here and
then here so it will work so save this
and it is good but we have to give it
the exact color which we want save this
and now it is looking good it is good
now what we need when we try to scroll
this this home should be fixed to the
top for that what we can do we can give
it blur we can not blur back BG plus
backdroper basically backdropular and PG
white of 10 and we need to make it fixed
or we can make it sticky to the top top
now you can see this is sticky and this
is backdrop blur you can see if we
remove this let's give it black 10. now
it's good yeah now it is sticky the home
part is sticky to the top always
remember to q a top bottom left right
any position while using a sticky
position you need to give some position
to it while using sticky otherwise the
SDK Position will not work like this you
can see the space is bit too much for
now so we can reduce the space so what
we can do here the Border bottom P4
space axis 4 which is good but space yo4
is not needed 2 will work now it is good
so now what I will do I will select the
icons for each of the thing comment like
and all the things I will go to here and
I will find all the icons I am finding
if some icon is looking similar to the
Twitter one but yeah it is looking good
so I will go here this is your comment
icon let's import this this is a retweet
search yeah we have a repeat icon import
this from react icon slash AI this is
our like which is like this will work
this is the share icon no this is the
state cycle so we can search States
let's import this and the last icon we
need is share icon which is yeah kind of
like this import all of them and it is
good to go I think what we can do here
instead of item Center space we can make
it justify around so it will take the
full width and stretch all over the
width you can see it is instead of this
what about justify around what about
evenly you can try whichever looks good
I would go for just if I start and Space
X of 8 more space X of 20 24 20 would
work now I need to give it extra of Y2
it will not work let's give everyone M
by 2 and let's give M by 1 and it will
also my one yeah it is good M by three
how about M by three I need to give some
space to it it is not working why is
that because we have given this m space
of Y yeah now it is good so what we can
do we can give it the top instead of
full my we can give it also M term 2
yeah it is actually good and whenever we
hover these icons there should be a nice
looking around it full let's give it
this this parent round it full and BG's
black 10 20. let's go for 24 now and
only when we have hover this otherwise
don't make it look so let's try this
also make it like
cursoris pointer so it is not looking
how about 50 yeah we need to give some
padding to it now if we hover it is
visible now you can see this is looking
good so I would go for 30 20 actually go
for 10 as we did here 15 10 would work
and that's cool we can make a transition
and the duration is 200. good now I
think we don't need to queue the PMT two
will work cool it's good and we will
copy this classes and we will paste to
each of the division instead of doing
this we can define a component and we
can render this icons but for now we are
just doing this in the future we can fix
our organization part so as you can see
we have designed our timeline section
for our Twitter there is three dots
which is not visible and the text is
also a bit larger so instead of text SM
how about going with large yeah this is
actually good or just stick to the base
and this is the curriculum username is
text Gray
this whole thing is gray basically so we
can remove this okay paste this class
here also and here also yeah it is
looking good and now we have our tweet
timeline section but we also forget to
make this three I can see here this
thing we also need this three dots so we
will wrap the whole thing cut it inside
a division and there is another division
which is PS3 dots we need to give these
classes to this espresso effects don't
need it here and it is good we can make
it full width we can give it full width
okay so note this thing okay so I think
I have included it here so this bs3 dots
should be outside this division here
save this now you can see this is at the
end and now we can also give some
padding to it so to give it some padding
what we need to do is how much bedding
we are giving it so let's see P4 so we
need to give some more padding to it how
about be it
p y 4 and P x 6 it is not working as
expected it's good I think because we
have given it fixed width that's why it
is not working where it was so as you
can see we have given it fixed width so
if you remove this whole thing if you
remove this now you can see this is
taking a hell lot of width and what you
can do here we can make it full with but
you can Define some Maximum width let's
go for 512 pixel or a bit more Excel a
bit more to excel would work yeah now
it's good because the image we have used
we have given it 384 pixel and this is
672 pixel and now it is looking good it
is a bit bigger than the Twitter but
yeah I think we have to follow the tutor
convention which is 600 pixel and we can
make it smaller 80. now it is good cool
so it is looking perfect now now we need
to design the right sidebar so here as
you can see this is what we have
designed as for now so we can cut this
thing and we can make a new file which
is main component rafce
paste here so these all are server
components because if you want to use
clients components you have to put use
client here like this because we are
using next year's 13 words so if you are
defining use client then it is a client
component if you are not saying anything
then it is by default server component
so we will import everything we will
save this main component we will import
this here cool now we have to design
override section so this is also a fixed
width so fixed now we need to give it
something it is also Flex Flex column
and space of Y of let's give it 4.
inside we have three sections you can
see this is our search bar this is
trending section and this is who to
follow section so this has three
divisions first one is search bar so we
can say input text so the type of this
input is text and the placeholder is
search tutor let's give some class names
it doesn't have any border but it has
this search icon so to keep this search
icon what we need to do is we need to
wrap this whole thing inside another
Division and we will give it relative
class W is full height is full and we
also give it w of full height of full
and we will give it rounded Excel and
the other thing we need to give it a
spading of let's give it four and now we
will Define search icon here we will
find a search icon so we can find the
search icon this PS search I can looks
good to me yeah it is looking good so I
will import this and I will make it
absolute and we need to also Center this
alongside the y-axis so we will create
another division inside we have this
search icon and it is taking let's give
it W5 H5 text is gray of 400 let's give
it 500 okay so this is a relative and
this is absolute division
absolute division this is absolute with
respect to this division so that we can
move it around anywhere and we will now
give it top 0 and we will make it high
to full we'll make it Flex we can Center
it that's how we are centering this
thing to here so as you can see this is
the icon let's go here so I will make
you understand what I am doing here so
this is our relative parent container so
this is our relative parent container
and we are saying that we have division
which is absolute so this is absolute
Division and we are saying the position
of this absolute division is top 0 and
right zero this means this absolute
division which means this is the
absolute division we have absolute
Division and this absolute division has
the position of top 0 and right 0 means
top left which means the position of
this division is top left and that's how
it will take this whole height and after
it is taking the whole light we are
saying that everything inside it we want
to Center so we will Define a icon and
we want to center it that's why we are
giving it flat and item Center and we
will also give justify Center to make it
Center and that's how it will work cool
now we have done this we can also give
it some padding but as for now let's
proceed with it and let's see what is
happening we will also give outline is
null BG is also transparent and border
is also save this and let's see how it
is looking so you can see this is our
search so this is right zero we instead
want left zero so now you can see it is
centered but we also need to give some
extra padding to x axis so we can say
the py is 4 good but we want p x to be 6
or let's go for it now it's good and
what we can do instead of division we
can make it level and we can give it
html4 search box and we can give it ID
of search box so whenever someone clicks
on this thing it will focus on the input
so that's how we have designed this
whole thing so this is fixed as you can
see and we will make it right zero so
that it will stick to the right as you
can see we need to give similar kind of
classes to this because as you can see
we want it after this thing for that we
will see what we are doing we are giving
it a fix with so that's what we have to
do here we can give it a fixed width to
this section instead of write 0 we can
give it fixed with okay so and H of
screen now let's see let's copy all the
things because this is the similar thing
we need so the problem is we want this
to be right for that I think we can give
it margin of left Auto this has a width
of 275 pixel that's that's okay but if
we go for right 0 then it will stick to
the far right but we don't want that for
that the other thing we can do is this
is relative we can make it absolute and
now if we save this you can see this is
here we can cut this thing and if you
series is relative and we if we make it
border of let's say 4 and now you can
see this is to the left here but let's
also make it something and remove this
thing and give it border border of Four
but we are missing something and I want
let's give it this left sidebar also the
absolute and left zero
cool and now give it this main component
with full where is this maximum width
just give it with full it will take the
full width instead of it will also take
this width okay so why we need to make
sure that
it doesn't take more than this centered
width for that we have to do some fixes
here okay
so these are both absolute division okay
so there is one thing we can do yeah
there is one thing we can do remove
everything related to the position we
can make it simple container a relative
container like this WSC w275 pixel left
sidebar this is already good we can
remove this part save this now we can
also remove this whole thing now if you
save this you can see we have these
three sections first one is this
division second one is this Division and
third one is this search bar so now we
need to make sure that this main
component doesn't take more than 600
pixel Max width can be 600 pixel now
it's good so it is taking more than
which so I think we have to decrease
some decrease this instead of LG yeah I
would go for LG but it is not good so LG
is
1024 pixels so I would go for 1100 pixel
okay Max with 1100 pixel or how about 80
VW which means 80 of the viewport let's
go 70 of
it's good then what we need to do we
need to queue according to the width not
with full but we can give it like this
is taking let's assume this is hundred
percent then this is checking 30 this is
taking 30 and the remaining is just 30
30 60 and this is 40. we can do that so
what we can do we can say with his main
component is 60 and the left sidebar has
the width of 30 percent and the
remaining section has the width of 30
percent yeah it's good but still it's
not looking perfect we have to decrease
some of the left High PX of 6 we don't
need the p x x here PX of 4 would work
and let's go for twenty percent yeah
it's good so this is 20 percent this is
also 20 percent now this should be 30
yeah it's good now but the problem is
with this the problem we are facing I am
seeing that this is not this is too much
of fading here we are giving so I don't
think we should give it padding here we
don't want to get the padding here yeah
it's good now it is looking perfect okay
as you can see it is looking good this
is good this is good but this is a bit
of weird so to fix this thing we can fix
this here so what okay so don't give
margin four yeah it's fixed
now you can see because we are giving it
margin it was not looking good so it is
exactly like similar to Twitter s for
now I think the 30 25
and 25 and let's give it 50. okay 30 is
bit too much for this left side but 20
20 is like perfect how about 23 yeah
it's good 23 is good 23 is good and the
main component should take the 50 that's
also good and the remaining one is this
with full this is with full now now it's
good now it's perfect okay so we have
designed this whole thing so now you can
see this is not stickiest so to make
this sticky what we can do instead of
before we are giving the fixed now we
can give it sticky so we can say this is
sticky to the Top This is sticky and we
can say top zero and the same thing we
can do for the left sidebar now the the
main component is not a sticky the left
side virus so now you can see this is
sticky for us okay so this is also
sticky this is we need to make sure this
that this is also sticky yeah now the
both sidebars are sticky you can see
this is also sticky this is also sticky
and this is scrollable so this is the
similar Behavior to our Twitter as you
can see here now we can remove the
border which we have given to these
divisions to debug our television CSS
now it is good okay so it is now looking
absolutely dope now we need to give some
gray to the border and for the icon so
where we were in the main component
close both the components here we are so
we can give the background is not
transparent it is actually some grayish
background gray of 400 okay 400 is not
good it is Greece or neutral I think it
is neutral neutral neutral 900 is yeah
you can see this is much better and 800
would work okay so 900 and let's opacity
is 990 yeah it is good it is good we
will proceed with it now as you can can
see this is the search icon is looking a
little bit weird so to fix this we can
give it some padding so this is our
division which is relative so what we
can do we can give it some padding note
here this is absolute division we can
give it some padding before it looks
good now but we also need to make sure
that we fix the PX so instead of p x we
can give it P left of 10 and the P right
is 4 by default let's make it 14 and
also instead of top 0 I would say yeah
it's good but I will give some margin to
top P4 yeah and now you can make it to 4
so it will be sticky yeah you can see
this is now good looking good okay so
now it works Forest a bit too much so I
would go for two yeah it works so now as
you can see we have designed our search
when we click on this input button now
it is focused and it is showing us a
blue border so we will also make this
effect so to do that when it is active
or I I think it is when it is focused
make the border border we need a border
and the border is primary focus border
is yeah now if we click this the Border
doesn't look okay so you press this
first now the border is not looking so
board it is primary and the border is
let's give it powder okay so we are
giving border none that's why it is not
working here now it will work so when we
click this this is blue border and when
we focus this border should be two now
you can see it looks good not one by
default the border border will work okay
it looks better now we have our also we
can group this whole thing what I am
saying is we can group this whole thing
this whole division we can group it by
using this group class and now we can
change this color also this search icon
color also so we can say group over when
this is group O or not over when this is
group Focus we can say the text of this
icon is primary and now it should it
should work okay it is not working
because yeah so to make this work we
have to use some JavaScript so we can
skip this part or we can use some peer
classes I think we can use some peer
classes there is something I think peer
peers first peer focus and then text of
primary it may work okay some something
is Pure Glass Delvin before and after
there is some class which I think we can
make it work you can say group hover
thing works but we want when the item
which is nearby is forecast to do
something okay so here it is so we will
Define a peer class here we will say
this is over here and when it is focused
it is visible you can say when it is
invalid visible this cool so now I think
it will work save this
okay so it is not looking how this works
so let's see here again this is input
which has period class and now we are
using peer invalid visible won't work
only previous sibling can Mark SPL okay
so we have to we have to make it like
this only previous siblings which means
it won't work it will work like now this
over this is our input and this is over
and you can see okay so this is our
input and this A P tag which is when it
is invalid make it visible here it is
saying that we have a span and this is
our input so if this is before this this
will not work now we have after this
only previous siblings can be marked as
peer okay cool now it is not still
working okay so what's the problem
let's try this for a simple other state
so we can say this is a P tag class name
peer Focus then make it visible
otherwise it is invisible hello world
okay you can see when we click this it
is visible otherwise it is not and we
want the same behavior for our text part
which is this but it is not working why
is that let's see yeah it is working now
because the problem was we are giving a
text Gray and we are saying that text is
primary so it will not work because
Telvin CSS will mark this class as a
priority so this will be note our
priority that's why it is it was not
working now if you remove this from here
now this classes will be applied to this
thing save this and now you can see our
thing is working without any JavaScript
this is directly using Telvin CSS and it
is so cool okay so this was the part I
didn't know before and I just learned
this thing now with you okay so this is
so cool now we will Design This what's
happening part okay so here is our
training section part so it is also Flex
Flex column that's all say we have S3
and copy this thing over here what's
happening and now here we can Define all
things here we can define a division
inside division we have array Dot from
another fake array we will create let's
we have five trending things for now and
we will map through them item and we
will say division key is and here as you
can see this item it is by default
undefined because it's a fake array so
we can get the index for now and we can
say trending item first like this now we
have to design so this is a neutral
color again so here we will say border
not border round it is Excel BG is
neutral um 900 and this is a bold text
font is bold text is to Excel and wise
for now it's looking good how about if
we make it 800 no how about 950 no how
about 50 I think 900 is good for now we
can give it some padding as well yeah
also we can give it margin and Y of 4
cool and now we can design a this
section this section okay so this is a
hashtag and Below we have number of
tests so we have two divisions div into
two hit enter and here we can say
trending item this instead of this we
can say hashtag trending I plus one and
here are the number of tweets this
hashtag contents so how is this visible
okay 35.8 K so let's go with this
35.8 okay this has the color of grayish
and this is bold last name font bold
text large this is text is small text of
gray save this and let's see how it is
looking okay so it is it is also note
gray I think it is neutral and we will
make it 400 yeah it's good forehand will
do the work and if we hover over
everything there is some background so
we can also do that
last name over BG white of 10 save this
and now if you hover over this this is
good but the padding we don't want to
give to the whole container we only want
to give it to this and we can give the
padding to it now you can see we are
good to go but here rounded Excel we
also need to give this thing rounded
Excel to the last element when this is
last a rounded Excel rounded bottom we
can say rounded bottom and we can say
Excel now when it is last item it is
rounded you can see it's look good it's
good and what's happening is 2XL is bit
much and Y can be 2 B4 can be 2 PX PX
can be four it is good okay so now you
can see this is our trending section and
it's good okay we only need this thing
now it is good we can give it some
transition so that it looks smooth
transition and other thing we need to
give it a situation now it is smooth a
bit okay so now we have designed
make another division here another fake
array 4 dot map key is I and this is who
to follow same thing so we can copy the
S3 here okay so we can copy the whole
thing here basically we can copy the
whole thing not from here yeah the full
because this is exactly and with some
modifications this is not here we were
doing some wrong instead of what's
Happening we can say who to Let's copy
this how to follow save this and let's
see now you can see we can the part is
we only need to make this part sticky
not the whole sidebar so we can come
here and we can say this only division
is sticky otherwise these both are screw
level now you can see sticky and The
Cone they are gone or I think there is
another hack let's make this sticky top
zero it is not working because the
parent content is flex and it doesn't
work like that so I think if we keep it
fixed it will not work it will take the
whole width that's why let's give it 25
percent now we can adjust the right
um 40 yeah now it is good
but we are facing the same problem which
means we are not able to scroll this
thing so for that we were doing
perfectly before so what I mean w full
sticky and top two is good what we need
to do is Overflow scroll we just need to
give it overflow scroll so it is also a
screw level it is fixed but it is also
scrollable now you can see we can also
scroll this part and we can also scroll
this part cool now we have to just
Define this it is a avatar this is a
name this is a username and this is a
follow-on follow button so we will do
that thing this is the same thing we
need we will give it Flex make item
Center and here we have three divisions
first division is Avatar class name
W10 S10 BG let's keep it neutral rounded
is full and that's all we need here and
this is a class name Plex Flex column
and we have space y of 2 this has two
divisions first one is name which is
other user and this is the username of
the user one two three four okay and now
this is a four one follow button so we
will Design this button also so this is
basically a button so we can wrap this
button inside a button component or a
button element class name rounded is
full PX 6 p y is 2 BG white text is
neutral 150 save this thing and let's
see how it looks yeah it is much similar
to the tutor one now we need to do some
fixes here we don't need this space okay
number one thing we have fixed now we
need some space of X here now it's good
or let's give it four now it's good and
we have to make it bolded and white this
thing last name font bold text white we
need to give you text Gray and text is
small it's better yeah so I think it is
good but we need the follow this button
to the at the end so what we can do
margin of left Auto this is a hex
sometimes this works and let's give it
with full now it only works when margin
of right now or this no we can make it
Flex none it's good I think okay so
instead of doing this what we can do we
can make them justify evenly or around
what do you think okay so this is the P4
which is causing the problem now we can
say justify around
no
this is good I think but we want to make
this follow button to the left so for
that we can use that again what is that
heck wrap this whole rep these divisions
to a another Division and wherever we
this is this board save this first so
you can see these both divisions are
into this Division and now we can say
justify between and it will work save
this and now we need to give it Flex
item Center space x 2 okay justify
between Flex item Center everything is
looking good okay the problem was you
can remove this division yeah now it is
at the end now you can see this is also
looking perfect so now we have created
the left sidebar we have created the
main section this is our Twitter and we
have also created the trending section
the who to follow section all these
sticky fixed positions are these things
are working so as you can see here I am
in the folder and the app is running
this is a database diagram I have
designed so first let's see how our app
is looking so you can see this is our
Twitter clone and it is looking
absolutely top it is exactly similar to
Twitter and it is awesome now this is
our Twitter database diagram I am using
this DB diagram website and you can use
it too so as you can see we are defining
table user has all the things related
like username email other things so user
can have multiple tweets this pins user
to tweet is a relationship of one to
many relationship but a tweet can be
only authored by one user that's why
author ID is string which is this and
this is how we Define reference or we
can say the relationship in this DB
diagram website so don't worry about
this thing I will share this thing with
you you can just see that a user can
have multiple tweets as you can see this
is multiple this is one so one too many
between user to tweet a tweet can have
multiple hashtags a tweet can have
multiple hashtags and a hashtag can also
have multiple tweets so this is many to
many relationship between tweet and
history now a tweet can be liked by
multiple authors so we can say a tweet
can have multiple likes and it also
connected to user a like his user ID
Intuit ID so this is how we are saying
that a tweet can have multiple likes and
a tweet can also have multiple bookmarks
and a user can also have multiple
bookmarks so this is how it is working
so this is our bookmark table and
bookmark table also have ID user ID
Twitter tweet ID created it if you are
having hard time understanding this
don't worry when we start coding this
part you will understand it better and
that's how it works and now this is our
reply a reply is just a like of tweet so
when a user replied to a tweet we will
save some text with the Tweet ID because
why we are saving the Tweet ID in the
reply row because we want to know where
this reply is related this reply is
related to which tweet that's why we
need a tweet ID so we can fetch all
replies of a tweet by saying that qumi
database give me all the replies of this
tweet ID then we will have all the
replies of a tweet but if a user is
replying to a reply that's why we are
saving a reply area also so here when we
will Define this it can be null so you
can visit the DB diagram you can see DB
diagram syntax and you can find out how
I have written this whole thing reply
identity both are optional both are
optional so here this is a dbml language
basically so this is the whole syntax of
dvml language you can see how we are
defining menu to one relationship
between these and how we are doing all
this stuff you can also share the node
or the save the node like this if you
write this and if you look at the reply
you will find the store user this is the
note we don't need we just need to
understand what we are storing in the
database so first thing first this is a
text VR showing the username when this
tweet is created who is posted this to
it and the likes bookmarks and other
things and here you can see nod null if
this is the username is like this if the
username is we want to be node null then
we can justify it like that note null
and unique so we can copy this thing and
we can say in the users table here we
can say it is not null and unique we can
also Define the default like 10 now and
all the things you can read this which
is on the DB diagram.io talks slash dbml
and you can click this link to see all
the syntax to write this database design
okay so now we have understood what is
our data now we will use share gbt to
build a query for us because I don't
want to manually create all the data
inside our database so what I am saying
is if we go to superbase if I sign in
now I can see this is Ultimate Twitter
clone and here I have this is a SQL
editor and here this is how you define
tables we can also go to this database
and we can insert table like this but we
have to do this all of manually and I
don't want we want our productivity to
be highest so for that we have to
leverage the chair gbt you can see all
the things are given here this is for
storage this is for Edge functions Super
Bass is awesome I think and we will use
this now so let's visit jgpt and build
the query so I will now open my another
Chrome so now I will open my another
Chrome tab here so this is changeivity
and I will tell it that qma the query
and I have already designed the DB so
you can follow me just so I'm using zpd
3.5 the default so here is my database I
will copy this and I will tell it give
me post to create all tables and the
dbml for those and use this dbm for the
context like this and we will give it
and now we'll it will you can see this
is this has given us all the tables like
this this is how much easier to use
cheer gbt for us to write SQL now you
can see ID you guid username email this
is good and I think it is nice all the
primary Keys foreign yeah it's good also
I have renamed the like table with
quotes like okay so what we can do we
can use likes instead of this and if you
visit this the database SQL editor
create table you can see this is how it
works ID begin generated by default is
identity primary key set at it I'm
starting with time zone default UTC not
null we will copy something from it and
we will modify according to us so let's
copy all this and we will modify
according to our need so user for the
user I think in the here I think we have
something
use management instructor profiles yeah
this is what I want so this will
reference to overthrow users table and
it will delete a user from our database
when this is deleted from superbase auth
table this is for the row level policies
this is handle news when a new user sign
up for a new account for on our website
then this function will be automatically
triggered and this will save a username
into our table this is setting up all
the yeah so we just need this thing this
one this one and this one this three
things we need for now let's copy in the
SQL editor here so instead of this user
I will say user ID uuid primary key yeah
so we need username text unique we can
use text inside postgres where care 255
is required for SQL so here yeah the ID
we need ID updated username full name
full name okay full name is stored in
oath Road users table also I think if
you use Google sign in then it is not
required also this is not required
constrained username length this is good
we just need one thing here username and
it it should be unique and that's all we
need for our profiles we can say our
users now this is a function which will
create a trigger and it will
automatically insert a username now we
don't need author so it will values new
DOT ID new DOT Ray row user metadatized
username so it will insert ID and
username into our table like this insert
into this table values are this and
return new it will be automatically
triggered and we will pass the metadata
from our front end when the user signs
up for a new account cool this is
profile now yeah the uuid cool updated
timestamp with time zone and we can
utilize this here yeah so it will be
default to now now we can remove this
because we have utilized this whole
thing these are rollable security
policies we will see all the Securities
at the last first we will Design or we
will build our whole application or
whole web application then you will see
if anything wrong with the security part
and we will improve our security for our
web application okay so trigger on Earth
user created it will be triggered each
row execute processor public dot yeah
now we have a tweet uuid it is a primary
key so for that yeah it is also primary
key reference so I think it's good see
it is ID where care instead of where
care I think we can directly use string
or not string text author IDs text
created a timestamp now we need to do
one thing over here testing default
notable this whole thing copy this for
the timestamp one part we will do this
yeah this is hashtag okay tweet ID uuid
okay this is also good you can use
capitalize or small case both will work
that's not a problem here primary key is
good foreign key yeah this is for
reference tweet hashtag so this is
another table which means a tweet can
have multiple hashtag and a hashtag in
your multiple tweets so it will store
tweet ID and hashtag ID and the primary
key is both tweet ID and hashtag ID and
it will reference to the table in tweet
and hashtag the id id field the
reference is ID field yeah and the reply
is also like that user ID this is good
create table like so now we can do one
thing instead of saying like we can do
likes we can say replies instead of
tweets instead of Twitter you can say
tweets this is better not here we can
various to it tweet hashtag is good
tweets hashtags this is better
programming practice to name your table
like that tweets instead of tweet this
is hashtag stable this is tweet hashtag
yeah this is fine now it replies this is
good
here just tweets so be careful by doing
all these things tweet ID user ID reply
ID this is fine now we have likes so
likes is good we don't need to use the
double quotes but it will be fine if you
use or not use here user ID code code no
so instead of users we are saying
profiles so here you can see so instead
of user everywhere instead of user we
will say profiles ID profiles here also
profiles SEO tweets so we will we will
have to instead of bookmark we will say
bookmarks The Bookmark should be unique
that's why we are saying that constraint
bookmark is unique unique user identity
it is good like should be also unique a
user why this is unique because a user
can like a post one time and a user can
bookmark a post one time that's why we
will save only one record in our
database that a user is liked or
bookmarked a post we will not allow a
user to like or bookmark multiple times
or in the other words to save multiple
rows inside over DB for one thing so
user ID this is good okay so let's check
again one time so we have profiles this
is looking good we have this trigger
function which will save a username into
our database every time a new user is
created this is our tweets table this is
our hashtag Stables this is a table
which will Define a relationship between
tips and hashtags table so this is
streets and this is hashtags like this
cool now we have replies profiles tweets
replies cool now we have likes this is
also we are yeah Astro tweets we have
tweets okay so this is good that's all
the table we need and now we can run
this query and over all functions our
tables will be created so click on run
and it will be fail to run okay so let's
see what is the problem here so it is
saying that foreign user ID foreign key
cannot be implemented so in the replies
so where it is here
so it is primary kit text is text okay
so here we will say that it can be null
okay so for that it is null or node null
so if it can't be null then we have to
define or we have to say normal
otherwise we can just skip null part
yeah so now here we can say not null
like this this is also notal a tweet
must contain text here also this should
be not null okay tweet hashtag tweet ID
hashtag this is good not null not now
good here also we will say not null here
user ID can't be null but tweet ID or
replied both can be null so we will ask
here jgpt that okay so let's first run
again it and then we will see what is
happening so this is yeah this is also
not null this is also not null here is
timestamps we will use this whole thing
here again let's run it again and we
will see what is happening so we will
ask this error to change GPT so that it
will fix this for us
let's see
now it is updated over so I will give it
my new this whole query I am saying that
find any problem with this okay so it
will say your modify query looks mostly
correct but there is a couple of issues
that I spotted in the replies table the
foreign key constraint tweet ID
reference to tweet stable instead of
tweet Stables ID column oh that's the
problem so you can see how we can
utilize this to increase our
productivity okay so what's the problem
in the bookmark table okay you should
change this to foreign key to it ID so
it is a foreign key okay so we are
saying which is a foreign key let's copy
this thing if we can see the difference
between the thing share gbt given us
okay so this is uuid cool usernal tweet
ID now let's remove this and we will run
it again it replies user ID foreign
cannot be implemented so I think it is
mostly because of this line because yeah
applies uuid okay user ID note null okay
now how about it likes okay okay now it
is working so what we have did is likes
user ID foreign key so this is likes
these both are uuid we are saying that
these are text that's why it is showing
us the problem author ID call a tweet a
profile or we can say a tweet can have
multiple users a tweet oh no a tweet
can't have multiple a user can have or
we can say a profile can have multiple
tweets fix the TV according to this and
also fix any error now it will create a
foreign key like that author ID and
profile ID that's we need previously we
don't have any foreign key or relation
between date and user now we have a
foreign key author ID and profile ID
yeah but we don't need author and
profile two things we okay it can be
just only one so profile ID remove this
author thing here
now it's good now we will run this and
we will see if it is working or not
let's try invalid SQL okay so we have
did some mistake here what can be the
mistake
okay
success now it is successfully run and
we will see if it works as we want so
first of all we will go to home in the
tables now we have seven tables
bookmarks let's see that bookmark have
ID user ID tweet ID created it that's
what we want first of all we will see
profiles profile says ID updated
username full name okay good replies
this is good reply ID tweet ID user ID
everything looking good and now we
should also have a trigger if we if you
click on a trigger these are our tables
and if you click on a trigger here you
can see when the user is created we have
a handle new user trigger which will
insert a username to our profiles tables
this one we can do all these things
webhooks functions and we will utilize
this according to our need you just saw
how we have used shared GPT to create
SQL query for us and to fix the error
and all these things okay and if you
want this code let me just create a note
here this one I will copy this whole
thing and I will create a GitHub guest
so this is DB design dot for ultimate
Twitter clone just like it I will create
a public just and that's all and I will
share it with you I will put this into
my readme file database I will save this
for now I haven't committed or pushed to
GitHub let's let me push that so okay so
you can follow along and you can find
all the code let me also create a GitHub
repository now the code is live on my
profile you can visit Sony prinjel on
GitHub and you will find the repository
here it is public repository and you can
find it you can follow along and here is
the code which we have used for our
supervis so now we have also
accomplished our database part now what
we will do I will put this whole section
into another component which is the
right section so I in the components new
file right
body of CE I will press the whole thing
here and this save this and I will
import this here good to go now if you
visit localhost 3000 you can see this is
our application and it is running on
Port 3000 and this is all the code you
can find all the code in the description
there is a link to GitHub and we are
going to use this Library called UI dot
sharedcn.com it is a great Library it
has a lot of components and we can use
these components instead of building
that on our own to increase our
productivity and to not reinvent the
wheel again and again so as you can see
currently we only have the Telvin CSS
installed so to install this UI Library
we just have to follow all the things so
if you want to create a directly
repository or you can say a fully
fledged next.js product with this UI
Library you can directly use this
command but we have already installed
all the things so we have to manually
install this Library so first of all we
will install this uh and beam packages
so we are using pnpm so I will open a
new terminal and I will install all of
these things so this is for icons Telvin
merge is used for merging the Tailwind
classes and I will explain you what it
is later clsx is also for merging
classes and it's kind of like if you
want to use logical classes or if you
want to like assume if you are doing
something and if something went wrong or
the error occurs and you want to render
a button color to Red based upon a logic
then you have to use some JavaScript for
your Telvin classes so instead of using
JavaScript so instead of doing Curly
braces and these brackets and all these
things you can directly use CL SX and
you can Define logical class names for
reverse element CSS here we have class
variance Authority it is for defining
variants for your components like if you
have a button which is primary the
button danger button or info button
Etc and television animate is just a
plugin now we will see how to proceed we
have already defined this path so now if
you open
tsconfig.json you can see we have
defined our paths here so we can instead
of relatively importing we can directly
import using this so our Imports will
not look ugly so now we will config our
Telvin CSS here yeah so we will copy
everything inside the Tailwind config so
where it is here we will use this so
control plus a control plus v so you can
see container Center this all the things
are defined for us already and these are
the colors you can see the radius the
Border radius and the primary color
secondary color all the things
cool and now here you can Define all the
colors so if you want to change any
color or theming in the future you can
do that so inside the Styles slash
Global CSS control plus a control plus v
and these all the colors are being used
here you can see variable primary
foreground and these are the colors so
we are good to go for now but as you can
see we have defined a color which is
primary color which is our blue color so
we will use that color here what I am
saying is if you control press Z here a
few times this is the color this is the
tutor color we have used so copy this
color Control Plus shift plus Z now if
you if we save this we need this color
everywhere so for the here you can see
how to customize theme according to you
so here is our theming section and we
will see how to use this so given the
following this is primary and this is
primary foreground okay so here
background is good card primary so
primary color is this this is the color
we are going to use primary color and
primary foreground is black so we will
just use hashtag zero zero zero and it
will work okay and we will see if it
won't work we can change it anytime
later so now we have defined all the
things now we have to do one thing more
we have to Define this helper this will
combine the CLS X and the Telvin merge
both days into one and we will use this
so copy this into a source directory
create a new folder called library
inside the Library create a folder
called what we can say it utils.ts
okay and save this now it is good to go
so in this Library we are using the
Lucid icon Library so you can use any
you want but we will use both and
basically we have created our layout so
probably we don't need anything for now
so now in the components we have to
create a new folder called UI in the UI
we can now copy and paste a lot of
components from here so first of all we
need a dialog or we can say a model so
that we can utilize our authentication
for that so if you have previously used
tutor so if you are not logged in then
it won't allow us to view anything and
it asks us to First authenticate
ourselves so that's how we are going to
make this application flow first a user
have to authenticate themselves then
they can proceed and now as we can see
everything is good but for now let's
Control Plus close the terminal and
restart everything so it will work pnpm
rundev now visit your application
refresh this you can see the Telvin all
the classes are gone why is that let's
see maybe because if you delete the next
folder here and that's that's the
problem restart the server refresh the
page sometime this hack works but okay
so this is not working so something is
not defined correctly okay so this is
the problem we have a source directory
so instead of directly saying you can
say Source slash go into the app
directory and find all the TS and TSX
files find all the Telvin class names
and use those for classes so instead of
this we can directly say go into the
source directory and find all the
folders and do all the things save this
thing now it should work yeah now you
can see this is working but something is
weird why is that because we have
configured our Telvin CSS and the font
is also looking a bit weird so first of
all we will improve our color and our
font yeah so this font is looking ugly
so these are the colors this border
radius phone families font sense okay so
I don't want it I want okay Acer default
default should be sense and it is good
now it is the font is looking good the
first thing we have fixed the text color
should be so if we go into here we can
say text should be white always now it
is good text is white and this tweet
button is not looking good so we have to
make it look good so in the left sidebar
where is our button here is over button
okay so we are not giving okay so the
primary color is not defined that's the
problem so here instead of doing this
here colors ring foreground primary yeah
it should work so let's see the problem
PG primary foreground yeah so the BG
primary color is not working which is
this color which is this variable the
primary variable so we will find this
variable where it is and we will fix
this thing
this variable doesn't need this RGB this
variable needs hsl format so we can
search RGB to hsl so we will 29 155 to
40 29 155 to 45 to 40 and that's good
this is the hex and this is the hsl so I
want a easy converter where it is color
converter yeah this is good so I will
copy this thing and now I will copy the
hsl format
I don't know but this is unless I don't
like this this background also is not so
we will we have to change this from
yeah now it should work you can see this
is working so the problem was we were
using hsl format here to convert these
variables into a hsl from it then we are
using this that's why we have to Define
this I don't like this approach I would
go for directly the color approach the
hex color that always works but for now
we can skip the part because we have
done all the things our background is
working okay and the thing is if we go
here the BG is black cool but why it is
not showing any color here yeah it is
showing it's showing now so if you
remove this text white let's see so the
text is not by default white so for that
we have to again modify something into
the colors input color all these things
we have to modify border input ring okay
so what we can do we can ask chair jbt
to give us all the colors for Twitter
because the chair gbt already knows the
GitHub colors so I think it should work
because it is too much hard work to
Define every color and I don't want you
to get into that for now so we can ask
we can ask Jr GPT to use Twitter colors
and modify this file this code
accordingly so now it is given us the
Twitter code you to use Twitter colors
yeah it's good I have replaced hsl
values with respective codes for Twitter
node that use hsl don't include hsl nice
so as you can see and it should work I
think and let's see so now this is the
color for Twitter and yeah so now
everything is changed you can see but
the text color is is Blue by default and
we don't want a text color to be blue
for that we can ask it to again modify
this thing change the text color to
white and the only color which needs to
be Tweeter blue is button background and
borders or accent colors okay the only
color which needs to be Twitter blue is
accent color
okay so we have changed this thing body
apply BG background text photograph text
is for the ground let's copy this file
again so it haven't given us the hsl
values change it to hsl values without
hsl keyword so this means it forgot now
I think it will work yeah
now let's see okay so it haven't changed
but here we can do apply BG background
and text should be white now it is good
now you can see the border is good if we
type the color is good yeah so you can
also use the chair GPT like that
otherwise if I had to do this all along
like finding the colors and doing this
this would take me like an hour or so so
to save my time here I would go for this
approach as you can see now everything
is good to go we just have to do
something here so now first thing first
we need a dialog or we can say the model
so for that we just have to do first of
all we need to add a button or we can
just add a dialog and I think it should
add all the things related to dialogue
so now we can copy and paste this
command here and hit enter and it should
add a dialog button where would you like
to install the components so in the dot
slash dots list SRC slash components
slash UI so we will copy this thing
maybe in the future if you want to
install any other component then we will
just paste this so now it will install
the component in the dialog here you can
see this component is here so basically
it has copied and pasted all the things
okay now we need to also install the
button because the button thing we need
always so here is the or button copy
this now we have also button you can see
all the variants of the button that's
why we have installed this class
variance Authority for our buttons now
this is good to go now we need
authentication for our application okay
so for that we have to define something
so first of all we'll find the
documentation related to superbase
authentication next year is 13. so this
is our authentication first we have to
install this libraries so we'll open a
new terminal this this terminal is only
for the UI part this is server this is
for installing all the other
dependencies so we can say pnpm install
supervised auth helpers next yes we also
have to install this all react not
helper so we can use all the hooks that
are provided next yes 13 is stable
however the new app directory and server
components are in beta check out our
experimental guide yeah so we are using
this app directory that's why we need to
follow this documentation and you can
find this link here I will paste this
link in my readme authentication setup
so you can follow along the video if you
want and you can also follow this
article to integrate authentication for
your application so first of all we will
copy this environment variable we will
create a environment file dot EnV here
dot ENB not for now first we will check
if we are using dot EnV here no so we
have to ignore dot EnV file here first
dot EnV now we can define a dot
env.local just like it so that it
doesn't get dragged by our GitHub these
are not secret next public means this
keys can be public what can't be public
are super best secret keys so we will
see what are they in the future so yeah
now it is good so your super based URL
and your supervised NN key we will find
this key by going to Super Bass project
so superbass.com sign in in the ultimate
clone and in the project settings in the
API where is the let's see API yeah here
is our project URL copy this next public
this is our project URL and this is our
NN public key see this is secret key and
this key has ability to bypass row level
security never share it publicly so
don't share this key publicly anytime
you can use this NN key always so now
let's paste this thing here so now we of
my energy now we have my Super Bass URL
that's good to go okay so for the
authentication allow new users to sign
up you can enable this we can enable
also custom SMTP settings that means we
can use our own email provider
credentials now here we will Define a
configure middleware so we are using
typescript you can toggle this thing
here so we have to use a middleware that
will be code every time we request a
page and this page will contain the
cookies and all the things that will be
handled by this thing and it will
provide us the supervisor that's how we
we know who is accessing our application
or we can say we can know the user
details when the page is rendered so
copy this thing typescript types can be
generated with super based through your
life so we will also generate all the
types so for that we have to use this
thing Super Bass start first of all we
will do Super Bass init now you can see
the Super Bass inside our application
this is C dot SQL if you want to see any
data for seeding your data you can also
use share GPT to write some queries for
you you can use chair GPT always use J
GPT I would say to increase your
productivity so now we will say Super
Bass star I think it will start the low
condition which we don't need for now I
will just use this thing if it works or
not let's see it will generate over
types in the library and database
type.ts okay you can use CLI to generate
types but the point is I am not using so
first of all we have to install the
supervisor we still haven't installed
the supervis if you go to package.json
we have installed the oauth helpers but
we haven't installed the supervised CS
Library so pnpm is done super based yes
this is how we create a client and now
we can face the data so where should we
generate the type so we I think we can
generate the types in Super Bass slash
database DOT type slash TS so it is
asking us to install or to run the
docker and then we have to run the super
based local instance
to generate the keys but what I want
here I want the remote database to
generate the tables for us so okay so
what you can do here if you don't have
Docker first install the docker for your
machine so if you visit this you can
download for your machine install this
and make sure the token is running fine
and now I will open the docker so that
we can run supabets inside our local
machine now if you visit the Super Bass
dashboard we are using the remote
version but for development we want a
local version that's why because we need
to generate the types and it is asking
us to generate the types now it is good
or we can ask it to I don't want you to
get into the docker any stuff that's why
I want the remote support so super bass
generate types remote database okay so
first login then we can use this command
to generate the types cool so let's
login npx superbase login
so we have to generate the excess token
here so I will generate a access token
so paste this thing and generate a token
local machine so I have this token I
will not show you this token and you
should keep this hidden because this is
a secret okay now I can close this thing
now we have generated our custom token
now we can generate the types here so
instead of using the project ID so we
can now delete the supervisor so we
don't need it okay what I'm saying is
first I will write steps you need to
follow before authentication
authentication generate the types
for your tables for the tables for the
database we have created in the last
video so for that npx super bass login
and then you have to do is this command
project ID and insert your project ID
here I will insert mine so I will go to
my super based dashboard this is my ID I
will copy this and I will copy here in
the public yeah I will hit enter type
supervised let's create a file or you
can say a folder types now it should
work it is generating the types and it
has generated the types you can see we
have all the bookmarks we have hashtags
we have likes you can see row insert
update everything is here these four
things likes profiles replies hashtag
tweets okay and these are the views
functions enums all the other things but
these are our tables which are seven
tables this is a profile the row is full
name ID updated username okay so the
username can't be null why it is saying
this is this can be null okay I'm not
sure about that maybe we have some
mistake this is also row IDE reply ID
can be null Twitter ID can be null yes
this profiles in the profiles we have
full name so the problem is when we
first run the query it has created a row
which has null and then we have run the
another query then it doesn't override
it again that's why the username can be
helped but we don't want the username to
be null so we'll modify our database so
in the profiles the username can't win
also I will say allow nullable so I will
not allow this to be nullable and is
unique yeah save this thing now we have
updated our username table this is the
much thing we have to do because we
don't want any user to sign up without a
username and if we now again generate
the types by using the same command you
will see that the username is now string
and not null in the profiles here
username is string no it can't be null
so this is the important thing we have
to do we have to remember so here you
you have to use your project ID good I
will clear everything now we are good to
go so where we were we were creating
this thing middleware.ts in the root of
your project and populate with the
following so this is a middleware which
we are going to use so let's see how it
is being used so this is a client common
in the client's component we can always
use the super based client and we can
face the data like this this is simple
but in the server components we have to
use like this create server component
super based client which comes from here
and then we can paste the data like this
and this all data will be faced on the
server so you can follow this repo for
the whole example okay so this is a
middleware.ts which we need to create in
the root of over directory so middleware
to TS go up copy this thing database two
types what we can do instead of here we
can paste this thing here or what we can
inside the Library supervised types two
types now it works remove this folder
these are our types cool so it is a
middleware which will handle it is a
database which is this it will create
our supervised instance and it will
provide us the authentication and it
will provide us the session of the user
close everything now in the app
directory create a supervised provider
which will provide the whole application
and it will work like a context so
Superbus provider.tsx copy everything
and this is a client that's why we are
using instead of super based root types
yeah if we call it database to types it
will be fine but yeah if we can call it
super based client database we are
defining the types this is a context
super best provider we will provide the
whole application
or we can say we will wrap our
application inside this provider and it
will run the use effect hook which will
check every time if we are authenticated
or not and Export cons used to always
supervised must be inside supervised
provider and now we can use this use
server base inside our application so we
don't have to Define again and again and
it will be only one instance of super
best inside our whole application save
this thing now we have to rape our whole
application inside this super best
provider here like this in the
layout.tsx like this so inside the body
we will say this is supervised provider
import this from supervised provider
save this thing and it will work now any
of our client components base hook use
super best hook to ensure they are using
the same instance of super bus line or
we can say they will not be creating
more than one instance okay so now
inside our client components we can use
this inside our server components we can
use this that's okay that's good so
first of all we will try this thing
inside our server component so so in our
page this is a server component we can
see now we'll import this create server
components import the database and the
headers and cookies do not cache this
page where we get our headers and
cookies okay let me see that we have to
import this from next header okay now if
we try to login now if you try to look
this console.org super based out all the
things auth dot user get user it will
give us let's update for it let's make
this function async and we will log in
the user here we will see if the user is
logged in or not save this thing and now
you can see the data is user dot data
dot user so instead of doing this we can
see the data and the error and we can
load both things now we have the user is
null and error is missing subclaim or
which means we are not authorized the
status is four zero one now we will try
to authenticate the user so what should
we use which method should we use I will
use the Google login because this is the
easiest one to create so I will go to
Google Docs so to create the Google
authentication you have to follow these
steps you have to get the oauth and now
you have to do all the things here we
can use a password method username
password method but I'm not going to
this add login code to your client
application sign it with Google so only
email providers is enabled for now okay
so I think we can use the email if you
want any other provider you can see
their docs their docs are very user
friendly very easy to follow we will use
the magic Link login for now simple
login the user will receive a login the
sign in with OTP and that's all this
simple thing we just have to provide the
email and everything will work so let's
copy this thing and that's all we need
we have to enable magic link
authenticator to your application so
here in the email I think this is
already enabled so what we will do first
we will create a model or we can say a
dialog we can create it here so we can
see if the error dot status is equal
equal to 4 1 which means the user is not
authenticated then don't allow user to
see the whole thing or we can say here
if the error dot status is 401 what we
need to do is we need to show the user
the model so if this 401 means the user
is not authorized or the user is not
authenticated so now we will import the
dialog here which we have created in the
components so remember to import this
from UI slash dialog so in the dialog we
have dialog content like this and now
here we can also use the input okay so
we can say so to use input we can also
use this thing input this will provide
us a beautiful input field now if you go
into the UI you can see the input this
so import the input from components this
is a client component and you will see
YZ we have to Define this as a client
component inside another component so
first of all let's save this thing and
see how it looks where is our
application localhost 3000 you can see
this is not visible now so we can can
say if the error dot status is 401 we
have to open this so is open default
open we can say if the error dot status
is 401 then open this thing refresh this
now you can see we have this model and
we can't see but we have got a few
errors doesn't match expected server
HTML to contain matching div the
hydration error refresh this it will not
work okay so what we need to do we have
to cut this whole thing we have to
create another component or the model we
can say not a folder it is a file auth
model dot TSX here what we can do rafce
this is a client component and to use a
client component we can say use client
why we can't use this is a server
component because at any point we have
to write something we have to send some
data to Source server so we have to
interact to our UI and for interactivity
we need to use client-side components
and if you are not sure why I am using a
used client here you can watch my next
year's app directory tutorial which was
a to-do list tutorial I have published a
few days ago in which you will learn it
to build a to-do list application and
inside that application you will see why
we are using here use client and you
will understand for sure okay now you
can follow along here I will copy this
thing dialog is good close this here we
will use a use State and these hooks can
be only used in client component that's
why is open files import the state here
and we can say open is open and on open
changes set is up so now we can control
this model to open and not open import
the input also this is good now what we
can do here is open so we can direct
face the detail here okay so what we can
do here so this whole thing can be used
inside our provider where we have used
supervised provider which is a client
component here here we are providing the
whole thing here we can find the details
okay so I think here we can do all the
stuff instead of creating a new
component by the way we can import the
dialog from components copy the state
import everything dialog and dialog
content here import the dialog from
components from components from
components save this thing so now we
have a dialog and we are rendering the
children and it is open by default if it
is if the user is not authenticated and
we can do it by doing it here so you can
say subscription dot not like that we
can say superbase dot oauth dot Care
Station dot then result if it is if
result dot error dot status is equal to
401 then what we need to do is we need
to open the model otherwise everything
is good to go and otherwise we don't
need to do anything so just save this
thing and that's all we don't need this
oath model anymore we have created all
the logic we need for our authentication
inside our supervised provider so now
this is a good tool we can remove these
components because these are they are
not used here go here now you can see if
we refresh this okay it is not working
let's see let's see the result here
first of all lock the result okay where
is our localhost
3000 now you can see we got two things
we got station and we got error okay so
if the session is null which means we
are not authenticated so what we can do
if the rest dot data dot session is not
true if this is not true or which means
the user is not authenticated then open
the model otherwise don't now you can
see the model is open and we should not
be able to close this okay now it is
good to go this is what I look dialog
overlay background at the busy
background we can change all the things
here if you want you can see dialogue
trigger dialog content header footer
title description cool so if we refresh
this you can see we are not logged in
and we are seeing that we need to do
something here so here we can do all the
magic first of all we will make this
whole look like Twitter so BG black give
some pairing to it cool now this is a
form and we need input field for now so
input we have already used that thing
the type is text the placeholder is
email and here we can say do or S3
please sign in to continue give some
classes to it text LG my 4 save this and
let's see how it looks now it's it's
look good mice my4 is bit much it's good
now we need to make a button also button
import the button from UI send login and
we can include a short here short a
paragraph here you will receive
a login magic link here we can give it
some classes text SM text is white or
you can make it gray somewhat 200 that's
good or we can also give it margin by
two yeah and what I need is I'm right
Auto the color is not looking good to me
this is tutor color but this is not
looking good to me so I will say BG BG
white and text is Click I want it to be
end so for that what we can do here is I
can wrap this whole thing inside a
division and I can make it Flex I can
give it w full and I can say justify to
the end so now the button will at the
end text is text should be white when
hover text should be white and when
hover the Border should also be white
okay so what you need to do is to make
this application beautiful you have to
give some time here you have to select
all the colors without using chair GPT
because we always want to make sure that
our app looks good inside tell me in CSS
television config in inside the
styles.css where it is inside the
globals.cs here you should carefully
Define all the colors and that's how it
will work nicely otherwise you can see
it it is working out and you will face
the problem like this so for that I will
use the default colors provided by here
theming for now I will use the default
color in the future I can go for
different color but for now I am going
with default now you can see refresh
this page it's good now I can remove
this this button already looks good you
can see this button already looks good
and the border the hover properties
everything seems perfect instead of text
Gray I would go for 900 okay so and for
our home page what we can do here so for
our home page we can give it text right
here so it will work good now our text
is white instead of this tweet wherever
we use the primary Dash primary like
here BG primary so here we can use the
Tweet color so go here so what we can do
we can insert a new color to it Twitter
color we can say it Twitter and we can
use the Twitter color hex Twitter color
hex code this code here now if you go to
here instead of PG primary you can
replace it with VG Twitter color and it
will work it will work as default
instead of compromising with the default
UI classes modify all the yeah so now it
should work so now if you visit our
application you can see our tweet over
everything is looking good if you
refresh yeah this is good and now we
have to login the user so for that first
of all when the user owns submit it
receives the event so we have to prevent
the default to prevent the page to
reload again and now we have to submit
the user email so for that you can use a
state again use State snippet email
first of all it is empty set email to
whenever this status changes so on
change it receives event and set email
we went to Target dot value okay okay so
why this login button is looking blue
because we have changed the button color
also so if we go to here instead of this
we have changed this thing also so we
have to use the primary yeah also now it
is good save this let's go into here if
we hit the login button it will work
this function will run and it will call
the supervis function which is superbase
dot auth dot login okay so we have to
find the documentation where it is login
with magic link sign in with OTP sign in
with OTP so here we can provide the
email and we can say email dot trim and
we can also check if the email is
correct or not for that we can choose
the email field here type email and it
will by default check it if the email is
correct or not then it we will trim and
we will send this and options are should
create user data and we also need a
username so that we will Define another
field which is text placeholder username
and we will use another state use State
as username this it is by default empty
set username and we can say minimum
minimum length or we can say the minimum
should be it should be three characters
long now if you parse the username in
the future we will also check if the
username is exist or not first check if
the username exists or not okay so we
also need to show some toast to users
for that we will install the new library
called sonar it's a great Library you
can visit the sonar npm you can see this
Library rendered Host this is a
beautiful toast and this is the same
toast I am using for my website Club of
folders if you search Club of folders so
I am using this for my website and I can
recommend it it's a great an awesome
library to render the toss so we have
installed this first of all if we go to
app in the layout here we can Define the
toaster in the Super Bass provider I
think here we can Define the toaster
also from sonar import this from sonar
we only need one toaster and now we can
use toast dot like this toast dot
success like this error like this
username already exist please use
another one we have to check this so
forth checking we can find we can say
Super Bass await super based out from
profiles Dot and make this function as a
async function dot we can fetch we can
select we can do everything select dot
now we can say select where the username
is let's find the supervised docs so we
don't miss anything so in the fetching
data we can select the data and here are
the filters we can use like this select
select dot now we can say is equal to it
except two things column is username
which is also a string and the value is
which we have used username dot let's
stream it if the user has typed in any
white space we can find it it provides
us data and error if data exists and
let's consult or load the data first of
all and we can say username already
exists please use another and we can
return it from that's how we are
checking if the username is already
exist or not and we are sending sign in
with OTP now we are good to go we can
avoid this also we can avoid this and
when everything is successful we can
close this model or let's don't do
anything and let's see for now what is
happening so go here in the OR
application refresh everything so we are
making sure that everything is good
extra attributes from server CZ shortcut
listen okay I will use my email which is
Club of Horrors
gmail.com
gmail.com and I will type my username
also Club of coders and let's click on
the login we should also show some
loading state for that we can use
another state here use State you can see
how many steps we have to use here
button or we can say yeah we can say
it's loading initially it is false set
loading is true and here set loading is
false and when it is loading show the
make the button is disabled simple
disabled save this thing now if we type
Club of quarters.com
[Music]
gmail.com I will type my username also
you can see we have to give some space
here let's click on the login username
already list please use another so in
the data you can see we have selected
and we have got nothing we got nothing
so the array is empty so if we can see
the data I thought length is equal to 0
or we can say is greater than 0 then
show this otherwise don't data and end
data dot length is greater than 0 then
show this and return from there
otherwise log in the user with email now
here we can remove everything let's also
give some space to this input last name
m y 2 now you can see it's good clap of
folders Dot
gmail.com Club of quarters hit enter now
you can see it is sending us an OTP so
now it first find that if the username
is exist and it found that username
doesn't exist now it has sent the
request with the data of username and
this user now the user should be in our
database so if you go to what tables and
this authentication and this sign in
with OTP also should create a trigger to
create a username which we have passed
easy data so we should see a username
inside our profiles let's see yeah so
you can see we have a club of folders
username inside our profile and now we
are signed in inside our application
okay so if you hit a button again you
will receive that username already exist
and it will find this full name and this
user okay that's how it works and we are
now signed in to our application and you
can see this is the current user this is
a user which we have faced now you can
remove this we can remove this we are
successfully created this sign
functionality
close this thing close everything we
should be able to see the data here okay
so it will not sign us up because we
have to verify as so I should have
received a magic link for signing you
can say confirm your sign up so if I
click this link here now I am signing
yeah so now I have signed up for the
application and you can see the data
here ID is this role is this my email is
this and everything is here okay so now
I am signed in and I didn't see anything
so we can remove this we can also remove
this basically we don't need anything
because we are handling all the what we
say the authentication logic inside our
supervised provider here we have created
a dialog we have created a form and we
are using this authentication here so
now we are signed in and we are good to
go to build the functionalities the
Tweet functionality is the live
functionality is the bookmark
functionalities so first of all what we
need to do is we need to enable row
level security policies for all the
tables currently over all the tables are
public which means anybody can access
over data and modify it and can fetch it
so we don't want that so we will go to
the Super page dashboard home and go to
the database part and in the
tables and here I think we have policies
so table editor go here
hashtags you can see all the tables
and the table save row level
you are allowing Anonymous access to
your table so we have to enable all row
level Securities so to do that go to
authentication and in the policies
clear the search box and you will find
all the tables here and enable the
policies for all the tables
so you can enable the policies
you can also enable all the policies by
running a SQL query but we are doing it
manually because we don't have many
tables and we can do this manually it is
easy
we have enabled the row level security
policies which means nobody can access
our tables now but if we try to access
from our database URL or database
connection string the database
connection issuing have previous to
access all the tables and all the data
so that's why we are going to use server
components and inside server components
we will face the data so that we don't
have to compromise our security over row
level security policies and everything
we are going to do is in the server side
okay so you will see what I'm saying so
first of all this is our project and I
will start this project by running so we
are using here pnpm and we will say pnpm
brand Dev and we will
take a demo first what we have built
till now so
we have env.local and everything is
looking good now so this is our app
directory because we are using the
latest nexgs features that's why
so let's go to localhost 3000 and we
will see what is
how it is looking you can see the this
is not looking good because I have
enabled the June so let me
yeah so 150 percent it's good
looking good so currently we are signed
in or not how get it so if you click on
the profile
the page doesn't exist if you click on
tweet nothing exists for now
the training part the home to fall apart
so what we have to do now we have to
check if we are authenticated or not we
will make this responsive in the later
videos so if you go to super best
provider so here we are providing
everything okay and if you try to tweet
something hello world we try to tweet it
doesn't work so we are getting the
profiles and we are saying that it
doesn't exist yeah so this is our
provider this is dialog set is open yes
so we are logged in basically so to
check if we are logged in on console.log
we will lock the current supervis user
so here we will consider.log the
superbase dot auth dot user dot get user
and that's all let's lock this thing
okay so it is let's see we want the
current user who is logged in so there
are a lot of things get user gets
session let's see the get session thing
okay this is also returning the promise
so what we can do we can look here we'll
check the result here it will refresh
and here we are so you can see we are
logged in this is our user this is my
email and everything is looking good but
for for the authentication I think we
can use something called server context
or server station to see if you are
logged in or not so now we will
implement the Tweet functionality if I
tweet something here or let's say I copy
some paragraphs so this is the rate cost
extension you can also install this it
is pretty handy you can install this
it's great you can directly go below MF
Sim you can also do the confetti thing
it is pretty good you can see so yeah
you can install this so this is our text
and if you try to tweet it doesn't work
now so we will implement this
functionality so in the main component
is our home this is our input text and
this is our tweet button so tweet
composer we will create another
component so recently when I have
created or when I have started building
this script clone next year's release a
few more features like nature server
actions so we can utilize these server
actions to mutate the data inside our
database so that we don't have to do all
the API stuff so let me show you what is
next year server directions you can see
this is how we will create a form and we
will decorate this as a server code and
we can directly you can see save to DB
and this is our running mode server this
is not running on client this is running
on server so this is very easy to do and
we will do this now so first of all what
we will do inside the components let's
close it in the source directory in the
components these are the components
these are server components by default
so we will create another component so I
think we can create a folder called
server components so that we can
differentiate what is server component
and what is nodes we can also do it like
this this is nothing bad in naming like
this and we can say compose to it and
this is a server component okay and what
we will do rafce compose tweet okay so
we renamed wrong compose tweet so this
is our composed tweet and what we will
do we will just use the latest next year
server directions so as you can see we
can face the data like that and we are
doing that in the supervised provider
here you can see this is a client
component you can see this is a client
component so okay so we are not fetching
any data is for now so we will use this
technique to fetch our data directly you
can see you can directly face the data
we can case the data using the kit
static props and we will see how to do
that also so this is this will speed up
our page reload and then we can also
revalidate the data like this when we
are using the kit static props and this
is how we can mutate the data directly
using the server components so now let's
do this so this is our function and we
will use this thing so copy this thing
so this is a function which will we will
say compose compose to it like this or
submit to it you can do is submit
details or save to it in rooted DB
whatever you want to name it save submit
to it this will take a tweet text tweet
and it is a string simple and it is a
used server you think you can see you
this is a use server but I think we have
to update our Nexus version because we
are I haven't updated anything after I
left building this uh in the like past
two months so this is the version we are
using 13.3 and what is the latest
version of lectures next shares let's go
okay so we I think we have to go to the
GitHub so the latest version is
13.4.7 so I think we can update it close
the server first
pnpm update next it will update over
let's see okay already up to date I
think what we can do this is remove this
thing and we can install this again so
it will update find the next note here
okay so it is uninstall we have to do it
again because I have saved this thing
yeah now you can see in next year's
13.4.7 so if you are watching this
tutorial please update this thing
otherwise the server actions may not
work I don't know so you can see we have
removed the 13.3 version and we are
updated in HS 13.4.7 clear everything
pnpm run there again it may create some
problems let's see if this is working or
not okay so it is working so inside the
compost Suite now we can use this theme
so let's comment it out first so this is
our server thing and we can get the data
like this we will see how to work with
that thing so first save this thing
let's see if your application is still
working or something is broken with the
updated version yeah so it's working
it's working fine you can see so now we
will integrate our server action
action and that Aid item and then okay
so we have to enable the server actions
from our next config so this is also you
should remember so go to the next config
and we have to enable the server actions
like that inside the component that uses
server components and in the separate
files code I just want to know how how
we are getting the data so this is the
data and we are doing Aid item and it is
getting the data from cookies but we
want to know and action is similar to
HTML primitive action okay so it is same
as HTML action okay so I think we we are
we can get the data from the form action
that's custom invocation using start
transition you can also invoke server
actions without using action or form
action you can achieve this by using
start transition provided by use
transition hook which can be useful if
you want to do server actions outside of
the form button or inputs okay so we can
actually use server actions without
using a form component this is what this
means cool like this this is a like
button so when we will Implement our
like functionality or bookmark
functionality we will use this thing and
you can see this we this is saying that
use Virtual KV which is a new feature or
we can say the new integration inversal
which is a KB or we can say the radius
database inside under the hood it is
using something called upstage This is a
serverless data for already so you can
have a look at it if you want
if this is how this is working this is a
client component this is what we were
doing when we were handling things in
react basic simple react but now time
has changed and we will do things
differently so first let's see how we
are getting the data so this is how we
are getting the data phone data just
like it and we will see how it is
working so this is our phone data and we
will console.locis and it will
console.log in our server here not in
the client in the browser this will load
the data inside here in the terminal so
first let's copy everything from our
main component which is this okay so
this is our main component and
let's cut this thing paste it here and
we can say this is a form we can remove
this thing save this now here we can say
action and here we can Define submit to
it it is saying that yeah let's see how
this works action and this is again form
data and format data good why it is
complaining so import the compose like
this it will okay so I think we have to
do something with our responsiveness
this is looking ugly okay so what we
will do we will hide it when this is
smaller so in the sidebar right sidebar
I think we can hide both of the sidebar
when this screen is smaller so here we
what we can do here we can use hidden
and only be visible when the screen is
clearer than large screen we can do the
same for right sidebar here we can say
this is hidden by default and only be
shown after the screen is larger this is
how so now if you refresh this you can
see this is hidden so what we can do we
can do after Excel so if this screen
size is extra large hide both of those
things now it's good but you can see
this is also breaking this thing and
this is overflowing from the content so
which is where so we have to fix some
styling in our own so if you go to the
main component okay so let's comment
this out this is all things let's remove
this thing and yeah now it is taking the
full width we can also do only after the
Excel the width is 50 otherwise the
width is like this so now it is good you
can see it is looking good but still
when the skin is too small this is
overflowing so we need to fix this thing
this tweet list so for the inside the
here so let's keep it with full we are
giving it border that's good overflow
hidden so now the Overflow is hidden but
we don't want the Overflow to read and
we want this to be contained inside the
flow so why we are facing this problem
let's see okay this is same problem
after so we have to remove the whole
thing we don't want our photo to be
hidden we want it to be contained inside
this so it is not content it may because
we are giving some fixed width to
something okay so this is width height
and 10 this looks good to me but let's
wait for some fix it yeah it's still
broken so you want to make make the
height or the font is smaller so for
that we can say after the Excel the
fonts I don't know what is causing the
problem so I will comment it out and I
will see it is the image which is
causing the problem this thing so if you
comment it out not this image where it
varies over full image yeah this thing
so we are giving it height of 80 and we
don't we are not giving it with full so
this is this is the thing which is
causing the problem so if we comment it
out no it is still causing the problem
we want it to be contained okay so this
is not the problem I am showing you how
I am fixing this problem so you will
also get the intuition behind everything
power commenting this out moderate 500
border 2 so this is our container and it
is yeah it is good but this is not
containing this inside this is bad the
resource URL was preloaded using link
preload but not used within a few
seconds from the windows okay so we will
fix this error also extra tribute server
so let's focus on building the feature
now we will see how to fix this scene
later or I believe we can fix this by
making it grid sometime that helps
create
otherwise if you don't give it anything
what will happen because something is
broken now and that's the reason it is
broken the reason this thing is broken
is this we are defining a maximum width
and we are trying to squeeze this and it
is taking the that width so that's the
reason of this is not working so you can
see this is getting out of hand so here
if we remove this you can see now it is
contained inside this that is good part
so here what we can do only give this
Max width when this is greater than XL
otherwise with full is good so if we try
to increase this you can see now it is
responsive if we squeeze it yeah you can
see this is responsive and looking good
cool now we can work on this thing so if
we try to yeah it's good so if we try to
submit something hello world and we
should be able to see something here
form data so for that we need to define
something old submit or I think action
which is submit tweet and this is taking
the form data yeah so this is a text and
the form meta we don't know what is this
we will see if we do it something let's
see the okay so we are not getting
anything so let's see the documentation
how it works okay so we haven't given
this button the submit type is submit
and this is inside the form you can see
so now if you try to submit this there
is still nothing type is text action on
data okay so this is a client component
here we need server comp why it is
complaining it is saying it is not a
sync okay any let's go for NES for now
so this action text action.js use server
so the problem we are facing was if you
remove this this will complain and type
this script is not happy so to avoid
that you can use as any this is a just
temporary fix I hope next yes will face
this issue as soon as they can but now
because this server or we can say this
function or this functionality is still
in Alpha phase which you can read over
here you can go to block you can read
that this server actions is is still in
Alpha phase so you can see this is good
but we have to careful to use this in
production this tutorial is just for
beginners or we can say for learning
purpose so we can use this thing but do
not use this thing in production because
this thing is still node in production
phase so let's just build our
application by using this temporary fix
so we can say temporary fix okay so now
if you go to your application which is
our application and Hello World server
actions like that and if you hit to it
you can see we are getting our data over
here I have changed I have also put the
name attribute over here and the type
attribute over here so now it is working
you can see Hello World server actions
and we are getting more data inside our
server and we can directly mutate our
database from here so what we can do
yeah you you can get the Tweet over here
just like that if you see in the console
we have a name and we have a value so we
can say form data dot get tweet so it
will give us the value of the Tweet so
you can also confirm it by console.log
tweet save this thing and if you click
on tweet you can see we are getting the
Tweet value now you can verify this or
you can check if this value is truthy or
you can say this value is good to put in
our database if you can check if not to
it then simply return and if this state
is accessed we can directly insert this
into our super best table so we can say
const data and cost error we can say
supervis import the Suba best client but
here we need our server swabish client
so for that where we can get our super
best server client so inside the app
directory layout this or supervised
provider let's see if we have any Super
Bass server client so first I think we
need to create a server client so using
superbase with Nexus app now
so this is the what we can say this is
the blog article which we have followed
to build our super base authentication
you can see we have also created a
middlewares called something this is a
create middleware supervised client and
yeah so this is how we are creating the
super based client we are using
typescript over here this is
authentication and this is what we were
doing previously yeah so this is they
have given the example of a server
action here you can see directly without
using anything like client component
create server action client and we will
pass the cookies and now we will have
our client everything is looking good so
this is how we can create our server
action client so we will create our
server client import this first import
from supervis import the database okay
so it is being imported from auth helper
Nexus create server super best client
this is what we need create server swaps
clients and import the cookies from here
I think we don't need testing and it
will ask us through something okay so
create server supervised client how
about this so I think they have also
changed their documentation and this is
not exported from auth helpers Nexus a
lot of things have changed rear server
action client what are the X create
browser create middleware create route
Handler create server component super
best client so this is what we need
create server component supervised
client and inside this we can pass our
cookies from like this what else it
needs it needs headers also import the
headers from there so now it is working
so super based Dot from so that table we
have named is we can also yeah so you
can see all our tables because we are
using this database types here so we
have bookmarks tabled hashtags likes
profiles tweets so inside the tweets we
need to insert a rogue so tweets dot
insert and here we can specify our
values just like that and it is you can
see this is auto completion is given to
us by typescript and it is pretty good
so profile ID
so here we will give the profile ID
which we will get from superbase dot
oauth dot so first thing we need to get
the user so here we will get the user
const so await Super Bass dot auth dot
get session or get user I think so it
will return as the user which has data
and errors in the user data we can say
this is the user data it is user error
if the user error exists return
and if the user data exists then log
this thing so we will log this and we
will see how it is working first we will
go here we will do it and you can see we
are getting the user data so this is the
user ID we are getting and everything is
looking good so first of all we will go
to the authentication in the profiles we
will see if we have the same ID inside
our profile ID as well so you can see
this is the ID we have copy this and
this is the same ID yeah this is the
same ID which we need here okay so we
will insert this into our tweet so if
you go to the twists tables here we have
mapped this profile ID to user ID if you
edit the column you can see this is
mapped to the profile ID and which is
the same ID which is here we are getting
so now we can see await super based Dot
from
and we can say tweets dot insert okay I
want to disable this co-pilot extension
I don't like this I will disable this
thing insert and now we can insert over
things here ID will be created
automatically so profile ID is user data
dot user dot ID like that other thing we
need is text so the text is tweet next
thing we need is ID okay so it is saying
that we need ID so we can generate a ID
not a big thing so this is a uuid and we
can generate it by uuid from the crypto
and it is saying that form data entry
value is not assignable to type Stream
So to each dot you can convert this to a
string and now it will it is looking
good so this is how we are directly
mutating our data without compromising
our security inside server components
using the server actions and it is
pretty simple you can see we can do one
thing here we can directly pass the ID
the user ID from the form but that is
another approach but this is far more
secure because we know that user is
logged in or not and this is pretty
sweet save this thing and then we need
to reload the page we will refetge all
our tweets so if you go to the main
components here we are getting the
tweets so this is also a server
component so what we will do we will
create a const get tweets this is a
server components and we will fetch all
the tools from our supervised client
so the same thing I think we can export
this from a utils folder something like
that the whole thing we can export it
here import cookies and import the
headers as well and Super Bass server
client just like that save this thing we
will see if this is working or not
remove this Ctrl D import this from
utils let's check this thing is working
or not okay so you can see this is not
working because we are also importing
this TW merge here so instead what I
will do I will create a new library
called Super Bass here superbase.ts I
will import everything inside this
because it may it is conflicting with
the client package which is this
television merge and the CL X CLX
package so now it is node conflicting
and here we can import this again from
our supervised server client and now it
will not conflict yeah you can see Hello
World this is a new tweet we will tweet
this so it is saying error something
went wrong okay avoid when wrong because
of this extraction viewed it but I want
to use it everywhere but we can't use
this because the cookies and headers are
different I don't know let's yeah this
is the same error which we are getting I
think we can't do this why we can't do
this let's see yeah so we have to
initialize this again and again for
every component this is not good I want
to use the Super Bass server everywhere
without getting worried so I think we
can create a client hook also and we can
use this remove this and Super Bass
client import this thing we are using
the database and here it will need
supervised client new superbased client
it will need the supervised URL which is
EnV import can say the process.env dot
it needs first argument is supervised
URL so you can say Super Bass URL and
the second one is process.enb dot the
subabase key here we will use the secret
key supervis secret key which is a key
that is previous access to all the rows
and it can bypass the security of row
level security SVA so it is a like admin
key or something so it is saying that it
can be undefined so we can say as a
string we can fix this this is a
temporary fix this is not a good idea I
will tell you how to improve your
managing your environment variables just
like we do in the T3 stick so now we can
remove these things we will try this
thing first so I will now go to EnV here
we have next public supervised URL this
is the same thing which we will use here
and this is the next public enem key so
this is the public key and it doesn't
have any access so we want the secret
key which is a server key super based
secret key and I will go now to Super
based dashboard and I will copy that key
here so in the API so this is service
rows this is what I am talking about and
I will reveal this I will copy this and
I am hiding this because this is a
secret key and you should also keep this
secure so now we have super best secret
key and we have Superbass public key and
we will use this client here so instead
of using this yeah let's see if now this
will work or not refresh the whole thing
try this we are just trying and we will
see if it is working or not super best
key is required okay so we have the
supervised key here let's lock this
thing out so we can see what is
happening here
process.env.next I think separating it
out it doesn't work yeah okay so let's
remove this thing we have to use it
again and again we have to create this
again and again so Ctrl Z Now this is is
good so we have to use this we have to
use this Constable base we have to
create this again anyway we can't use
this only once so we have tried it and
we have tested and it is not working
like that so as you can see here we have
our main timeline and as of now we are
not showing anything but we are we can
submit now any tweet we can create it we
can tweet basically so this is a tweet
and if you hit enter it is being
done you can see okay so yeah so now we
have some tweets inside our database so
if we go to our dashboard in the Twitter
in the tables in the tweets here we can
see all the tweets okay so there is no
Tweed because if you go to the main
component in the main component we have
a main form a composed with here we are
submitting the Tweet just like that it
is saying that oauth user yeah Miss so
let's see if it is working or not so as
of for now you can see this is not
working we will see what is happening
here const it gives us data in error
console.log we will load the data in the
error both and we will see if this is
working or not this time this is a tweet
let's tweet this yeah new row okay so it
is saying that we are violating the row
level security policies so it's good we
are getting some details over here but I
want to show this message or this error
message on the front end so can we do
that can we do that but I I think we
can't do this in in the server actions
so if we showing error on client in
server actions Nexus how to handle the
errors so we will see how to handle the
error okay so we can submit the error
and we can do like this cool you can
return anything we can return the data
and error from here so what we can do
with return data and it's just like that
and here we can do this thing Action
assing phone data await Action phone
data and this is how it is suggested
here so this is a tweet we can see what
it is saying if it doesn't break uib
don't consider it an error yeah that's
true because we are doing all in server
so it is not breaking the UI it's just
the data you return from an action
support it into the state when it create
true sleep error Setter there but also
be built in the Injustice pattern model
so now let's try to return this and we
will see if this is working or not the
data we are getting here we can make it
a sync and here we can make this action
the data and let's give it any on now
and it should give us some data or the
response and we will print out the
response I am not sure it will work or
not but yeah yeah it is saying form
action function functions cannot be
passed directly to client components
unless this is not a client component
let's see if it is breaking the UI yeah
so form action function cannot be passed
but why it is saying here the same thing
we are doing the same here action async
data the form data and okay so what I
found out is we can't handle the error
system like we handle in the client
components if you want to do this we
need to create a client component and
then call the server action like this
this is a client component we need to
create a client component inside the
server component and then we can call
this as a prop storage Direction inform
data like this it's possible with a
client component you can pass the server
action as a prop to the client component
so this is how we can handle the errors
that's why I believe the trpc is still
ahead of time if you use trpc QV live
will be so much easier but don't worry
we can do that now so let's create a
client component for now so in This
Server component create a form client
component let's try this out if this is
working or not so first we will say use
client
and we will receive the props in here
like this we are typing it and we will
say we will receive a phone client
component just like here so we can I
think remove this thing we can just
follow this pattern over here the whole
thing the error everything let's install
the package first pnpm we'll start Sonos
this is a package which will help us to
show some toast messages and nice toast
messages so you can see the touch
presser these are very good and we can
also you can see this is Rich colors and
looking good this is our server this is
our server action and we will cut this
thing and we will paste it here and
instead of doing everything here we will
say props dot submit tweet so if you
hover over it you can see this is a
promise of data and error so promise of
something form data so what you can do
we will pass the whole thing here
let's rename this form capitalizes we
will import and we will pass our props
here so we will pass this submit to it
action or we can directly say the action
thing submit to it and here we can
declare the type action and the type of
it is these things let's copy this and
paste here simple directly I am showing
you how I am doing this and this is our
thing and here we have our action so now
when this is action is being done we can
say it is dirt here is our data in
action dot this is our action and we
will pass the data inside it submit to
it and to remove this this error what we
can do we can declare this in another
function handle submit just like
something const handle submit tweet sync
and this is our action or let's rename
it to server action so it will be more
server action more descriptive so we
will face some errors like this because
we are doing we are coding the latest
pattern or the latest thing in the next
yes so we can we may face more such a
problems in the future okay so it's a
functions so yeah
now now we will paste it here and we can
say as any we will see if this is
working or not but there is such that it
will not work functions cannot be passed
directly to client components unless you
explicitly expose it by marking it with
use server so as you can see it is still
not working and we are not getting what
we want this is already a server
function so basically it's not working
so we can't handle the errors properly
in here you can't get the return value
of a server action in a server component
yet okay so we can't get the written
value the action must be code from a
client component to to this we are
waiting for something like use action
State the action must be called from a
client component so we are calling that
but it is still not working okay so what
I am saying is if we remove this thing
let's refresh test and now it's what
it's good it's happy and if I do this
it's happy yeah and let's try to submit
something hello world okay so something
so are we getting anything from here or
no basically this is this is working we
can pass the server action as a submit
to it and here we are calling this thing
but I am not sure if we are Hello World
server actions yeah we are getting this
console.log rest okay okay we got this
yeah we got this we got this so this is
working we are getting the error here so
we can see if the rest dot error is
there then touch dot error and we can
say res dot error Dot message that's
what we want to do that's our whole goal
and if this is not true or the error is
not here then we can show a success
message which means toast dot success
tweet send successfully okay we need to
configure our toaster for that to
configure our toaster we have to install
this and we have to use this toaster in
the top level component so let's go to
the context main component not in the
main component in the layout go to app
in the layout this is our server
component keep remember in the
supervised provider this is the
overclient component so in the client
component we are already showing a toast
here you can see so now here we can show
a toast and it will work so let's go if
we try to tweet okay we are not able to
see any error why is that let's close
this this is not working hit enter okay
we are not seeing anything why is that
we can create a client combo inside a
server component so you can see this is
composed to it this is our server
component and we are passing This Server
action into a client component and we
are calling this from here so this is
just like in API which is working yeah I
got this this is just an API so you
still have to do this things here so top
stored error is not working so let's
console.log let's see what is happening
here res dot error and if we try to hit
it is it is being low but I think it is
doing Globe from here okay so maybe we
have to refresh this whole thing
something new we are getting this but we
are not number one thing we are not able
to see this thing number second where
where is this consulted look I'm not
sure how this is we are able to see the
console.log but let's see what is
happening now let's run our server again
and we will see what is happening
because we are not logging any data and
it is still showing so that's what I am
trying to figure out oh okay okay okay
so that's the wrong thing we have did so
we are reporting in drone got it now it
will work it will work now yeah
something happened same something
happened good let's try it again we can
wrap this thing into try catch the whole
thing
if you hit the Tweet yeah now we are
able to see our error we are getting
this error from our server component and
this is true this is awesome so now
something is working so we have to
restart our server and we need to import
our files correctly we were doing it
wrong that's why you are facing the
problem so now we can remove this and
now we are creating everything from here
so it's not a cleaner approach it's good
we can say this is our form directly we
are calling from here and this is our
function which is a server function so
this is all good but I would say trbc
handles it very beautifully okay so if
you visit the trpc mutation you will
find that it is very good it's my
opinion you can have yours so now over
this is saying that it boilers the
policy why is that because we are
creating a component server super based
client and this uses the API key which
is NN key and which is public key
so that's why we are not able to access
our tables so to access over tables we
need a secret key to top level key which
we will use only in server because this
is a confidential key and we must not
reveal it to the public to the client so
that's why if you go to the super best
provider and I think in the supervised
context somewhere we were using in the
library in the middleware yeah it's good
so I think we are missing something we
need to create a server client which
will handle all this stuff so super bass
client this is not what we want so from
the JS Library what I am saying is from
Super page yes here we have super best
client and we need to create a server
client this supervised doesn't have
access to over tables that's what I'm
saying and this is a confidential or a
server code and this is not a public
code so we can remove this thing we
don't need this here what we need is we
need a Super Bass client super best
server client you can say which is
confidential and which will use a secret
key so supervised client you can say
this is a new supervised client and it
will accept first one is supervised URL
so it is in the process dot EnV dot
subabase URL and another thing is super
best secret case so
process.env dot superbase secret key
like that and it will say that it is it
may be undefined so what we can do if
this is defined so we can say Super Bass
URL is equal to const Super Bass secret
key this is a secret key which I have
shown you already in this in your Super
Bass table editor in the project setting
in the API this is what is secret this
key has the ability to bypass row level
security so it is secure and you can use
this thing process.env dot super best
secret key like that and if not if this
doesn't exist or if this doesn't exist
then we can return the error and in the
error in we can return message supervis
credentials not provided like that
because this is what we are sending here
so we want to send the same schema so
that we can show this clear message so
here we what we can do here we can use
this and here we can use this so it will
not complain no so it will not complain
now we have our super best server client
and here instead of super based server
client we will use the super best server
so to insert into our table we will use
super based server from tweets like this
and to get the to get the user to get
the current user we need to use the
previous super best thing what I'm
saying is const superbase is equal to
the previous thing which we have removed
create server component client this
thing it accepts cookies and it accepts
headers so this is our client component
this variables know that we have located
no not so super best client here we will
say super best client dot dot get user
so it will get the current user and it
will helps us to insert in our tables
just like that now you can save this and
it will work nicely this is complaining
postgres error so what we can do here is
postgres error it is complaining that
now we have two things data and error
error has message but here error is say
said to be postgres error but here we
are sending the error indifferently so a
is any does it work so a type script may
be pain sometime but you can fix this
error so what you can do you can copy
this whole thing and you can paste it
over here now this will not complaint so
now we we have we are getting the error
in the message type and we are getting
the data like this so the two things we
have but still the error can be possible
server or the error can be the error
object which has message so now let's
try this and this should work this time
hello world if you create a tweet super
basic credentials not provided
credentials are not provided why is that
because maybe we don't have or this
variable is named next public because
this is a public think and we are also
exposing it to the client okay so if you
go to the context where is this in the
supervised provider I think here okay so
this this should work now click on treat
Super Bass credentials are not provided
so this means we don't have one of them
two variables so if you go to the EnV
local you can see we have our secret key
and secret key named ronly it is s e c r
e t it is a confidential key and you
should not show this to public I am
saying it again it is a very
confidential and it has all the access
to your database and your everything so
this
URL and that's what we need okay so
remember to name them correctly so now
if you try to submit it will work tweet
sent successfully now our tweet is
working if you go to the database in the
tweets you should able to see the Tweet
here you can see everything is looking
good and nice and this is the username
which have submitted this with so that's
how we have where is this in the compose
to it we have created a server component
we have created a client component
we learned how to pass how to handle
errors in server component and do all
things as you can see we are now able to
successfully submit a tweet let's do it
again copy some lower map sim a long
paragraph Maybe
so you can see this is a long paragraph
if we tweet this
this way it is sent successfully and in
the network tape you can see all the
requests so these all are the requests
which is
working on in the backend you can see
this is the tweet and this is how it is
being sent and we are getting some data
from our server as well
this is a server action
okay so now let's close this thing
I just want to show you that it is
basically sending API request nothing
much
and here we are able to see our tweets
we just now have to face them and show
to the main component in the main
component here we are fetching all the
tweets so here we will Define our get
bits function first we will create our
Super Bass server client just how we
have created in our server component so
this is how we we will create our thing
so what I want is I want this to be used
on the same place
so I can create a yeah so we have
supervised URL everything is good and
here we have our super based light so
this is a JS Library I think it may not
work so we can try this at least there
is no worry in trying we can try this
okay so this is an async function and
here we have over Super Bass server
client new supervis then do anything
basic simple we will figure out how to
handle this stuff much smoothly or much
nicely in a very much organized way this
looks ugly as for now but yeah we can
handle this for now
so now we have our supervised server we
just need to fetch all that bits for
that
I can show you the example how the data
is being fetched so in the fetching you
can see get data here we are fetching
the data if this is okay we are
returning the data and this is how we
will get the data so what we can do
const superbase gives us two things data
and error you can await we can say Super
Bass server not secret key server Dot
from tweets and we can select all the
records you can see we have all the
records but we also want to select the
profile with the tweets because we want
to show something here we want to show
the username we want to show the user
profile also
okay so we want to join this table as
well so you can see username and full
name so we will join this table the
username the name and the Tweet later on
we will also join the likes bookmarks
and all the other tables for now let's
join the user table so if you go to API
docs here you will find how to join this
so in the trades you can see you can
read the for Interval like that select
some column other table and here you can
select so what we can do here we can
select all the rows from the current
Table in the other table which is
profiles table we can select everything
from profiles as well can we show
everything from profiles on the client
let's see if profile doesn't have any
secret or confidential thing so it is ID
upgraded username profile so we can
select the username in full name
basically for now so we can say Here
full name and we can say we need the
username name and we can as for now
let's console.log the data so we can see
what is going on here okay so the data
is not typed full name and username so
if you go here and if you hit the
refresh now we should be able to see
something here okay so we have to call
this thing over here so const data is
equal to get tweets and we have to avoid
this and to avoid this we have to make
this function a synchronous now this
will work you can see we are getting
some data this is hello word username is
Club folders and the name is null you
can see the full name is null and we are
getting the table as well so you can see
we are getting the profiles and we are
getting the main data as well taught so
here we can say what it returns so it
will be type save so what it returns so
here if you hover over it you can see
overrides the type of return data so how
to do this let's see if the supervised
talks has anything related to returning
the super base
returns type from table type script
TS with supervis yeah so here you can
see export async so this is how we are
returning the movies ID and titles and
here we can say type of get movies but
it will show us the title but we want to
show the correct response here I think
there must be docs related to returns
foreign
so here as you can see we can override
the data by defining here so if we
Define a string over here so you can see
this is string order this data is string
or null so we can type the data over
here so to type the data we have the
database types here all the types we
have generated previously in our
previous video
so we just need to join two tables so
forward here we can say the database
import the data first of all we need to
import this thing okay so we are not
getting the imported thing here so we
can import so in the database we have
some types in the public in the tables
instead of doing the tables yeah in the
tables we have tweets
we are getting the tweets here all the
tweets and we are getting the profiles
as well so if you go over here where
this no you just need to copy this thing
you can profiles and here you can see
profiles so now if you hover over the
data you can see we are getting
something but in the tweets you can
suggest what do we need it is a row and
it is also Arrow now you hover over it
you can see we are getting some data
which is a created ID profile this is
okay but here we are getting only full
name and username so we can select we
can modify the type and you will see how
we will do that also so profiles is is a
row and which is a array like that so
now if you hover over it you can see the
profiles is now in Array note array it
is just a single so we can remove this
now it is good so now if you click data
dot okay so it is so we are returning
the array of this whole thing so now
this is an array so if we go to the
zeroth element and we go to profiles and
now here we can
print the full name and but we'd only
want to select something so we can pick
from our types so we want to pick full
name and we want to pick the username
only two things we want here so you can
search the pick type script in the
documentation so here you can pick the
desired columns like that so now if if
we have full name and profile like that
so now if you go here on the application
if you refresh this now you will see
Club of order signal which is the first
element of our thing so we are getting
all the things we need and now we can
return this whole data and this will be
nice and easy so you can return it
directly and here we have our data if we
get any error so we can show the error
okay so this is something wrong with
this so here we what we can do if we
have data dot error we can show an error
here to its node available okay tweets
or we can show server something wrong
with server something along with the
supervis or we can say the server and
here we want to show the data if it is
available so if we can say data dot data
is here so instead of data we can say
the return the return all the response
response dot data is available then
restore data dot map directly and here
we have our tweet and inside our Tweet
now we have a tweet ID you can see
everything is typed save now here we can
set tweet.r profiles.what is this this
is full name and if it doesn't exist
don't show anything and here we can show
the username here we will show the time
when this is created so we can use the
datejust library for it and the relative
time plugin so if you search dgs we'll
use this thing so go to new terminal
install pnpm install date yes and if you
search if you go to the documentation
display and time from now so it requires
relative time plugin to work so if you
search you just need to also import this
thing so what I'm saying is import to
AGS from thgs import relative time
plugin and you can what you can do here
you can
j.js.xtend and you can extend the plugin
like this so import relative time from
this and now you can extend this thing
and now you can use this format here
from now so here we are what we can do
teachers day cheers here we can give it
a the Tweet when this is created and we
can say from now now it will show us the
relative time and this is our tweet text
here we can show to it dot text this is
everything else we will do after the
like we have implemented the like
functionality and the other
functionalities so for now let's save
this thing and see if this is working or
showing some error so now you can see we
have two tweets and it is showing nice
and good we can submit it to it let's
copy some another lower map some now
tweet this tweet sent successfully but
now this is not refreshed so we have to
refresh this and then it is it should be
available okay so it is not available
so what we can do we can disable the
caching if you go over here it is
enabled the caching
for now we don't want it background
reveal is a very validates the data at a
specific time interval on demand we will
data based on the email such as an
update yet it is fetching and next it
will debilitate so we can do something
like this so in the next case we have
something so in the revalidated tag here
we should have something console.log we
will edit take okay so this is the API
route I am talking about the this is
that's why it is very fast you can see
this is like very quick 78 millisecond
because we are hitting the cache notice
hitting the default so when we have
created the Tweet we are on to
rehabilitate the data so to revalidate
the data we need to we can directly to
this we can set this to zero I think so
it will revalidate again and again let's
try this now this is not working let's
see this in the server actions
it is saying that when we have submitted
a product to the card we can develop it
the path this is a used client component
you can see increment client here we are
using a server component this is what we
have did now custom invocations without
start transition yeah
I want to see the documentation not
testing
Dynamic data phases are phase requested
specifically opt out for caching
Behavior by setting the cache option to
no store OD validate to zero that's what
we are doing we are rev editing this to
zero so instead of here this is our main
component so inside of defining the
revaluation the tag here we have to do
this here and it is saying that main
component cannot be used as CSX we can
also separate this whole thing out into
the separate file for now yeah now you
can see we are getting all the three
tweets because we have disabled our
caching if we try to submit again we are
not seeing we have to refresh this thing
to be able to see two very words now
yeah this is hello world we are seeing
two lovers this is hello world
second tweet tweet said successfully we
should see three hello world now if you
hit refresh hello word hello word hello
word two yeah it's working so we have
disabled the caching for now you can see
the cache is missed and it is taking
some more time now what is your main
concern is when we submit any tweet we
want to revalidate the whole thing okay
so revalidate the path note path we want
to revalidate or there is something
called mutation
success mutation in the compost it let's
go to here supervised server from insert
when this is successfully done you want
to refresh the page so routed we can use
a router from next router latest const
so let's go to the documentation here we
have something called router Router
there is something which I have used in
my previous tutorial and the
documentation is not nice I would say
previously there was good documentation
which was a development version of the
documentation of latest Snapchat
features use router yeah this this is a
thing I'm saying in validating the case
server actions can be used to revalidate
the data on Demand by path or by case
Tech what is this revelated take here so
if we are using the
Nexus API routes then we can really take
it like this
but we want to do inside our server
actions that's why I think we need very
validated path so I think here we can
revalidate our path revalidate okay what
it is saying revalidate now this is not
revalidate the path and it will accept
the path is a home page so now if we
submit anything yeah you can see that we
haven't refreshed and this is
automatically getting populated Auto
revalidate to it you can see we are Auto
revalidating this thing so this is
working nicely now we can demo our
consort.log which is here in the page in
the main component you can remove this
thing we can also put this thing into
the separate component or the functions
so in the app or in the library create a
super base create a new folder I think
supervised in the create a new file get
tweets dot TS export constant tweets and
here we can use this thing over here as
simple as it is
save this and we will just import here
so this is how we are extracting the
logic out of here it will be much better
import the database also yeah it's
looking good let's see if this is
working or not yeah this is working and
one thing more is remaining when we
compose a tweet in the form client I
want to reset the whole form
so how should we reset the form okay so
to reset the form
there is something reset for HTML
cool there is something called a type
reset which will reset everything you
can see this is action.php the page if
we try to do integrate submit this image
this yeah everything is good but I want
to reset phone
which we can basically this is a client
component you can see so we can just do
it directly what I mean is we can have a
button type is reset and we can give the
reference to this button and we can
programmatically call this so reset ref
is equal to use ref it is a button HTML
button element initially it is null we
can pass the reference to this I haven't
used this approach but I think this can
work we can give class name as a
invisible so it is invisible and when we
have successfully sent the Tweet we can
click this button like this so it will
this is a tweet with
Auto reset if you hit enter you can see
it automatically reset our form which is
good I I don't know this is a correct
approach but yeah this is a one approach
which you can use to reset your form so
that's how we have submitted our tweet
and everything is looking good for now
this is maybe hard for you because I
know next shares this is the latest
things which we are doing so as you can
see here is our timeline and this is
looking good as for now this is all
being rendered server side so if you hit
refresh then you will see all the tweets
rendered instantly or like it is not
being rendered on Clyde that's why we
don't have any loading indicators at all
so it will be faced directly
now what we need to do we need to
implement our like feature and our
bookmark feature so in the new Twitter
we can also bookmark tweet directly from
here so we can implement the feature we
can Implement a save button here and
then we will see how to do The Bookmark
feature implementing bookmark and like
feature the both logic is similar very
similar and you will see how we get that
so this is our application inside the
main component we are rendering all our
tweets so first of all I will separate
this component out into a new component
so let's create a new component and also
the other thing is you can see here we
are using Pascal case and here we are
using some another case so I will change
the case to smaller case so here I will
say left side part like that we will
also auto update the Imports as well so
here you can see this is looking good so
that we have consistent naming in our
whole application here we will say main
component component yes let's change
this here we have our right section or
yeah let's name it right section just it
is complaining and it is saying main
component cannot be used as CSX
component it's return type is not
available
[Music]
so this is our client component as you
can see we have some hooks inside here
but we need a server component so this
is our page here we are getting all the
data and here we are fetching all the
data so why it is not working is it is
saying that promise element is missing
okay so we need to mark it as a react
dot server context no let's see if Nexus
has some type for it server no
okay so to use async server component
with type script ensure you are using
typescript 5.1.3 or higher end types
react okay so that's why we are facing
the problem so we need to update our
typescript as well if we go to
package.json so if we go to our
package.json and here we can find out
the typescript version we are using so
you can say 540.1 and it is not updated
that's why we are facing that problem
let's update the type script as well we
don't need typescript as a dependency we
can use it as a div dependency and types
react is 18.2.8 this is also not updated
so we can put all these things inside
div dependencies so open a new terminal
because the project I am building I am
building it for like two months and I
haven't tested anything for two minutes
now I am doing all the things now that's
why we are facing some problems with
versions
so now what we will do pnpm 8 as save
div and we will update all these things
inside our Dev dependencies also the
type script let's remove all these three
things and it will work just like fine
save this hit enter so now we have all
the latest version
5.1.3 yeah and
18.2.8 yeah it is higher so now it will
work nice save this and now if we hit
the refresh let's PNP and brand new
again and if we reload our window now
our error should be gone okay it is
still here now it's searching on Google
and see if this works or not
so it is showing that it is async server
component okay so we type script let's
see restart the TS server we can do a
lot of things here we can also enable
this typed route feature that's good so
this is over here to use and ensure you
are using if you are using old you may
updating the latest version and types
should resolve this issue okay but we
are still facing the issue or maybe we
are not using the version which we have
operated to so here we can select our
typescript version to use workspace
version Wi-Fi 1.3 which is this yeah
okay so you can see the error is gone
that's why we were also facing the
problem when we are trying to submit
something inside our server component so
if we go to our
form so here you can see p here defined
as any so let's remove this as well now
you can see we are not seeing any error
it is fixed so updating your typescript
version and configuring it from here
select type is extrogen and U is a 5.1.3
version and it will be fixed or you can
use the use work work space version as
well also update your react types both
so inside package.json this version and
this version this both needs to be
updated okay so now we are good so let's
also update this so this is a client
component we are using this inside
server component so I will create
another component which is client
components client components and I will
put this into client components because
this is a client component so we can
differentiate it better yes I will also
rename this server component to S cell
components and I will update this now
things should be good
so now the naming is consistent you as
you can see we have also defined our
functions separately over here here we
are getting the tools it is for our
timeline and things are now good to go
so now we can create our further things
we can create our features like like
feature and bookmark feature first of
all we need to also add a button of
bookmark let's remove this and see what
is going on we refresh this yeah it's
good some errors we are getting from
pnpm updating to yarn works as well but
for now we can proceed it you can see
this is being rendered so in the client
component we can create a new form but
before that in the main component here
we are rendering everything so first of
all we will create a new client
component which is tweet tweet.tsx we
can also update this form client
components so we can say compose tweet
compose tweet form and then we need to
also update all the namings I am fixing
the naming post Tweet form like that now
you can also update this props at school
and in the client company compose to it
form and here we are importing notice
compose create form so it is correct and
now it is good to go we have fixed over
naming we've fixed a few things here and
there so in the now we need to go inside
main component so here is our tweet
rafce capital letter first and in the
main component here we can cut this
whole thing and here we can put this
thing we can import the tweet from
client components and here we can pass
our ID as well so we can say key is to
get root ID and other than that we can
pass the whole tweet as a props so tweet
is equal to tweet and here we can say we
are accepting tweet and this is tweet
probes so type tweet probes is equal to
feet and here we will Define what with
so let's hover over this tweet and we
can copy this whole thing or what we can
do go to kit tweets and here we are
returning so this is our type so copy
this and this thing import the database
from library super best types and here
we have a word with just like this or we
can define a type and we can use this
everywhere so what I'm saying is type
feed type so we are sure that we are
using the same thing here and there save
the thing do we type and we can export
from here export type to type and we
will use this over here so instead of
doing this we can do tweet type import
the other things as well this icons Ctrl
X and that's how import the pages as
well and the relative time plugin this
is how it will work so now we have
created a separate component for tweet
and we are using the same type here and
there and it is good now it is much more
organized and looking beautiful so if we
go to our application it is running and
everything is code now we will go to the
Tweet component here and we will create
our like button let's create the like
and we will see how to implement the
bookmark feature as well so the live
feature is nothing we just need to
insert a row inside our likes table so
if we go to super base our project
dashboard and here is our tweet clone in
the table editor here you can see we
have over like stable here we need to
insert Arrow insert some data we will
say who the user so who is the user who
is like which tweet so we will specify
user ID and tweet ID and we will save
both of these so that we can know who is
this user who has like this to it then
we can also fetch all the users from a
single date we just need to get all the
data from this table we will just say
give me all the users who have liked
this post so we will say select all the
users from like stable where the Tweet
IDs is simple so now what we will do
here we will create another server
action so this time we are not using the
form element we will use something
called start transition or a new thing
in the Nexus server if you search server
actions
so this is how we are submitting our
tweet but this is how we can also use
this for a button where is this so this
is this thing use transition hook so
this is basically a client component so
we need to import use transition from
here from react and this is a client
component we can specify this with use
client a server component can have
client component inside but a client
component can't have server component
inside it so it will work just like as
it was working and we just need to do
this transition
we will say is with pending so it gives
two things allows component to avoid
undesirable loading instead by waiting
for content to load before transitioning
to next system so it's good you we can
take a reference to this what is this
excuse as two things is spending and use
transition let's do update the state
without blocking the UI okay this is
cool thing so you can see the demo of
this so currently we are now at the
about tab if we click on the post we now
have post if we click on about and
contact it is fast but this is slow okay
why is that start transitioning and set
tab to Next Step cool system method to
use this okay now let's see how we can
use this with our server actions is like
pending and start transition it gives
Boolean and start transition function so
we can name it whatever we want so we
will just name it start transition and
when this is clicked we will add a row
so this is hard button and when this is
clicked we can name it Button as tool so
this is much better so when this is
Click you can copy the whole thing I
will Implement a function called like to
it and we will pass the Tweet ID to the
function like that so now we need to
implement our like tweet feature or we
can set the light tweet function so
inside the actions we are importing add
item from our server actions okay so
this is how we can import it from so in
the server component we can create new
thing or in the super base here we can
declare use server as well like this and
here we can export the like to it
feature or lightweight function as well
is equal to async it will accept the
Tweet ID which is a string and then we
just need to do the same thing here not
same basically we need this thing if we
have supervised URL in supervised secret
key then we need to await super based
server Dot from behave like stable dot
insert and it will ask us to insert
something okay so we here we are not
joining the database that's why it is
not giving us Auto completion now we
should have over Auto completion yeah we
have Auto completion so here we can say
random quid the Tweet ID is which is
passed s tweet ID here we have the user
ID we can find our user we can also pass
the user ID over here that's the good
thing user ID which is string and here
we should have the user ID so for that
we can use a hook code use users this is
a auth helper which is given to us by
react it gives us two things I think it
uses user which can be user or null okay
so here we can also make it condition if
the user exists then only like this to
it otherwise don't like this if the user
exists user and user dot ID exist which
is by the way exist if user exist then
like this tweet otherwise toast dot info
or we can say toast. error error would
be not good simply we can show a message
we can say
please login to like a tweet just like
that here we can pass two things so
instead of passing the parameters as
different different variables we will
make it a object so it will be much more
easier for us to pass it down here so
what I'm saying is we need a tweet ID
and we need a user ID and these both are
interesting we can say we have tweet ID
which is string we have user ID which is
also a string and here we can pass over
user ID as well that's thing we need and
it will create a row inside our likes
table and then we can revalidate or we
can update our UI that it is like that's
how it is simple so here we can import
and we can pass down things here twit ID
is tweet dot ID and user IDs user dot ID
like that and let's see if this is
working or not so here we are and also
log this out we can see if this
something went wrong data and error we
can log console.log broke data and error
and we can also load this so it will be
more descriptive so here is our
application if we click on the like
button so we are liking over to it
ourselves so it is saying please login
to like a tweet which means the user is
not defined so we can log the user as
well here we can see what is going on so
if we try to the user is null why is
that when we have sign in Wise user is
why is user not logged in if we can
tweet yeah if we can tweet which means
we are login then why it is not showing
if we go to application localhost so
there is some there is no other place
where we have used this so if we go to
our context our main context where we
have defined all the logic for
authentication which is in the app
directory we have components we have
library in the app directory yeah we
have super based provider here we are
using everything yeah the router tools
refresh is a thing which we can use to
refresh our router superbase dot oauth
so I think we can use this also we have
to use this use State create browser
super best light and then here we can
call this whole thing we can say
superbase.aut.getuser.10 it will give us
the result inside the result we can do
all the stuff basically so instead of
console.logging it remove this and here
we have the response which is user
response fresh dot data which is data is
user and we can say rest dot user data
dot user dot ID otherwise you can say
the user is not logged in okay so it is
also possibly undefined or the null so
here we can say if the result or data
exists and this exists then do this okay
so what it is saying is having some
problems with that const user is equal
to race dot data dot user and here we
have our user we can say you user dot ID
like that yeah and we can show a loading
indicator when this is being pressed but
we will see what it is you can also show
if this failed so we can say cache cache
the error and show a toast message
authentication failed and instead of
doing it inline we can create a new
function as well but for now let's
proceed with it and see what is
happening so if we click on dislike okay
something worked this time and here you
can see over like that's what I'm
talking about if you go here and user ID
and we can refresh this to ourself
because we have liked the state and you
can see we are able to see and we if we
go to refresh this the statuses we can
see select a record okay so this is a
tweet ID and we can find out which to it
is this we can filter our table
with the Tweet ID so you can see Hello
World we have liked hello world and
let's like this time this whole text if
you click on this and new like row will
be inserted into our table which you can
see and this tweet is the long text you
can say so this is how we have created
our main Logic for implementing like now
what we can do here we also have this
like pending so when it is pending we
can show three dots or something we can
disable the button if it's like spending
and we can change it to a red hat if the
user has lagged it to it or not so as
you can see this is our project and here
is our app if you refresh this allo our
tweets are being rendered nicely but
here you can see some white background
is here so we want to remove this white
background so for that I will go to in
the layout and here in the HTML what I
will do I will do it I will make the
whole background black so now I think
this is still not black so let's inspect
the element and see what is this so we
can then debug this thing so if we try
to make it hidden so we can say what is
the property I don't it's hidden sticky
and then after Excel it is flexed so
it's good but I think the hidden
property tell it so I use television so
much that I've forgot what is the
visible property so it is not visible I
am more into okay so let's give it
visibility let's make it hidden so now
you can see there is no white background
but this is the problem of this
container if we remove this you can see
there is some white background at the
bottom so I think we can give it the
class name of let's let's give it
background color of black no it's not
working or let's give it overflow of
hidden yeah this is working so what we
need to do is remove this thing go to
the right section and here what we need
to do we are giving it height of screen
so let's cut this part now it is not
sticky because we should give it some
fixed height to make it sticky okay so
instead of giving Edge screen we can
give it 90 of the viewport yeah now it's
sticky and it's good 90 report but I'm
worried about this white thing and it is
because of the Overflow X property so
what we can do we can give it overflow
hidden and only the X overflow is hidden
so now you can see this is gone but it's
it's scrollable it is uh so instead of
overflow Y is Overflow scroll we can say
overflow y Auto so when this is bigger
so the white will be there otherwise now
this is good so when we try to make it
large so now it is scrollable and it's
good but when the screen is bigger and
the content is inside the container so
every content so now it is working so
now it's look it's looking good so where
we were we want to implement our live
functionality we want to show all the
likes so there are some different
different approaches how we can show the
likes on our timeline so the first
approach is fetch all the likes with the
post so let's assume this is our post
and count all the likes and show here so
how many likes this tweet has so we will
fetch the likes count with the post when
we are fetching the post from our
database the other method is fetch all
the likes on each separate post but what
I am worried about if you face for each
post you have to send a lot of API
requests to your database and which is
not a good idea so we will reduce our
API request number and we will fetch the
likes count with our post so what I am
saying is let's implement it so if you
go to the main component this is our
server component and here we are getting
the Twist and the other thing we want to
improve is this is Super Bass and this
is get tweets instead of get tweets we
can rename these two functions or
queries or two different things so we
can make two different things so this is
for queries queries yes and then what we
can do we can cut this thing because
this is a mutation this is a database
mutation so inside supervised create a
new field called mutation so we are
separating out queries and mutation now
this is good okay and the other thing is
if you go to the queries this is also
your server and this is also your server
that's okay but I am worried that we can
export this also we can in the utils not
in the utils we can create a index.ts
and we can export or subabase server for
that we also need these things in the
index.ts we can import and then we can
import the supervised client as well and
for that for the fix we can do is string
and as string Super Bass server client
this is a super best server Library okay
so let's name this super best server
this is good so now we can use this
thing over here so we can remove all of
these we can import like this supervised
server from here and we can import the
random uuid from crypto save this thing
this is good and we need to do that here
also so we'll remove the unused code and
we will import everything what we need
so now it's much cleaner approach you
can save this now we have queries and vo
mutations so if you want to face
something we will Define here and if you
want to insert some data or update some
data we will Define here all the
functions so now if you go here if we
refresh everything is working as it was
working previously okay so now what we
want to do is you want to fetch the
likes count with all the tweets we are
fetching now what we can do we are
saying that give me all the profiles as
well but we want to join the likes table
as well so if we go to our super based
dashboards so let's go to supervis
Project
let's go to Twitter clone and here is
over all the tables so we want to join
the likes table as well so here we are
saying that give me the profiles which
is related to the tweets so here are our
tweets and we are saying that okay so
remove this filter we are saying that
this is the profile ID and give me this
profile ID or give me the profile of the
user who has made or who has submitted
this tweet we want to also attach like
who is who is who is liking over to it
okay so we want to query the count also
so for that we have to look for the
documentation so inside API docs here we
can see how to get that we can also page
in it we will do this uh at the end of
our course what we will do we will fetch
only a few tweets for once and then when
the user Scrolls down we will fetch more
tweets so really specific columns some
column other column other table foreign
key good but other table is fits and we
want to with filtering okay so we we can
this is how we can filter also insert a
row insert menu update subscribe to
changes read four intervals so this is
what we want to do let's assume we have
likes table then we can fetch who has
like this tweet or who which to it is
this so we can face the detail but we
want to do from another Direction so
let's try this comma and we will say
like stable and in the likes table let's
go here and the foreign key is I think
the ID okay so let's do it like that and
we will see what it is giving to us or
what we are getting so const if you are
getting any error or something I think
this will not work but let's try if we
were using Prisma or some Oran that's
another thing but let's see what it
gives to us data and error return data
yeah column tweets dot likes does not
exist and that's we know that's good
because the problem is we have tweets so
let me make you understand so we have
tweets inside tweets we have a foreign
key you user ID so we can fetch the user
details or the author of The tweets
fetch the author details who tweeted
this tweet on the other hand we have our
likes table inside we have two for in
case we have user ID and we have tweet
ID so from this side we can fetch the
Tweet detail and as well as the user
detail I want to do in it in one one
query so we can make two queries but I
don't want to make two queries let's see
how to achieve it so here is the thing
we count directly face the count of the
tweets which is related to direct
relatives so here we can't say that give
me all the likes of this tweet or give
me all the count like that we can't do
that because we are not using an orm
this is something which Superbass offers
us to fetch all the things so what we
can do now we have to fetch the Tweet
count for every single tweet so here we
can define a single function get likes
count this is how and we can Define it
will accept a single tweet ID so tweet
ID which is string and it will return
the count of the likes for this to it so
we can say return a bit Super Bass
server Dot from and which is the likes
table give me all the count of the table
us where we can say the equal we can say
the Tweet ID is equal to the Tweet ID so
now it will return so first let's
consider.log or we can directly log this
thing yeah so constant result we can
console.log result and we can return
this as well so this thing we will use
inside our get likes count so if you go
to the Tweet component this is over
tweet and this is a client use client so
this is a client function or you can say
the client component this is complaining
that okay because this is the query and
we have to import it from mutation so
now we have mutation so inside the
client component you can't Define a
server components that's the thing
that's one thing we have to remember but
inside a server component we can have a
client component so now we have here a
new problem which is this oh this is our
server component we do you can see this
is our server thing this is a server
function we can't face directly using
this function on the client so that's
why we need to Define in some more
components so instead of doing this a
use client we will do this is a use
server component
that's why we can't Define a used State
here so we have to remove the ReUse
State and we will cut this thing we will
Define another component which is like
button to TSX and this is a client
component finally this is a final client
component we need and it is a like
button simple so we will cut this whole
thing we will paste here because we can
Define use State inside our client
component import the use browser super
best client as well cool and then we can
cut the whole thing from here and we can
paste it here this thing also we can cut
from here paste here import the like
tweet import the toast import this and
that's good tweet.id so it will accept
some props so we can say like button
props and we will Define the props type
which is tweet ID which is string and
here we will say this is our tweet ID
and instead of doing tweet ID and tweet
ID we can simply do this tweet ID save
the whole thing here we will import our
like button and we will pass down the
Tweet ID which is tweet.id like that
save this thing remove these functions
also this one we don't need this and now
this is a server component and we can
fetch all the details of the Tweet here
so if we go to our application you can
refresh this and it should work as
expected like this tweet and it should
work in the likes table we have three
likes now good so here we will fetch the
tweets so you can say const get to it
likes count is equal to get likes count
and here we will pass the tweet.id like
that and now it will give us the like
count so we can consort.log and we can
find out what is this so if we go here
if we refresh this we will get a lot of
things okay so so here you can search
for a foreign relation between likes and
count in the schema but no matches for
fall okay okay so we did some mistake so
it is assuming that it is a count table
and give me all the okay this is not we
want so instead of this so we can find
out how to count rows super base client
how to get count start okay so we can
pass around the count exit you can say
give me all the rows and we can Define
things here we can Define count and
which is true now if we what it is okay
no it it doesn't accept true it accepts
estimate exact plant so we can say
accept so it will return as the exact
count of a single tweet so you can see
count is fun you can remove this thing
we don't need any data we need only
count okay so we need something so
instead of that we can just say we need
only ID so now we are getting something
so this is test two it has one this dude
has zero count distribute has one this
two it has yeah so we are getting the
Tweet count now and we can show the
Tweet count over there so here here we
can Define the returns type as well we
can say what we are getting we are
getting the ID and we are getting the
count so okay so let's not Define the
type here we can directly render over
count get tweet likes count here because
we don't need to worry about the ID this
is just for the purpose of like we need
something that's why we are getting that
and where is our like button so here we
can pass the count likes count as well
likes count is equal to get likes count
dot so it is a promise basically we have
to await this that's why we are getting
a lot of things there so now this is
good toad get likes get tweet likes
count this is what we need so it is dot
you can see we have count so you can
pass down the count and if we go here we
can see we can this is a number and we
can show the likes count here near to
the button like this likes count here we
have our likes count okay so it is
saying it can be null as well so we will
say in the likes it can be null as well
so if this is null if the count likes
count is null then it shows zero save
this thing if we go to our application
and now you can see one like and zero
like zero like one like that's cool and
it is sending rumors request to the
server but okay this is okay because
this is the only choice we have if we
use super best clangers Library if you
are using an orm then it will be much
easier task for you you can directly
join the tables and you can do a lot of
things now in the like count here we
want to Define it in one line or what
I'm saying is flex item Center like this
and we can skew it some space space X2
and we can yeah this is looking much
like Twitter so if you go to Twitter so
you can see we have the 2D likes after
this after the yeah so this is what we
need we can make it bigger a little bit
class name is W5 H5 and that's good
that's looking good and now we need to
do one more thing we we need to do we
need to find out that if the user who is
currently logged in is liked or not if
the user who is logged in if liked it
then we will show the red Earth so in
the queries here we are getting the
likes count so here we can also get
export const get is liked if the Tweet
is liked or not async and we can get the
Tweet ID and we can so we just need to
find out that if this row exists or not
in the database if this row exists with
the tivitis and the user IDs is then we
will show the red heart otherwise we
will load we will not show the header
this is tweet ID it is string string and
user ID it is also a string then here we
can return we just need to do the same
thing here copy it paste here from likes
select ID count exactly we don't need
the count we need only if this is liked
or not we can remove the count you can
say tweet ID is this and Dot equal we
can say the user ID is user ID so now it
will find the Tweet or if it it will
find a row which satisfy these both
parameters tweet ID and user ID save
this thing and we can fetch this detail
here okay const is like oh wait so if
user has liked so is liked and import
from library and here we will pass down
the Tweet ID as well tweet.it and here
we will pass down the user ID so now we
don't have the user ID so what we need
to do we need to find out the user ID
then we can only know that if this is
liked or not right so for that we need
to create a server thing const superbase
server is equal to Super Bass note these
things supervised auth client create
server supervisor and this thing we need
the exact the exact thing which we have
used to compose over to it so if you go
to the composed bit server component
here you can find out we have used this
thing so that's the first thing we need
to copy this paste here supervised
client supervised server component
supervised client import this import
cookies in headers so that we know who
is logged in currently import this from
next headers because it's a server
component now we have super based client
and it has the user details auth dot so
this is how user data superbased client
auth get user so these two things we
need here so it will find out the user
and we will see or the other thing what
we can do go to the because it will
fetch the details of the user each time
it is rendered instead of doing this we
can get the user details here only one
time and we can pass down the whole
thing over here cut this whole thing
paste it here so we only getting the
user details one time or or we are
sending the API request only one time
this is what it means so yeah so now we
can pass down to Twitter now we can pass
down the user ID so this is our tweet
user data is equal to or you can say the
user ID is equal to user data dot user
dot ID like this and if you go into the
Tweet here we can accept the user ID as
string we can say current user ID
current user ID so it is much clearer
what is this can pass down the current
user ID like that current user ID so it
is saying that it can be undefined so we
will do this we can make a question mark
here and here but now we have problem we
have this is saying that it can be
undefined or it can be null so if we
will go to is liked and we will Define
some custom logic here we will say user
ID can be undefined so we will say if
user ID is not available then just
return this whole thing just like this
so now it is good save this whole thing
save this also if user has like so now
we will so.log what it is giving to us
console.log is user is like and in the
queries instead of directly returning we
can return that user isn't like this
otherwise we can find out if this is
exist or not and we can return it true
here so const data error not this error
we can say we can also say that a single
the user can only like single time nice
and we can say if data dot ID exist then
return we can directly return if use
data.id exist you can say Boolean data
dot ID so if this exists then this is
the activity is liked by the current
user otherwise it doesn't like to buy
the current user so now if you can see
this is a Boolean and we will get if the
user is liked or not so now here you can
see fast true false false false yeah
this is the whole thing so true means we
have like this to it false means we
don't have like this tweet cool so now
we just need to show this over here we
will pass down this thing is is user has
liked and in the like button we will get
this detail over here which is a Boolean
and if this is liked then show the red
heart or we can import the CN Library
over here so do this to this import the
CN helper which will merge all the
Tailwind glasses we can say if his user
has liked then show the color of red so
we can set text to rows yeah now let's
see now it is so we need to find out a
good component so we can show here SVG
elements so react icons so heart icon
where is this yeah so AI feel hurt
whichever you want you can use so what
we what I'm saying is AI feel hurt if
user has liked then show this fill hurt
otherwise show this thing this is simple
and we can remove this thing we can use
the same here and we can say text is
read 600 let's try this refresh this
whole thing okay now we are not able to
see if it is we can use the free
property I think fill from the color
let's give it black for some time
because we have already liked this this
should show a like here but it is not
showing why is this console.load and
let's see so it is giving us undefined
why is that if user has liked okay we
haven't saved this save this now refresh
this okay so refresh this again now you
can see we have some black control files
here good now it is working remove this
fill yeah so now it is red and we have
liked this video you can see this is
good if you hit refresh it will show
that we have liked this to it and this
is good but we want to remove this like
okay so what I'm saying is we also want
to implement the unlike feature so in
the queries in the mutation so like to
it here we can do the same thing unlike
tweet unlike tweet the same thing which
will just delete the tweet from the
database supervised server from likes to
delete dot equal don't forget to use
this equal otherwise it will delete the
whole table you should be careful doing
this and we can say the like which is
the like row so we can say the ID is
like ID you don't need these two things
we just need like ID like ID which is
string so now it will delete from like
stable it will delete a single like from
our database we can remove this we can
also remove this or we can yeah if we
have got any error we will get any error
in the future then we want to debug that
also that's why we are consider plugging
everything so now unlike tweet we just
need to do one thing here so when this
button is clicked when we get this user
then we just need to do one thing if the
user has likes so we can say if if user
has liked then unlike otherwise like
import this it will accept like ID and
the like ID is so we should also get the
like ID from our table or otherwise we
can do one thing we can do one thing
instead of deleting it from using the
like ID what we can do we can do the
same thing the treat ID is tweet ID and
like this the user ID is user ID like
this same same as this so now we have
user ID and tweet ID and we are using
this here so delete this row where tweet
ID is this and user ID is this simple so
we can pass down the same thing as here
good now it is good also here we are
getting the user but we don't need it we
can pass down into the component but
yeah if you don't want to pass down as a
props so what I am saying if you go to
the Tweet component here we are getting
the current user ID so we can pass down
this current user ID into the like
button and here we can use it directly
instead of getting the user again but
that's totally up to you we can remove
that thing and when this cheat is liked
we want to refresh we want to refresh
the like count so what we need to do is
we can revalidate this thing so we can
revalidate this tweet component so how
we can do that so we will find out so
refresh this for now if you go to the
likes table you can see we have three
likes one two and three if we click here
the like is removed now you can see the
like is removed but here the like is not
updated we have to refresh the page find
out okay so this is updated if we click
here not updated but here you can see
this is gone and here this will also
come but because we are changing our
window that's why it is being refreshed
but if we do it here again if you click
the like button this is created a row
but it is not refreshed so we want to
refresh this for that what should we do
so I think we have something yeah it is
liked but we want to refresh it
instantly so now for the simplification
for the simplification purpose you can
revalidate the whole page but this is
not recommended the another way is just
update the UI optimistic update so user
click the on the like button and you
know this will be updated the row inside
of a database so update the UI that's
all so this is called optimistic update
so we are optimistic that this tweet is
successfully liked or the user has
inserted a row into our like table
successfully and we are sure of that so
when this is successfully done you can
directly like you can then and you can
directly update your UI or another way
is evaluate the whole page which is not
recommended but we are going to do here
we validate the whole page just like it
when user like or dislike the Tweet
trivialated the whole page so now here
if you refresh the page everything is
good but if we click on this you can see
this is gone here if you like this to it
this Tut is like if we remove this this
is removed so now it is working like
Char so now only one two it is like and
which is liked by us we can remove this
by clicking on this it is remote and you
can see this row is removed if we like
this tweet again a row will be inserted
and the state is like let's log into a
different account and see if it is can
be liked by multiple accounts so let's
to that also so this is my other account
and you can see this is asking me for
liking the Tweet so here we can see this
is liked but not liked by us so if I try
to so you can you can see we we need to
login so for that if you hit refresh it
will ask us to sign in so let's sign in
I will put my email
ytblogs.app gmail.com I will put my
email
ytblogs.hab it is my recent product
which generates blogs Twitter Searchers
from any YouTube video so I'm using this
demo so let's login so I think it has
sent me the login link let's see yeah so
I have received my request and I will
confirm my email and now I think I am
signed in yeah so if I try to like I can
like this tweet and now if I like this
this has two likes and this is good and
here I am a if I hit refresh you can see
we have two likes now if I like like
this we have two likes and this is
working nicely we can like from multiple
accounts and it is good so let's create
something also this is a new tweet from
another account hit enter and you can
see this is a tweet from another account
this is our username and all is good we
can also order all the tweets you can
see we have we should have a new tweet
here so if we hit refresh you can see we
have a new tweet here we are not able to
see this data in the real time we can
also implement the real-time feature by
using real time updates from super best
but that's for another part we are just
building a basic web application and you
can see our like feature is working
nicely similar to this you can Implement
a bookmark feature as well we are not
going to do that in this video because
this is a simple a same thing similar to
like feature you just need to create a
row inside your bookmarks and you can
you have to delete Arrow from your
bookmark table and that's all about
bookmarking a post as well so now our
like feature is done what we are focused
on now we have implemented posting We
have implemented liking and disliking
now we will implement and the reply
features so anyone can reply to this
post where we have first we have showed
all the likes count we have showed
everything what user is doing on the
website here you can see all the tweets
but there is a very big problem here
what is the problem the performance
problem if you can see on our super
based dashboard the requests are 14 and
708 which is a huge request which is
like this can't be true so we are doing
something wrong here what we are doing
wrong so let's assume we have 10 tweets
and we have 100 users 100 users are
minimal noted a lot so let's assume we
have 10 tweets and we have 100 users who
have visited our web page and now each
of the user will send each request for
each tweet so this means each user will
send 1000 requests every time user
refreshes the page or if the user has
liked any tweet then he also fetch like
100 requests so this is like huge burden
on our server and we don't want that why
it is happening because you can see on
our main component if we are fetching
gate tweets this is totally fine because
we are fetching it only once and this is
totally fine but what we are doing we
are rendering all our tweets here and we
are fetching again and again this thing
so let's assume this component is being
rendered two times so we will fetch this
request two times so this is very bad so
we can't do this this is a very bad
approach we have implemented this
approach we have seen that this is
getting us some problem we are facing
some performance problems now we will
resolve this how we should resolve this
is using chpt so in this video I will
tell you how you can utilize crgbt to
get all the results so basically we want
to fetch all the tweets single time we
want to fetch tweets with the likes
count and we want to also assure that
are we including or do behave like the
Tweet so the user who is authenticated
in the current application is liked a
single to it or not so how should we do
that so we can run a plain SQL query
because super bases client Library
doesn't provide a query like that it is
a complex Courier so we have to build a
plane a square query on our own because
we are not using any orm for now if we
use an orm like Prisma or drizzle or
type on something like that you can do
it with orm but here we are not using an
orm that's why we have to define a
single performant SQL query so for that
as I said I am not good at writing SQL
so I have used crgbt to help me here so
you can see these are my SQL tables and
I have pasted all the SQL tables which
we created I want to fetch all the
trades with likes count can you give me
the best way to achieve this so it gave
me how you can get all the Tweet switch
like on so we don't have to fetch the
likes count again and again for a single
tweet so it will give us the likes count
another thing which I said to it also I
need to include in that query if the
current user has liked the post or not
so it gave me the SQL query that give me
twitch.all so this means give me all the
rows and it is saying that count all the
likes as likes count and it is finding
that if two likes or tweet ID is current
tweet ID and likes to user IDs current
user ID exist or not if it exists then
user has liked the state otherwise it is
not so this is how it is finding all the
twists and from tweets and this is left
joining the likes table and it is
grouping the tweets by tweet dot ID so
this is how it works and then I told
jgbt to order it by latest tweet on the
first of our web page so it gave me
order by so we can copy this query and
you can go to your SQL editor and you
can create a new query and you can paste
it here and I have checked it it is
totally correct and if you run this you
will find all the tweets but for that
you have to get the current user ID so
let's assume our user is something
random so this means this user doesn't
exist so if we run this query then you
can see we have a input a few values so
let's find out the correct view ID here
so for that I have recently query the
same thing so what we I can do I can
show you this is my user id we will pass
this your user ID to the function and
this then this to query so this is a big
query you can see and now if we run this
we can find out all the tweets with the
latest tweet on the top this is new to
it from another account and we can also
find out the likes we can also find out
if the current user has like this post
or not so if you go to bottom you can
see we haven't like this and we can see
if we like this tweet you can see now we
have liked and if you run this query
again we should be able to see true here
so you can see we are now getting true
so this query is working so now we have
to run this query on user main page so
here instead of running a lot of queries
again then again we will only run one
query and it will improve our
performance so for that to connect this
database to our application we need
something called PG pole so if you
search Pages pool postgres Circle pool
on the internet you can find out this
package and we will use this package to
query our database like this so let's
install this let's remove this thing
because you can see we are sending a lot
of requests to the server and it is very
bad we don't want to send too many
requests to our server so we will
install PNP install PC pool in the
source here we will inside the DB in the
utils not in the utils yeah you can
create here PG pool or you can create a
new folder called DB here in the DB you
can say index.ts and here you can Define
your poll so all the details you can
read and let's go to GitHub and find out
how we can use this pool so PG pool we
have to also install the PC here so
let's copy this and install everything
we need PG pool and PG both the things
we need and then we will use physical to
create our instant database instant and
then we can query our database so let's
copy this also instead of variable we
will use const you can supply custom
client Constructor if you want to use
the native postgresq okay so we don't
want this thing we also don't want this
we also don't want this so we need to
Define all the options here import poll
from PG pool like that you can see we
don't have the types that's why it is
not showing us Auto completion so we
will install the types pnpm install PG
pool types so it we are installing the
PG prototypes as Dev dependencies as you
can see now if you hover over it you can
see other types and if you try you can
see all the stuff here so the database
is postgres and the connection is string
which we will get from the database node
EnV we need it from import okay so we
will Define process dot EnV tote our
connection string so what we will do
database connection string so I will go
to my EnV which is confidential and here
I will Define my database connection
string and you can go to supervis on the
project setting in the database here you
can find the node.js database connection
string copy this thing paste here and
here you will here I will reset my
password I will regenerate my password
so that it is good confidential and now
I will paste my password here so now
this is my database connection stream I
will copy this and I will use this here
just like that and I can Define the
other options as well allow exit on idle
true now we have a pool so how to query
okay so let's see all the things SSL is
true yeah so now we can query like that
poll dot connect then and then catch
like this play nice with a syncope so we
want to use a single bit so let's use
that also so what we will do we will
export it export const pool so pool dot
connect and then we can use this so it's
instead of directly exporting this we
will Define our client and then we will
use this cons DV is equal to await or
instead of doing this we can use this
thing this is a self volume function
const poll is we already have a pole and
then we will say pool dot connect okay
this is good and then we can find the
result and all the things here your new
favorite helper method so we can
directly call this also what you think
because it's so common to just run a
query and return the client report
afterwards visible has this built in so
it directly curages that's good so let's
do this one thing first export this pole
and then we will use this export this
for now so we will go to our main
component inside here where we are
getting all the tweets so instead of
this we need to run the query so return
is equal to await we will import the
tool from DB and then we will directly
query the stuff we will directly query
the stuff so like this select dollar one
means the distinct text S name so we
will copy our whole query which is this
copy this thing we'll use this you can
see to install star and here we are
using the current user ID so we want to
pass this as a so we will pass this
thing like this so if you go to current
user ID here you can see this is our
current user ID and in the example of PG
pool you will here you can see this is
over so we can ask share GPT to return
the query with the PC pool so we can say
return the query with using the PG pool
and random uuid variable so you can see
this is a connection string and this is
dollar one so we will set instead of
this this is our dollar one which is the
parameter and then we can directly query
like that don't forget to release the
pool so this is how you can leverage
chair GPT here so it will copy the whole
thing paste it here it will also copy
the query yeah so this is our query and
we are are passing the current user ID
and here we can get the current user ID
as well which is a string here over
query and here we are getting everything
so now if we go to main component here
you can see this is complaining this is
complaining that you have to get the
user ID as well so we can do that that's
not a problem so what we can do we can
pass the user data over here so user
data dot user dot ID like that and we
can cut it from here we can paste it and
here instead of this we can say this is
a string and when the yeah so we can
Define two queries here so query with
current user ID and query without
current user ID like that we can copy
the whole thing we just need to change a
few things we need likes count but we
don't need the user is like simple so we
can run this simple query so what we
need to do is if the current if the
current user ID exists then query so we
can Define the query temporary here
which is a string let query is string or
we can say this is QD without current
user ID and if the current user ID exist
then we can say the queries query with
current user ID and then we will run the
query we will pass the parameters and we
will process the query results like that
pull dot end and that's all what we are
doing now let's remove this four now we
don't need this we don't need this as
well for the moment let's comment
everything out and we will see if this
is working or not so pnpm brand there
and we should be able to see something
for now so now if you go to localhost if
you try to refresh we should be able to
see something here yeah something went
wrong can you use a pool after calling
and on the pole so something went wrong
error password authentication failed for
user postgres okay okay password
authentication has failed so why is that
this is over pool database okay so we
don't need this database thing here we
can directly use without connection
string like that can connection sync
directly and from PG yeah so now if you
try to hit the refresh and we will see
what is happening here we get something
now authentication field executing query
authentication failed for user postgres
this means over connection string is not
correct so let me correct my connection
a string so to check if this is
connecting or not we will first let me
reset my database password again reset
the whole password and I will use here
again good pool mode
6534 okay so connection string is this
connection pulling is this let's copy
this thing this is for the connection
pooling I think we need to use this we
can try it we can see what is happening
refresh this yeah we are okay so now we
got this okay so after changing we have
get everything we want you can see we
are creating ID text profile ID created
it updated likes count and user has
select or not and that's totally awesome
and we can just return this whole whole
query result from here so if this
doesn't exist we can return nothing and
if it exists we can return result.rows
like that so what you need to is you
need to use this pool here this one
connection string for connection polling
not this one this one and then it will
work and now we are efficiently curing
everything okay but it is still getting
some problems like cannot use a pool
after calling and on the pole now we can
remove this thing and we can modify our
treat type and we will return everything
so here we are returning all the tweets
and here we will render everything we
need so restored error is so if this is
error so we can return the error inside
error we can return a message DB queuing
failed and here we are returning all the
rows restore data and we can wrap this
whole thing in the data like that we can
use a sync and await here but we are not
using that for some reason because jgbt
go to us this thing but yeah that's also
possible here we can for this moment we
can say this any but this is not a good
idea so if you come here if you refresh
this nothing is visible and we are still
fetching all the things here we don't
want these things likes count tweet tote
likes count and and the other thing is
which we are getting is in the queries
you can see Twitter stored lights count
and otherwise this user has liked so
tweet. user has liked so this thing but
there is a challenge is that this
doesn't exist so we will wrap this whole
thing in the Boolean here you are saying
tweet type but we will Define any for
the moment so it doesn't show us any
error save this whole thing rest dot
data let's lock this thing so we can see
if we are getting something on the
client not getting we are not getting
anything let's restart the whole server
sometime you may need to restart the
server to get things working okay so we
are not getting anything and it is still
sending a lot of requests to the server
which is auth request we are sending a
lot of oauth request why is that do we
in the like button so in the like button
queries index console.log let's lock the
result as well so you can see what is
happening result yeah something is
working here if we are getting the
result basically result of rows then why
it is not being shown yeah we are
getting the result as well so return the
data okay okay okay okay okay so the
problem is if you visit the poll
documentation you can query like that so
we will use this async a bit note this
not testing I don't like this too let's
cut the whole thing const result is
equal to oh wait hold dot query because
it is a promise and we can see now the
query result and we can wrap the whole
thing into try cage block so if
something went wrong we can console Dot
Lock error otherwise we can return the
data as rest dot you can see rows
because full name is not defined so why
is that cannot read the property of full
name this is this okay so we want to
also fetch the whole profile of the user
so we can ask the chair GPD to modify
our our queries so we also want to fetch
the user author details as well so it
will say that profiles.user yeah so we
can now face the whole thing here as
well so let's copy this thing Ctrl D
Ctrl V remove the extra comma and it is
good so you can see profiles.username so
we are getting the profiles.username as
well we are getting profiles dot full
name as well so if you save this now it
should not complain good now it is not
complaining so here if we refresh this
thing because something is wrong here
missing from close from enter okay okay
so we haven't copied it correctly so
left join joins profile so we have to
join the profile table as well so we are
left joining the Tweet table left
showing likes join and group by yeah so
we have to correctly fix our query Group
by and then order wire so this is a big
query you can see but yeah we have to do
this now we are getting something we are
getting something we are getting text
username full name everything directly
without any hassle so what we can do
here we have to modify this thing here
we are saying tweet.profile so instead
of profiles we can directly save this
thing now it's good you can see we are
directly getting everything so if we hit
refresh this is being rendered one time
but the likes count is still not visible
why is that tweet dot likes count okay
so this is Lex count now it is visible
you can see and if we try to click here
you can see this is updated if we try to
click this is updated and we are also
not bombarding over database with a lot
of requests so if you hit refresh we now
have something 16 000 or 17 000 request
in the last 68 minutes but it will now
we have removed every complexity from
our application like a lot of request we
were doing in the last video so this is
the only time we have to specifically
query a single SQL query otherwise we
don't need to do this okay so you can go
here and you can refresh this a hell lot
of time and this will note you can see
4309 if you hit refresh if you try to to
refresh this it is not changed a lot you
can see this is cool so now we can like
this tweet remove or like and here as
well okay so so if we are not logged in
we are not able to see any tweets that
is not the way I want so if I open this
tab in the new tab this is not we are
not able to see any why is that syntax
error at or near from so this is a bad
thing like not using an orm because it
will make our life complicated as you
can see here qdb dot current user ID if
current user exists then QD is qdv so
let's see what is the problem we are
facing here profiles.full name what is
the problem here we are getting this is
the same likes dot tweet ID profiles
everything seems good to me let's remove
this current editing and let's see if it
we are still getting a problem yeah so
we will fix this problem in the next
video I think we have done a lot of
stuff in this video so I have explained
you how you can optimize your web
application so that a lot of users can
use it many time and you will not
bombard your server with a lot of
requests from clients now if you refresh
you can see we are not bombarding our
server facing some problems with this
query without current user ID so what
was the problem we are using extra comma
here and that's why we are getting the
problem so we are selecting The Columns
and we are then joining and grouping and
ordering everything doing so it's good
so here we can Define our query so our
query is basically this one so if the
query is basically if the current user
doesn't exist then our query is poll dot
query is query without current user ID
that's our query so it is yeah and if
the current user exists then our query
will be query with current user ID and
then we will pass this current user ID
with our query okay so this is for the
parameter this taller one then we can
await this query here we can avoid this
query and here we have our result and
then we can save this thing and now we
have all the tweets here you can see and
if we go to a incognito mode then if we
try to see here still we can see all the
tweets we can see everything is working
nice and good so this is a little bit of
complex query but yeah with the help of
jlcpt we can query our database
efficiently so this is what jpt can do
now what we need to do is here we can
also Define an error so return error
something wrong with curing the DB like
that now save this now this is good so
we are rendering everything and
everything looks good to me so now what
we need to if you go to the like button
so everything is good so you can like we
can dislike we are not bombarding our
server with a lot of API requests you
can see this is still the same yeah what
requests are a lot of fourth requests we
are sending why is that let's find out
there is a reason so this is a homework
for you what you need to do you need to
remove this oath here and you can pass
down the user ID from the tweet and from
the main component so we we have the
user data we have the user ID you just
need to pass down the ID from here you
need to pass down the ID through the
like button enter so it's that's how you
can also remove a lot of like and what
what we can say the oath request to the
Super Bass server that's all now our
application is looking good where is
this so this is our application we can
take to it this is a latest tweet you
can tweet and you can see this is being
rendered here instantly this is is super
fast okay now what feature we can
implement we need to implement our reply
functionality so in the next video we
will implement the reply functionality
what we need to do is similar to Twitter
so let's close everything if we go to
Twitter so here is a tweet and if I
tweet something here you can see if I
click on this button it will open a new
model and now I can reply the to this
Suite so same thing we are going to do
when we I click over here it will open a
model and then I can type my reply after
this if I click on this tweet it will
open a whole new window and then I can
see the replies below so here you can
see this is our application and if you
go to the here localhost 3000 and we are
running our application nicely but if
you go to the queries part we are doing
all these things so this is looking bad
and there is a great chance that you
might do a typo here like we heard it in
the last part like if you type a comma
here and then it will break your goal
thing and you are not able to get this
why it is happening so if you now go to
your application you can see something
went wrong with the server right so we
don't know what went wrong and this is a
very small typo and we can't debug this
thing very quickly that's why it's
always good to use in orm that's why we
are going to use drizzle orm because it
is a typesafe orm you can go to the
drizzle warm website you can go to the
documentation and you can find out that
it's very good over so we are going to
use this so first of all let's click on
pnpm and install all the packages we
need here close this thing pnpm install
all the stuff we need so we will create
a schema.ts file so this is our source
directory inside the DB houses TV thing
okay so we will create a new file called
schema.ts here we will Define all our
schemas which we have created in the
supervised so you can see we have a few
tables and we need to now create all the
tables here this is a simple part but a
repetitive part and you can use share
GPT to do this also firstly so how to do
that using this crcpj so let's go to
chair GPT and here we have our schema so
if you are watching this part then you
also must have watched the previous part
in which we have created all the tables
so if you go to the SQL editor so create
table you here we are creating all the
tables so now what we need to do we need
to create our schema using all these
tables okay so let's copy this thing and
this is my SQL tables these you can say
these are my SQL tables we can copy
everything so this is our profile table
and we can remove this row level thing
here this is already done so we can
remove this this is unnecessary we don't
need this thing in our schema file now
we will tell this jgpt to generate over
schema so generate the orm schemas as
you know that JDP don't have the latest
data so what we will do generate the RM
schema From Below talks so we will paste
the relevant information here so we'll
go to chat GPT or we will go to the
result one because we are using postgres
SQL here you can go to redox not here it
is directly yeah so we'll copy the whole
thing so what I want to do is this is
redirecting us to so I want to copy them
so this is a postgresql so you can see
these are all the docs here so just Ctrl
a Ctrl C so we have copied all the
things and we will paste this and now we
will send this so you can see there was
an error generating this much because
this is very big so we just need the
relevant data what is the relevant data
the column types is relevant data okay
the this is relevant data so we can copy
the whole thing so first of all what we
need to do is we have did a mistake here
the chair GPD only accept 4000 tokens so
we'll fix this thing we will copy
everything from here and we will again
from docs below and we will only paste
the relevant docs nothing much so let's
paste this now we have this thing go up
to the top here we have the things
schematic layers this is our main thing
this is also relevant yeah this is
relevant index is foreign that's all we
need and you can now send this and it
will generate all the tables for us you
can see
is generating all the schemas so we
don't have to write all these things by
ourselves it's like a productivity hack
you can use this and it's good I will
tell you if this has any error we will
also fix this so now we just need to
copy our whole thing copy the whole
thing paste here result or MPG core so
pgnm
popularity so we don't need this
populated thing here so we can remove
this the uuid column we also don't need
this we can just pass the uuid so this
may have some error so we are fixing
this we are checking if chair TPT has
done anything wrong
so this is good PG table profiles ID is
uuid which is a primary key it's totally
okay and we can also pass Auto generated
default random so it means it is
generated default so now we can copy
every ID using this thing uuid primary
key default random updated it timestamp
defined now not null okay username so
this unique constraint is not available
in the drizzle noun so we can remove
this also instead of uid column we can
replace it with only uuid now you can
see username dot now we also don't have
this check thing so we can remove this
it's totally okay but we can say we want
not null full name also not null we will
again cross check with our original
schema so you can go here ID updated
username and full name these four things
ID updated username and full name cool
we can remove this this one also we have
tweets which is default random text is
not null profile ID and the refresh to
the profile IDs profiles.id so this is
saying that a profile can have many
tweets just like that and now here we
can also Define some react Convention of
for naming so instead of profile
underscore ID we can say profile and
then capitalize and then D so profile it
it's the best practice to do like that
profile ID create it updated it so the
database will be saved or what I'm
saying is the data base column will be
named after this but in the application
we will use this for our type script
generation so it's cool we have Hastings
so it's also cool default random the
hashtag continental and then we have a
PG table called tweet hashtag a tweet
can have multiple hashtag and a hashtag
can be part of multiple tweets so you
can see we have a table tweet hashtag so
instead of saying to it hashtag we can
do this do it hashtag this is a table
tweet ID hashtag ID and then this one
this is cool to eat hashtag primary key
so we will say that this is tweet ID and
this is hashtag ID so it is creating a
table which has access to the thing that
which tweet has which hashtag okay so we
can if we want to get all the tweets of
a single hashtag then we can query the
table you can say give me all the tweets
of this particular hashtag ID we can
create this table and then we can join
the Tweet table with each ID of the
Tweet is equal to the student ID so it
will join the tweetable and it will give
us all the tweets so that's how we can
do that here we have our replies replies
why it is complaining so let's see we
have uid as a primary key we have text
that's good user ID
son ordinal references profile dot ID so
it means yeah so who is the user who
have replied okay okay let's see we have
tweet ID we here we can instead of
username we can say user capital I tweet
Capital ID reply Capital ID over
productivity after this after creating
this schema is going to be very good
this is one time thing and you will be
very much productive after implementing
this because previously we were doing
all the row things the native things
like queuing the database from raw
queries that that is very bad so it
should always use orm so I thought why
not use overm in this tutorial that's
why I'm creating this part also when
integrating the one part okay so replies
text user ID tweet ID reply ID you can
see this is itself reference note this
you can see self reference a user can
reply to okay so we have ID tweet so if
we comment this out we yeah it will work
so this is not working it is saying that
it can't refresh the current table so if
we go to the documentation here you can
find out an example that for sure which
is self-reference you can see that
sisters City ID and it is self
referencing foreign key and that's cool
you can see country ID is countrys.id
inline foreign key that is good country
ID thesis and sister city ID which is
referencing to same table and EPG column
and then so replied is also referencing
to the same table which is replies and
it is saying that reply ID is this do we
need the reply ID basically yeah because
a reply can also be reply so this is the
confusing part let's omit this part I
don't think we need the reply why do we
need the reply yeah we don't need the
reply reply user a tweet can have many
replies and then a reply can have more
replies also that's why we are doing
this yeah that's why we are doing this
so if the reply ID exists that means it
is a reply for another reply if it
doesn't exist this means it is a top
level reply if it is existing it means
it is a down level reply good so let's
do this also now you can see it is gone
we are referencing the
same table so we will insert this reply
ID whenever we are replying to a reply
that's how it is work it will work now
we are getting the replies and we are
constructing the foreign Keys which is
columns foreign columns yeah but we
don't need this thing we are already
referencing things here reply user
foreign key columns reply dot user ID
profiles.id explicit foreign key with
one column explicit foreign key with
multiple columns in line four and key so
this is a explicit foreign key and this
is inline foreign key we can choose to
use either of the one we don't need to
do both of them so we are referencing
one two three so this table has three
reference so a user can have many
replies a tweet can have many replies
and a reply can have many replies so
this is what these three references mean
and we don't need this extra hustle of
creating this explicitly if you don't
want to Define this inline you can do
that so we will remove now testing and
it's going to now we have likes table
which is likes that's good default
random uuid which is user ID and it is
referencing to the profiles.id which is
this one that's good tweet ID is this a
tweet can have many likes that's why it
is referencing to tweet ID so we can
instead of saying user we can say user
ID tweet IDE you can see we have to do a
lot of fixes after behaviors shared GPT
jgpt will give us the initial boost so
we don't have to write a lot of text
here basically and we are creating a
index over here why we are creating
index because sometimes it is faster to
get the data if we have created the
indexes but it is not required but yeah
we can create that so let's create a
index on user ID and tweet ID so we can
query them faster so here you can find
out about the indexes so if you search
index you know this index you can say
index and unique index two things we
have here okay so I think it is so we
need to import the unique index unique
Index right so now we have our where is
this likes yeah so we have this unique
index over here unique index
which is like can only be like is unique
basically the user cannot like a tweet
more than one so it means with the same
user ID or tweet ID more than one row
can't be existed in this table that's
why we are creating a unique index like
unique and we can name this thing
likes user ID tweet ID index and here we
can say unique like index dot on and
here we can Define our columns here so
we can say like stored first one is user
ID likes tote and the second one is
tweet ID like that so we have defined
our index selected awesome here we have
our bookmarks it is PG table
the same thing here we need to do user
ID tweet ID created it it is referencing
to the correct table good it is also
Continental so we can say it can't be
null so this bookmark feature is same as
the like feature nothing much so you can
also okay so we are already saying it
convenal that's good this reference
thinks continual basically yeah this
reply can be null but it can't be null
okay so this both can be null but yeah
these both can Minal but they can't be
null both at same time because we need
to fetch we need to find that if this
tweet has some likes or if this supply
has some replies Good now we have some
likes over here and we need to do the
same thing like we have did for the like
so we can just say bookmarks we will say
bookmarks unique because as I said in
the last part that bookmark and like are
the same thing unique bookmark index
then we can say bookmarks user ID tweet
ID index ID user ID tweet ID created it
okay so you can see this is how we have
created all of our tables
and now the migration part comes we need
to generate the SQL from this and we
need to sync our database so for that we
will use again result docs here you can
find out how to connect to our database
like this we just need to use this we
are already using the pool which you can
see and then we just need to pass you
can remove this thing import the drizzle
import the drizzle from the result
postgres import the pool from PG install
everything PNP install PG okay I think
we need to also install the types over
here we have connection string and then
we can use over overm just like that's
DB select from users and it is simple
let's reload our window so we can see
what is going on we need to export it
also yeah we need to install the type
PMP install save there at the rate
thanks slash PG so now we have types we
reload it will it is gone and it's good
so now we have our SQL DB which is a orm
and we can now efficiently query so you
can see DB dot we have all the auto
completion beautifully Auto completion
now our productivity will be much faster
and we will be able to catch error much
faster so we don't need to do this now
we can also remove comment it out we
will use this riff for reference when we
create the same query using the treasure
worm so we have seen three methods first
of all we have used Super Bass client.js
library to fetch all the tweets and to
mutate or insert like row and doing all
the stuff then we have used plain SQL
now we are using an orm so these three
different approaches and you can choose
from last to whichever you want it is
not like must for you to use this result
if you want to go with Prisma you can I
just want to explore this new thing
that's why I am creating a tutorial for
it and let's see
we have to eat hashtag table it is good
you can see many too many this is a
many-to-many relationship between tweet
and hashtag otherwise we have one too
many relationship like a tweet can have
many likes a two it can have many
bookmarks a reply can have many replies
a tweet can have many reply so this is a
one to many but a tweet can have many
hashtags and a history can have many
tweets so this is a many-to-many
relationship good so now we have over DB
now we will create another script for
migrating over database migrate.ts here
we will do we will Define a function
which is main function we will call it
async and what we will do await migrate
so we need to find a way to migrate our
database so if you go to migrations here
you can find out how to utilize the
migrations so we need to install the
drizzle kit which we have already did I
think and now we can use this thing
await migrate and import the migrate
from here import it import these two
things import the DB now we have DB okay
so it is migration folder of migration
folder is our Reserve when we will
generate the migrations it will create a
new folder digital and in which we have
our migrations node PG database record
string yeah so white is complaining
let's see diesel SQL let's use this Max
connection and also the postgres thing
here over here so I think we need to we
need distinct postgres and then here we
can use the postgres and we have other
things here database yeah connection
option so this is the database string we
need I think so let's connect our
database here we can see this is using
pool and here it is using postgres so
two things we have here but at the end
we have database let's use the
process.env okay it doesn't need the new
thing and now let's see what the things
you have connection host host name
password everything it has we want to
use connection let's go with the
database yeah and we will pass okay I
think it accepts a connection string
like that and it accepts all the can say
as a string and we can pass down all the
stuff here we can say Max connection is
one so we have our SQL can pass down
over SQL here inside the drizzle which
we will import from postgres CS yeah and
now it is not complaining it is good
postgres JS database and we will run
this main function we will say main dot
then process dot exit I will say
console.log migrations running
console.log migration finished cool so
now we have our drizzle warm with a
schema proper with proper SQL DB and
with migration system now we have to do
few more things if you go to the
package.json in the scripts you need to
Define some script over here so we can
say generate so it will generate over
all the migrations file so for that to
generate all the migrations file you can
use test result kit generate PC so where
you can use result kits and net PC it
will generate all the migrations file
and then we will use the migrate to push
the migrations to our database so here
we can say we will use one something
code 1 to run over script one dot sh
so it will automatically handle all the
stuff holders like getting the
environment variables and handling the
type script stuff and all the things so
you don't have to worry about anything
you just need to use npx or pnpx
whatever you want npx1 you can say run
and then you can copy the migrate copy
path the migrate so instead of this we
can directly say source code to Source
in the library in the DB migrate.ts so
it will run over migrations so first of
all let's try this let's try to generate
the schema SQL from our schema so we
will type over here we will say nbx you
can type pnpma as well pnpm run what is
our description rate okay so it is
failed result config.json doesn't exist
so we have to define the configs of this
thing let's import this as well in the
root of 4 directory create a result
config.ts and paste this stuff so we can
find out we can Define our schema in the
source in the library in the DB we have
our schemato
schema.ts and where we want to Output
the SQL we can say it isn't now it's
good it will now do the work so let's
run the command again pnpm run generate
yeah so now we have something and it is
showing us that transforming const to
the configuring environment is not
supported yet so it is saying that no
config path provided
result.config.ts let's see what is
happening errors are if you want to have
all the params as CLA options we can
also do the install spec command here
and spec so it should have directly
saying result create yeah so we Face an
error so what is the error if you go to
the tsconfig.json file you will find
that yes if you previously we were using
es5 instead of es5 what you need to do
es
2017 so if you can see there are a lot
of things so you want to use es 2017 and
it will work nicely so if you run PNP
and run generate again it will right so
this is the version thing type script
sometimes stuff like that may happen so
you can see our migration file is ready
and you can see this is mostly similar
to our stuff all the stuff we have
created here we have our indexes and all
the things like foreign keys and stuff
awesome so now we have all our things
and now we can run the migrations as
well so if you run pnpm plan and then
you can say interest Let's do an
instrument okay so pnbm run install spec
what is this select you go to the
package.json you can find out it's true
spec it is what like this and here yeah
intro expect install not not install
intro respect and let me fix that intro
expect and hit this also address so pnpm
run intro is introspect so it will only
PG is available option for Drive command
field only PC is available option for
Drive okay so something is happening
here so connection we have to Define our
connection string over here if you want
to install inspect our stuff so we can
go to our config which is drizzle config
and here we can provide our connection
string yeah it is saying DB credentials
inside DB credentials we have connection
is string and which is process.env dot
what is over connection let's go to
command plea of your own make if you are
on Windows control P
env.local this is our database
connection string so make sure this is
hidden and yeah database connection
string as a string let's fix this so now
if we run the install respect it is
saying that it is only available for the
driver what is that okay so you can
Define our driver PG either connection
using database are required for database
connection so for the temporary purpose
what I am going to do I am going to
paste my database connection string over
here it is not necessary let's not do
that if you want to and install is intro
respect to your database you can put
your connection string and you can
remove definitely remove this because we
don't want to commit this to our GitHub
result config you can see we have test
result config and we don't want to
GitHub to track our database connection
string to please do it carefully so we
should remove this thing over here but
yeah you can do that okay so you can
also pass the connection string like
that so we can do that this is this is
this can be done so what I'm saying is
if you go to the PK store Json Ctrl P
command P package to Json here we are
saying generate kit install spec PG so
here we can say npx result kit intro
expect PG and here we can pass over
connection string as well out migration
and then we can pass our connection
history so we don't have to copy and
paste so GitHub won't be able to trick
yeah so I will now paste my EnV my
secret connection string over here and
let's try this PC is available option
for driver okay so what it is sometime
it doesn't work yes so we can say the
driver is PG or something yeah now it
worked driver is busy and if you go to
the migrations in the schema you have
all the things okay what is this you can
see it is commented current SQL files
while generated after intro expecting
the database if you want to run this
migration please uncomment this code
before executing migration so what is
happening here first of all
we have find out what is the difference
between our current database tables and
the previous one so it find out that we
need to create some more few things here
like user identity ID because if you see
in our database in our super based
database we have tweet underscore ID
this is not the naming condition we are
using that's why it is generating and
yeah so what we can do instead of this
let's remove the whole thing we don't
need to intro expect for now
let's generate the migration file once
more so let's delete the migration in
the drizzle yeah we have this this one
so we have this one in inside the
migration we have this one that's good
so if we go to our migrated file which
is this migration folder is we are
saying that this is drizzle and this is
our migration folder and if we try to
generate or we try to push the changes
to our DB let's try this because this is
a div instance and we don't care about
it that's why we are doing all the stuff
over here so we can say pnpm run migrate
and it will push over changes to the DB
now you can see npx button so if you
don't have the bun install it will say
please install the button and you can
hit the enter and it will work now we
have got some errors you can see
migrations running bookmarks table
already exist relation already exist
hashtags so this is stuff all all of
this stuff already exists that's why it
is not doing anything multiple primary
keys for table tweet hashtag are not
allowed
so it is now done so instead of this we
can save after this is done we finally
close the connection so now if we try to
do this again it will close our server
after running yeah after generating the
script so you can see already exist now
if you go to our database which is here
you can find out all the things here if
you go to tweets you can see there is
nothing changed we already have all the
things as they should be and everything
is good to go but if you try to change
something then it will do something so
if you go to the migrate folder and
let's try to run the migrations on the
migration folder and go to here
uncomment the whole thing so we can
generate our migration so now let's try
it again PNP and run migrate and let's
see what is happening yeah so we got
something this time also we are getting
some errors if this is a fresh database
then we won't be facing any problem
schema result Rd exists
checks already exist bookmarks already
exist likes profiles replies to it stick
yeah that's good but then why what did
you do with introspecting so
introspecting is the way to find out
what is changed let's assume we have a
fresh database create a fresh database
and try to push something there and it
will work so if we go to a fresh
database let's create a new project test
or let's say Dev database Twitter
ultimate Twitter clone tail generate a
password I will copy this choose your
reason and we will create a new database
let's find out if this is working or not
if we will go to paycase.json not in the
package in the EnV and I will change
my database connection string and all
this stuff all this stuff let's change
all this stuff so this is my secret
service key I will change this this is
my nnn public key I will change this as
well this is My URL I will change this
and now we need our database in the
database it is our connection stream and
we need a new password so basically I
will generate a new password again
generated new password copy this thing
reset this thing and here I will paste
my password that's good now everything
is new and we will generate everything
from scratch delete the drizzle delete
the migration now we will drive
everything from scratch so if you go to
yeah we can generate pnpm run and then
we can generate SQL from our schemas so
what we can do we can generate pnpm
branch and rate it will generate all
over SQL in the drizzle folder so you
can see we have all our tables and
relations here this is cool and now if
you change this if you change something
let's let's assume we want to insert
something in the user stable so we will
go to schema.ts here I will create a
created it as well so I will say this is
the timestamp I want to show you how you
will do the work if you want to change
something with the database in the
future create it eight dot default now
dot note null I just created it updated
it like that and now we will generate
over
again so you can see now we have two
migrations and it is saying altered
table profiles and add a column which is
time which time default is this can be
null discontinental and this is now you
can see and this is how we have we are
generating all the things over here and
we can push these changes to our
database in single click so we can say
pnpm run migrate and you can see
migration running and we are
successfully done over migration so if
we go to migration okay we haven't got
this but yeah it is done if you go to
the tables okay so there is nothing
let's see so then so cloak finished we
will also log if something went wrong
with that dot catch if we have any error
then
console.log yeah now let's do it again
PNP and migrate something is here
migration for okay so we don't have
migration folder here we are specifying
the wrong folder so that's why this
console.log error is also useful
sometimes so what we will do result now
it will it should work pnpm return
migrate migrations running migration
finished and finished and here if we you
can see all the tables and if you now go
to the tweets you should be able to see
some foreign gear so you can see this is
a foreign key which is released related
to the profiles public key and if you go
to the tweets table the profile table
basically you can see all the columns
are here you can go to the replies as
well here you can find out the reply ID
you can see this is self-relation this
is from tit relation indices so
everything is working like we have
expected and now we can easily QD over
database and we can do all the stuff if
we pnpm run do we will see something
happen so this is our application and
let's refresh the page we have also
created a new database so that we can
now integrate Result One freshly without
worrying about our previous stuff okay
so that's why we have created a new new
database so you should enable row level
policies for all the tables here so to
do that you just need to follow what I
am doing in ml row level policies for
all the rows so people will not be able
to access all these tables from anywhere
it should be more protected if assumed
like your public key supervisor public
key code in wrong hands then they can
utilize those keys to get all the data
so we don't want our data to be stolen
that's why we are enabling our own level
security policies because from a super
based public key these rows can be
accessed if the row level security
policy is not enabled enable all row
level policies so you can see enable
enable and now it's good now we have our
database with our schema in sync so in
the source directory in the library in
the DB in the schema you can find all
over schemas and it is in sync with
overproduction or you can see over
remote database but we want to integrate
it for fetching getting in all this
stuff so here we are saying that curing
and mutating so instead of doing this
what we will do if the current user
exists so we don't need this all the
stuff here we can directly fetch the
rows using retrieval Oram so what we
will do we will import the DB from the
DB and we will say select and what the
things we need okay so we need all the
tweets we need all the we need profiles
inside profiles we need username and we
need full name now what we can do we can
say from which table we want so we want
from tweets so we will import you can
see we are getting all the things so we
are importing all the columns this means
we if we don't specify anything then it
means we are importing everything so now
inside here so in the tweets if you do
this you will find some Auto completion
here and let's find out in the doc in
the documentation of drizzle warm how to
run a relational query so you can see DB
dot query.user.find menu so we can query
users and we can find many with post
like that so we need to do the stuff we
can also left or right join so here if
you sign many point first queries so
here they are using query fit post with
comments like this is good so there we
can do that as well so we can say query
and we want tweets okay so we want to
query okay so it will say Dot case but
we are not getting any auto completion
here you want the auto combination
that's why we are using that result here
so we are not getting any auto
completion why is that for any nested
with queries result will be infer type
of infer model from core API good that's
good but we want to okay so if you have
schema so we have to specify the schema
here basically so if you go to the DB
here you can specify the schema and
let's import everything import or copy
the whole line and you can specify the
schema now if you do this you can say ah
we have 104 tables so we want to query
the tweets don't find many and we will
say what do we want with and it will
give us the other thing which we have so
let's find out how we can find many here
we can specify the other columns as well
or the other tables as well so so here
what we want here we want the users or
you can say where is this a field code
to the tweets here we have profile ID it
is related to yeah so here we can say we
want the profile as well so profiles
true we want the profiles so this is how
we can do but we are not getting any
auto completion here why is that find
many columns what are the columns you
need okay so it is saying that space are
the columns let's see columns extra
limit offset where with good so we want
the columns all we want all the columns
okay so that's not the case extras what
is extras let's find out okay which in
the width we have comments and then
inside we can pass down the other things
as well so let's pass the profiles but
we are not getting any auto completion
here why set because we are not using
the relations here so what I'm saying is
we have profiles and profiles each
profile okay so profiles don't have
anything inside it like profiles don't
have any one too many relation here but
tweet has something so a profile can
have many tweets so what here we can do
we can specify some things here like it
is given here user relation the same
thing which we can do here so instead of
saying user relation can say profiles
relations import the relations and here
we will pass down the profiles here we
will say many and it a user can have
many tweets and this is into tweets like
this a user can have many likes a user
can have many bookmarks a user can have
many replies as well so this is what we
are doing here tweets let's forget about
tweet hashtag now replies and likes and
bookmarks the same thing we need to do
for from the other direction so what I'm
saying is copy this whole thing and we
will Define tweets relations this
doesn't effect over schema this is much
more of a application iteration level
interface thing so this is only is
required for the application Level so
here we can say tweets relation and
profile info has user ID could can see
this these both have the same thing but
if the database doesn't support
relations like Planet scale doesn't
support relations so you have to use
this schema otherwise you can use this
thing okay so users relations user one
user can have one profile good a user
can have many comments and on the other
side one post a comment yeah so we have
to Define from both sides so you can see
a post can have many comments and a
comment can be only posted on one post
so that's why we have to Define this
thing here like this a post so here we
will Define the profile we will say one
and it has it accepts two things it X it
will accept here we will pass down the
Prof tweets tweets relation it we will
pass down the tweets just like that in
the comments we are passing down the
comments like here and here we are
saying a comment can be posted on one
post and here we are specifying the
posts here cool so here we will specify
the profiles and here we will save the
fields which are the fields basically so
it is the tweets dot which field is this
so is it is profile ID and what is the
reference of this field so we will say
profiles.id just like it post dot ID
this is the reference which means this
is a reference and this is the field
which we want to reference so we can say
this post ID is referenced to this ID so
we have to do this for all the other was
as well this is our profiles this solar
profiles relations tweets tweets
relations it replies now we have replies
relations here instead of doing this we
will say replace dot user ID okay so
here we are saying user ID which is good
profiles replies so if you have to pass
down the replies here basically where
then this will have the reply success
now we have profiles okay now it is good
to go every as well we will do the same
for the likes table here instead of
reprise relation we will say likes
relations here we will pass down the
likes table here we will say likes dot
user ID just like that and the
references profiles dot ID good
here in the bookmarks we will do the
same thing I know it is repetitive but
yeah it it works it will help us when we
are querying our database and it will be
much more error prone here we will pass
down the bookmarks it will say bookmarks
towards user ID
I would suggest you to name these
profiles users and then you can specify
the user ID as well here so let's save
this it will it won't affect the schema
but it will affect here so if you now
see you can see we have a profile it
will hit enter we can find out what
columns we need so we need username and
we need true and we need full name so
this is because of here we have
specified the tweets relations tweet if
we want to find out on the tweets we
have this thing that's why it is working
and if we log this it will work but we
want to left showing this profile
stepping so for that we can do that we
can do that if we go to joins here we
can find out how to do that so DB dot
select from users then we can left join
things so this is what we need to do so
let's comment this out for now and here
we will try something out here we will
say const result is equal to await DB
dot select you can just select distinct
select this technique we will just
select and we want to select from tweets
we want to select from tweets and then
we want to left join basically so here
you can find out all the things inner
join left show and right join everything
Behavior so we want to left join the
table which is which table we want to
lecture you can see we want to left join
the likes table and then join the
profiles as well so we are joining two
tables so we will join the likes table
then join add all element are the
elements of an error into any string
separated by specific separate so we are
taking the reference of this SQL query
which we have got from chat CPT now we
will join the profiles but before that I
think we need to specify something we
need to left join and we need to
find out Pro for which column you want
to left showing so here we will specify
something where we will say equal and we
can say tweets dot which tab which
column you want to join okay so we have
ID profile ID everything so we want to
join the twitch ID and likes dot tweet
ID now this this is what we want after
this we want to join the whole table
which is the profiles table basically
and it it will accept the same thing it
will accept the tweets dot profile ID
and we need profiles.id okay what it is
saying okay left join required and full
join code partial select then what is
the join many to one example aggregate
result so here we have joined all the
twists basically here here we are
selecting everything but what if we
don't I don't want to select everything
here length join I want to join the
profiles and it's separator add all the
element to an array into string left
join for each row of the table includes
value from a matching row of the join
table if there is a matching row if not
all of The Columns of the joint table
will be set to null okay that's cool but
this join is not a yeah this join is not
a thing of our right join includes all
the rows of joint table if there is no
matching Row in the main table all The
Columns of the main table will not be
set to null so here we are joining the
lift we are basically we are saying that
give me the tweet and give me the likes
count of this to it basically so we are
saying that when when the Tweet ID is
equal to likes to it ID give me all the
rows as well and then we are joining the
profile and let's lock the result out
and we will see what we are getting here
restored yeah so we should get something
here dot returning and now what we can
do here we can order them order by and
we will say how do you want to order by
so can set tweets tote created it taught
okay so how this order Works cost to
tier order by documentation let's find
out what is this okay it is sending us
to dot all so we can find all the rows
and here we can specify the rows as well
we don't need all the rows we can offset
or we can find some rows note all of
them and here we are also grouping them
by tweet ID profiles username and
profiles okay so we don't need that
thing descending the result the GitHub
one GitHub documentation is better let's
go to there
huh here you can see how we can select
the users or how we can use this thing
select from user where this is this this
is this could limit offset and order by
okay so we have to use this ascending or
descending from here so we need to
descending we need descending so what we
will do we will trap tesc from drizzle
worm we will import and we will say use
in sorting and you can hover over it you
can find from users order by descending
users to created it and to sort created
it that's what we are doing here that's
totally good now it will work we can
limit an offset offset means how many
users or tweets you want to jump you can
limit them let's limit to one tweet only
dot yeah that's that's what we need to
returning I think there is something
called returning if you hover over it
you can see what we are getting we are
getting if we do this too we will
receive an array if we do it one we will
receive array of objects so here we have
twits here we have profiles and here we
have likes save this thing and here we
will find out what we are getting we are
getting undefined why is set so if we go
to the main component let's comment
everything out for now here we are
creating the tweets let's pass this
thing also console.log current user ID
and yeah so basically the current user
ID is undefined and we are getting
nothing and if we remove this what we
will get nothing okay because we don't
have any tweets that's why we are
getting all of these things so let's
login and try to submit some tweets here
then it will work save this thing here
in the mutation if you go to compose
tweet here we are submitting the tweets
instead of this now you can use the
treasure worm if you want so let's use
the twizzle Orem so import the DB dot
insert and we will specify our tweets
tweets table schema and we can we will
say the values are this profile ID is
user data.user dot ID just like that dot
yeah so this is how you can insert
something using the drizzle warm result
and let's lock the result as well
console.log press what we are getting
yeah we are getting the user and it's
good node user we are getting the Tweet
basically so we can now remove this we
don't need Super based server we need
only response actually we don't need to
send anything if this went wrong dot
catch we can set some error we can say
let error is equal to empty string and
if something went wrong we can say error
something wrong with inside something
wrong with server let's say for now and
we can pass down the error as error
that's good and we can pass down the
data as Razer res why it is complaining
if we go here yeah it is complaining
because if we hover over this now we
have some different things so just for
the sake of demo we will do it any and
now let's say how if we able to submit a
tweet or not so first we need to sign in
so Club of quarters.com
gmail.com and username is Club of
quarters hit enter now we should be
received and yeah so we have received a
link I will sign up now I am logged in
you can see we are getting an ID here I
will submit something this is a tweet
this is my first tweet if I hit enter
you can see something is happening
something is happening so let's log this
out what we are getting you can say
error console.log error if we try to fit
some yeah we are getting something we
are getting insert or update on tweets
we will list the foreign key constraint
to its profile ID profile ID foreign
go to profiles okay so we don't have any
profiles here why because this is our
new database and we haven't configured
over trigger to in insert a row into our
profiles table when a new user is
created for that you could you can go to
SQL editor you can go to there is a user
management starter and you can just copy
this whole trigger create function what
it will do it will it will create a
trigger whenever a new user will sign up
on your application it will insert into
the profiles table so new blank query
create function public handle user
insert into public dot profile ID full
name of the URL we don't need the author
URL we need the username username full
name username these two things we need
new DOT ID new DOT now let's try to run
this now successfully done if we go to
our profiles username for name these two
things we need we need the ID as well so
yeah we are getting the ID as well cool
so now we will delete this user which
just has signed up now if you refresh
this it will ask us to sign up again
love of quarters dot com and Delete
gmail.com here we will say Club of
coders now I will click on login it will
send me a email ID code and email
something went wrong let's see let's
click on login again something is not
working so we will find out what is
happening here oath so in the provider
we are opening the model here is our
authentication model please sign in to
continue here we are select okay so the
username already exists please use and
then we are signing using OTP if
something is wrong we should show
something here so I think it will give
us some data an error if we got any
error sign up error sign data so if we
got any error then we should Source
something and we should return it return
those dot error error dot you can say
sign up error Dot message and if it is
successfully done we can send a we can
show it tosh.success magic link sent
successfully like that now it's good now
if we try to do that again Club of
orders.com
gmail.com Club of folders login null
value in the column full name of
relation profiles okay so we are getting
something let's lock the error so we can
see what is happening we'll sign up
error block of quarters okay I don't
want to type again and again I think I
should use type is email already it
should show me auto completion but it is
not showing okay so it is what is the
problem we are facing is inside the
authentication in the profiles username
full name let's try this and see the
error more carefully fixed error where
is there okay in the terminal it should
have so null value in the column full
name of relations profile Violet null
not null constraint at not null value in
column yeah previously we were able to
sign up and this time note what happened
let's clear the whole data where is the
storage clear the site data everything
now everything is clear localhost go to
localhost now let's do it again
cloudforest.com
gmail.com here we will say the username
is Club of quarters hit enter and it is
saying data is username preview failing
2 contains this null value in column
full name of relation profile so we are
not able to insert a new row that's why
we are not able to sign up so let's pass
down the full name as well so it needs a
full name so what we can do we can do is
same thing here and instead of
placeholder we can say name type text
minimum let's remove this and let's
define a new state as well for the name
full name it is empty here we will say
okay the value is username and here the
value is email why have I'll forward
that thing here the value is e not email
here is the value is full name and set
the full name that's all now we need to
send the full name as well to our server
full name is full name that's good now
let's write email is Club of
quarters.com
gmail.com username is Club of quarters
name is pranjal Sony hit enter now it is
done magic link sent successfully now it
is done and we should have a new row
inserted in our DB that's totally
awesome and we will confirm our sign up
now we are sign up and here we will this
is my first tweet hit tweet to it sends
successfully everything is working as
expected and here now we are able to see
the gateways and everything is now good
so close close close close you can see
this is how we are using digital aurum
to insert something from note from
inside our TV and here we are creating
the TV and joining all the Stables here
so you can see we are getting an array
which has only one element it has
something it has tweets which is the
Tweet detail it has likes which is null
because now the likes is null it has
profiles which who is the user who
created this to it this is what we are
showing here that's totally good now we
want all the likes okay so how to do
that we want all the likes I want to
count it can we do that no so we can
send the whole response here and
response and in the main component here
we can catch the error if something went
wrong let error is equal to empty string
and here we can directly say like this
and we can say error is equal to
something went wrong while fetching all
the tweets and here we can pass down the
data is response and the error is the
error now we have something and if we
have place to data dot length is greater
than 0 or or not like that if this is
defined here we can remove this tweet
why it is showing us this weekly line
control set rest to data.map now we have
this tweet void element undefined is not
assignable to type react node type word
is not a seven yeah two it is raised to
data and raised to data.nint is greater
than zero something is not working here
something is very wrong we can say it is
dot data yeah now it's happy it's
basically happy it is saying yeah so
here tweets tweet dot so we can split
the profiles tweets here we can say
tweets.id here we have our tweets and in
the yeah here we have all the things
here tweet.text here we don't need to
give this thing here we can infer tweet
type so if you go to the documentation
of drizzle let's close this you can
infer actually you can infer the types
so if you go to schema declaration this
is how you can infer the types of the
everything so if you go to schema here
we want to infer the twitch type so here
we can say tweets instead of saying the
so this is our users table we want to
infer the user here we can say we want
to infer the tweet and import from
reservoirum and we can pass down type of
tweets now we have a tweet type and here
page we can get the Tweet type from
schema good so here we can spread both
things
profiles like that now it has all the
things here which are needed it has all
these tweets it has all the profiles so
we can Union we can Union both the types
so here this is our tweets and here is
our profiles so this is our profiles so
we can say this is our profile infer
from profile and here we can make a
junior notice Union there is something
Union type script if you search this you
can find how we can Union a type yeah
this is how you can Union simple we can
say if this is profile or this is Street
import the profile now it is happy it is
also happy here you can say tweet okay
not to be basically we don't want to
Union this it will eliminate the common
things we want to intersection let's try
it and we want both so tweet dot yeah
now we have both so here we want the
full name here this is of yeah tweet
tote created it now we don't have the
likes count for now we can pass down
this we can pass down the zero it can
also make sure it is false everything is
looking good for now we will see what we
can do to make sure our like button also
works like it was working previously so
now if we go to our application you can
see this is my first tweet we are
getting everything we need so if you hit
refresh everything is good now we want
to like this field if you click this
button it will like but it will not
shows anything so here we are getting
all the tweets likes and profiles if you
like this thing insert or update on
likes for tweet ID okay so we can't we
are not able to insert into the likes
table why is that let's find out it is
our uuid for our thing for our tweet if
we go to tweet inside like button here
we are liking to tweet tweet ID user ID
it's good why it is not working so
instead of doing this we will use the
digital alarm dot insert insert into the
likes row and we want to insert some
values dot values which are of tweet ID
which are user ID and everything else
will be Auto generated basically so now
you can you can lock the error if we get
anything error
console.log in error yeah now let's do
it again try to like this tweet it
worked right thing if you go to the
likes table nothing is here we also want
to find out what is happening so const
response is equal to
console.loke response save this thing
now we will refresh this I will like
this yeah we are getting something
insert or update on likes whether it's
the foreign
tweets for NK something is missing here
something is not correct why is that
let's find out let's log first let's
look the IDS we are receiving here so we
can find out what is happening so here
is our cheat ID here is our user ID
let's lock both of these out our user ID
is this and our tweet ID over user ID is
4D something and our tweet ID is 10c
something let's click on this button and
see what is happening yeah okay so we
are getting both same things here tweet
ID and user ID both are same why is that
why is why is this problem because we
are not passing the Tweet ID correctly
so if you go here in the light bit here
we are getting the Tweet ID but where
from where we are getting the Tweet ID
in the like button and this is the ID of
tweet and this is wrong why is that
let's look the Tweet okay this is both
same why is that oh okay okay okay these
both are same why is that let's find out
here we want to return this thing but to
debug this thing we want to to
console.log tweets so it is combining
both of this ID and it is taking one so
the problem is the ID so to fix this
problem what we will do we will pass
down the Tweet ID here we will say tweet
ID it is it is confusing us okay so we
are getting confused here what is tweets
and what is not so we will do use
Reserve profile and here we will pass
down the profiles so now everything is
clear tweets so now we have ID text and
nicely so we we can differentiate which
is Twitter ID and which is user ID so we
have this user ID and this is the Tweet
ID so that's why we are doing something
here so instead of doing this we can
make our type like this we can say roof
file just like this bit user profile is
profile and another thing which we have
is tweet or we here we can specify or we
can directly say we have Waits here
tweets is to it
it's still not happy so we need to fix
the type here so I think we need to do
something here user profile and tweet
details and here I can we can pass the
tweets now here we can the Tweet details
is Tweet now both are satisfied and it's
good save this save this thing also and
here you can say user profile dot full
name twitch.user profile dot username
and here we want tweet details created
it to tweet details and the Tweet IDs
tweet details dot edit node the user and
now it's good now it's totally
differentiated it's good and if you
click on this like button it will work
it will work it will definitely work now
if you go to here in the likes table you
can see we have now our like which is
created using Crystal orm now we can
remove all the consulted look first
remove all the controller block so why I
have recorded this debugging path also
because I want you to know that not all
the times everything works out sometimes
we get get some errors and we need to
figure out and we need to debug the
errors okay so that's cool we can do
this or we can delete from using the
tercelorm as well but you can do this by
yourself now here we are getting
something here so what I'm saying is
let's log the likes and we will see what
we are getting so we are getting the
likes as well you can see and if you
like this tweet one more time then we
will also get that one tweet so I will
open a new window which you seeked
foreign
so here as you can see we are saying
that where if this exists or not so if
this is doesn't exist then we can say
undefined argument of type this node
assignable we are getting this problem
let's assume we do this okay because
this can be undefined that's why it is
not working so if we do this it will not
show us any problem let's find out what
we are getting here hit refresh now we
get something this is straight this is
likes profiles that's good that's not I
want let's remove this whole thing let's
find out console.log row dot okay we
have three things likes profiles and
tweets
so I want to select some custom columns
okay so how can we do that let's find
out
we can select partial select user.id
user.name mapped1 map2 that's okay
that's totally okay DB dot select as SQL
number X from this generate series
conditionally select fields we can also
do this SQL thing here it's cool how
about we try this the same thing here we
can save the user has liked or not so
what I'm saying is user has liked if the
current user ID exist then has light
otherwise null conditionally where is
this conditionally yeah now it's good
it's conditional with name name.users
otherwise this that's good and we can
say is liked and it is SQL import SQL
from here and we can pass down over SQL
string DB with SQ we can do a lot of
things here basically as liked exist is
we want to do this can we do that damn
wait okay we can do that let's find out
we are getting this thing here row Dot
has liked okay so we have his leg now
but we don't have the tweets or anything
now we can say tweets is tweets likes
his likes and we can say profiles is
profiles let's find out what it gave us
not working let's go to the main and
something happened true so we have liked
all of them so it is giving us two
that's totally dope and what if we what
if I remove all the likes let's delete
all the tables so we have two users we
have three tweets so we have light all
of them
I want to delete all of the tables okay
why can't I delete this table note table
we want to delete yeah delete six rows
delete all the rows now it should be
false if I hit refresh yeah it's zero it
falls dim
so our query which we have written in
SQL just worked in drizzle orm so this
is how you can do that it's totally
awesome
it's cool what if I go to local notes
3000 now it's good we are getting three
likes if I hit refresh if I hit like now
it has one like that's totally dope so
we are getting all the results what we
want and we can pass down the
road.heslite into select is equal to row
dot select this is a complex query and
we have struggled a lot to achieve this
but yeah it was totally fun now we can
also specify this okay so it is saying
unknown we can pass down like a Boolean
why it is saying okay so we have to
specify the as liked as Boolean here
that's stop and now in the main
component in the main component here we
are getting the tweets and here we will
also specify if the user has liked this
tweet or not so here we have his liked
and we will pass this down into our main
thing so if user has light or not here
it will go this is a Boolean save this
thing save this thing save this thing
now it will refresh and everything will
work like charm okay why it is if I hit
okay so it is getting all the true and
false for older yeah why is that let's
find out in the in the queries hereby
here we are seeing if current user ID
exists then here's like it exist
otherwise not so something is fishy here
something is not correct what we are
doing we are selecting from likes we are
saying if likes dot user ID is okay so
this is wrong this is wrong this is not
what we want we want to find if this
current user has light or not so we have
to Define two equal and we will say
twist out like stored user ID and also
the likes dot the Tweet ID is equal to
the current tweet ID basically that's
what we are doing so we are saying the
tweets this this ID is equal to this ID
or node so for that what we can do here
we can instead of doing this we can say
DB dot select Dot from likes dot aware
dot where and here we can say equal
likes
tweet ID is equal to tweets dot ID and
at the same time we need equal likes dot
user ID is equal to the current user ID
so this is not accepting to equal in the
same way so we can pass down another
where here and we can say this now save
this thing now if you hit refresh
everything is good if you hit like all
the three tweets are like no this is not
what you want something is still missing
DB dot select from likes where likes to
tweet IDs to it stored ID like stored
user IDs current user ID and now we can
remove the whole thing here basically
let's remove this refresh this okay so
we have to use this end operator here
and that's how it will work instead of
changing we can do and import the end
and here we will use the same thing like
that and here you can see where where
these both conditions are satisfied
where the user ID is equal to current
user ID and the Tweet ID is equal to the
current tweet ID let's find out yeah I
think it worked if I remove this if I
like this if I like this I like this if
I refresh this now it's good if I remove
this yeah two likes it has two likes I
will remove one like it has one like I
will remove this one like as well now it
has zero like so it's working so yeah we
can't change multiple where operators we
can use end operator and we we can
select multiple equal yeah that's good
so that's how we have successfully
fetching the tweets we are getting the
tweets this is a fresh new tweet hit
enter this is a fresh new tweet with
zero likes if we hit click if you like
this tweet if you are liking this tweet
here we can see our fresh new tweet as
well and we can like this tweet and
everything is working like charm and we
have successfully converted our row SQL
query into the orm query which is long
and honestly this is not looking good
but yeah this is better than this where
we don't have to define a lot of things
and we can conditional chain multiple
things so yeah thank you so much for
continuing with me till now I know this
must be hard for you at the first I am
you very new to Teresa Orem this is my
first time where I have tried laser over
so here as you can see this is our
application and we can like this and we
can remove our like as well and if you
refresh this everything is good and
perfect we can also tweet this is a new
Tweet now we want to implement a new
function when we click this a new model
will open and then we will be able to
submit a new reply to this video so
let's build that part first of all we
need a new model for that we will use UI
dot sharedcn.com that's the thing we
need so let's go to the app page here we
have main component left sidebar and
right sidebar that's good in the
component in the client component we
have did a mistake that this like button
is use client okay but this activities
use server but as you can see we are
getting everything in this component
from as a props so if you even use this
component as I use client component it
will still work if you hit refresh you
can see this is still working the same
now it's good and now if someone clicks
on the street so on click we will open a
new model okay so we will open the reply
model or we can say the dialog so let's
go to the twitter.com and we will find
out how it works so you can see if we
hover over it you can see some a little
bit of white color is here okay so if we
click this and if we click on this reply
it will open a new window where we can
reply to this tweet so we want to build
this thing so when we click this we will
build this model so note the whole thing
note the whole thing only when we click
on this shade thing so this is a button
and when we click this open the reply
dialog so here we can Define our dialog
so we can wrap this thing inside a
fragment this is called react fragment
and here we can Define our dialog we can
copy and paste the dialog code from UI
dot share cn.com get started in the
dialog node in the alert dialog in the
dialog you here you can copy and paste
you can see there are two Styles but
yeah now we will copy this thing this is
our dialog also copy this and paste here
it's good and when this is open when we
click click our chat button so instead
of here we can cut this thing we can
paste it over here and for the trigger
we can use this button cut this paste
here button cut this save and for the
trigger we can use a child so that when
we click over this button it will assume
that we are triggering our legs so now
let's go to our application here you can
see we can't able to hover it so let's
give it some effects like we have given
to the like button so here you can copy
the classes same
and we will use these classes for our
button now if you hover over it okay it
is still not working let's say press
this something is missing here okay so
our app got hang why is that localhost
3000 and now you can see we can hover
over this like it like the like button
you can like this we can remove the like
if we click this you can see we are
opening a nice model but we don't want a
lot of white shadow you can see this is
a much the opacity is much cleaner so we
can improve our dialogue let's go to the
dialogue and this is our dialogue
overlay we can fix this so BG background
80. so instead of 80 let's do a 20 so it
will refresh if you click this now it is
much clearer let's do it then we can
remove the blood as well let's remove
the blur or we can keep it it's the blur
looks good so now it's much much clearer
here we can reply to the Tweet so just
we need to create a new server component
over here but remember but we can not
use a server component inside client
Commodore and am I right yeah here you
can see Server component inside line
component so you can summarize the
differences between server component and
client components here so on the top
level if you can see this is our page
and this is a server component in the we
have another server component in this we
can have a client component but in the
client component we cannot have a server
server component that is the main point
in the server component we can have
client component that's the thing to
remember and which is pretty obvious if
you think that if your client component
has some interactivity and it is already
gone to client which means this is
publicly available and our server code
is private that's why we can't code
anything server inside our client and if
we have a server component inside it we
can create a client component this is
pretty obvious and easy to remember this
is a technique I use to remember which
is client and what is this so in the
client component we cannot declare a
server action or anything okay so to use
it basically we will use in the mutation
if we go to the mutation just like we
are using the light to it unlike tweet
actions we will use this actions to do
our stuff While submitting the reply so
here we will Implement our reply thing
let's create another model in the
component in the client component it
will create a new component which is
reply moral or reply dialog dot TSX and
it is a client component by default use
server not your server use client
rafce here we can say reply dialog here
we can cut the whole thing and we can
import the reply dialog just like that
save this thing now we need to cut this
also paste here import this everything
is good okay so now it's good what we
need we need to style it a little bit so
go to this we need a tweet here so
basically we need the Tweet details like
this so we we just we are just rendering
this whole component and we are showing
it over here and then we will show a
reply box here so what we can do we can
import that tweet again inside this
button that that would be not a good
approach we can copy the whole thing and
we can show this over here so this is
only for image so if we try to reply
this you can see we are only rendering
the text and then we are showing the
then the Twitter is showing the image
URL we can actually remove the both of
the things so if we do this yeah so we
need to copy the whole thing copy the
whole thing we are not going to copy
everything but you will see what we are
doing here remove the title as we don't
need it remove the description as well
remove the header we only need the
content we need we don't need this yeah
we need the username full name text we
need the date you need to text and then
we don't need this whole bottom thing so
the data we need is we need the Tweet so
replied dialog procs so here we will
Define our props we will say type is
reply dialog props which is tweet and
that's all we need it will accept tweet
import the stuff here like that import
everything and here we will say it is
the type of tweet which we are getting
over here same import this icon and if
we save this and we will go and we will
see how it is looking refresh the whole
thing it's slow it it is stuck sometimes
but yeah let's go to localhost 3000 you
can this happens sometimes when we are
developing in early stage product okay
it is stuck so we have to open okay so
our browser is hang I don't know why it
is happening but it may happen now it is
gone we will open the localhost okay so
we are not passing the tweet from here
so we will say the two it is to it save
it is getting us in the problem so what
I will do I will open my new window and
I will use this over here yeah so if we
open this you can see we can see our
model here oh it is not opening here
yeah we can see if it open this we can
see this but we don't want this inside
or
so the problem we are facing over here
if we open this reply model this is the
thing which we don't need what is this
so let's PG slate this is a new tweet BG
slate this is we don't need where is
this yeah so this thing we don't need
and the text is gray let's use that text
white and we have to make this dialog
content look as our tweet so for that we
need to give some classes to it like PG
black and the classes we are giving
let's go here yeah it's good we can give
it BG black it's black we don't need the
Border as well so border is none it's
good text is white everywhere we can
remove this now it is looking much
better and if you go to the Tweet here
you can see this is over Avatar which we
have removed by assuming it as a picture
so now it's good we can give some space
to it so m y 4 yeah so let's assume a
big tweet create a big tweet generate
paragraph it hit enter or tweet
submitted in if you open this yeah
now this is looking just like a Twitter
timeline and this is awesome you can see
now we can open tweet and now we want to
reply to this tweet for that we need to
create a reply thing or we can say the
input thing so we will go to Twitter
again here we are if we click over here
you can see replying to pranzel Sony so
we can also show that replying to this
for that create another division
replying to at the rate and here we will
show the username tweet.user profile
load username and if we go to here you
can see replying to here and we can now
use our input box here create a division
we will use the input from UI it's
totally good to use anything like one
change or anything so save this this is
our input here we can submit our reply
let's make this look better just like
our tweet so if we go to main component
if we go to the compose compose Street
form here you can see the all input put
classes and we will use exact classes
over here because it is much much
similar you can see now it is good and
we can use this simple input field we
need to show the current user the author
as well so what we can do we can name it
Plex W full items Center space x 4 here
we can create a author as well so
instead of a dummy Avatar you can show
the original Avatar of user now we have
something we can type it's looking good
let's make it too so now if we open any
of the window you can see we can type
over here and we can reply and that's
okay that's cool I want to give it
maximum width of LG let's see how it
works SM after SM we are giving the
maximum weight of LC so instead of that
what I will do I will give it Excel
maximum width of MD let's see what we
are giving after SM maximum width of LG
okay okay okay if I remove this after SM
maximum width of let's go with SM yeah
we have to refresh this let's go with
Excel now if you open this you can see
this is bigger we want to make it much
bigger so we can go with to excel so if
we open this you can see this is better
this is the only single tweet and it is
rendered twice yeah this looks good this
looks good now we can reply something
here and let's assume we have a bigger
reply which is standard paragraph so it
should get bigger so instead of text
instead of input we can use something
called text area if you hit save you can
see this is bigger if you hit you can
see we can also scroll and it's better
and open this you can see we can see all
the things over here this is good now we
just need to submit this reply so for
that we can use a use form book or
something similar but what we are doing
we are just we will just use the use
State Hook and the on change this is
simple and we can just use it reply
reply text which is empty import it is
string you can say but it is also it is
already assuming it is a string because
we have empty string over here so we can
say it the value of it is apply text and
when we on change it it has event and we
can set the reply text to even though
Target dot value just like that save
this thing behave text area and now if
we hit submit if you go to Twitter and
we can show it reply button just like in
the compose form tweet button so copy
this thing also here I will paste this
and we will see how it is looking so you
can see we can tweet instead of tweet we
will say reply and this is below the
container so we can cut this container
and we can paste it here so it is below
the container you can see this is our
container we can show a little border
here so instead of this you can see this
is our reply area and here we have over
reply button which is exactly similar to
just like Twitter here we can open this
let's try to submit a reply and when we
click on this button we will submit
something we will do something so what
we will do when with this is clicked we
will submit a server action just like
like tweet so in the like date whereas I
would like tweet component close
everything go to the like button here
this is what we are going to do so we
will copy the whole thing the whole
thing copy this paste over here copy
this paste over here instead of using
this browser client now we can use the
use supervis from our authentication
provider Super Bass Just like that and
here we can say super based dot so yeah
like that here we can get the user and
here we can do the things we like import
the use transition Hook from react is
reply pending start transition and here
we can instead of it's like pending we
can show its reply pending and here
instead of this we can submit a or we
can say insert insert a row into the DB
which DB the reply table like that it is
simple and we need to do something so we
will do this and we can import the toast
to show some Tosh please log into reply
to reply please login to reply to a
tweet and if this is called
authentication failed that's good
everything looks good now and we just
need to insert Arrow into our database
for that we'll go to our mutation here
we will say export const reply and reply
yeah that's good reply async and it will
accept one thing it will accept tweet ID
it can accept two things basically it
can accept two things it can accept
tweet ID for now just accept the Tweet
ID and in the future I will tell you
what it can accept more tweet ID which
is string just like that and here we
will await and DB dot insert which table
you want to insert so we can say we we
want to insert in the replies table so
this table we want to insert it accepts
two things text user ID and tweet ID or
reply ID yeah we need the user ID as
well this is if this is a must can say
user ID which is string dot values here
we can pass down the values the text is
yeah basically we also need the text
which is reply text copy this it is also
a string so here we can say the text is
reply text the user ID is user ID the
Tweet ID is tweet ID that's all now it
will work like Char that's all we need
here if you want you can let's assume
your replies HTML you are submitting
Rich text into your database so you can
sanitize or you can verify your reply
text before saving to your DP so here
you can see you can verify or instead of
saying verify what we can say you can
check the reply text is 2 3 or not wait
for now we will just check if this is a
string or not for that we can we can
directly do if not reply which is which
can't be happen because we are checking
if it is reply here we can say if reply
text is no not equal to empty string or
we can say yeah then do this otherwise
don't do this so we can say if reply is
equal to empty string or reply text Dot
length which is the reply text length is
less than one character or two character
okay okay so we can allow one character
reply that's totally good we can return
simply we can return so now we just need
to use this reply over here so reply
here it will accept few things reply
text it will accept tweet ID it will
accept user ID and we have all of them
we have user dot ID the Tweet ID is we
have tweet dot tweet details dot ID save
this and when this is successfully done
what we need to do we need to close the
model which model we need to close the
reply model for that first we have to
control the model if we can open this or
not so here we can define a state use
State like that is reply mode if replied
dialog open initially it is false
initially it is false basically and here
we can say on change set is reply change
and yeah we can control it by status
reply change and it is open which is is
reply dialog open like that and we can
make it close like that so start
transition reply dot then here we can
make it false we can disable this button
and if we get something error we can
show dot error something
went wrong with Divi save this thing
here we are we will click on here this
is a reply we will click on reply and it
is closed as you can see and now if we
go to a database in the replies we
should be able to see one row of our
first reply so you can see this is a
reply and this is a tweet and it's
totally awesome tweet ID we have tweet
ID and we have everything we need here
and that is awesome that is totally
awesome so now if you this is cheat if
you click on the select record you can
see it will select a record from the
yeah this is a reply we have submitted
to test it and B now can render this
reply if we click on this whole tweet we
should be able to see the reply so for
that what we can do if we click on this
reply we can show the reply account as
well so now for this we have to create a
new UI for that so if you go to the
Tweet component here you can say when
the user clicks this division we should
open something or we should redirect to
something okay and also we can hover
when this is over PG white five so when
this is hovered we are not able to say
let's do it 20 refresh this and it will
work sometime it code is stuck now you
can see we are getting this white here
so let's do it then refresh this is slow
I can say this is slow now yeah five
would work and let's give it some
transition and also some timing so it
will work let's open localhost again in
the new window yeah it's good just like
Twitter a little bit of whiteness and
when we click this just like Twitter we
should also make this cursor as a cursor
pointer cursor pointer but the problem
is for that if we open the localhost if
we click this this is not opening okay
so it is it is slow let's open again in
new window if you click this you can see
we are opening a new model which is
totally good the model is good and if we
click this we are clicking two things we
are clicking this model and we are
clicking this so if we click this this
should open a new window but the problem
is if we click this it will also get
this clicked note this if we click this
okay so let me tell you what I'm saying
console Dot Lock hold tweet clicked this
is hold bit clicked and if we go to the
reply dialog here you can remove this
yeah here you can see console.log we
apply dialog clicked so now if you open
the console if you
I'm not sure why it is slow but it is
painfully slow let's open it inside
Firefox so you can see this is our
Twitter and it is looking dope I can say
this is looking dope if we go to tools
if we go to browser tools if we go to
browser console this is our console you
can see okay browser console mode yeah
and if I click on the street if I click
on the street and nothing is happening
or is the correct console let me open
web developer tools this over console
yeah so the problem I'm saying is if I
click on this whole tweet this whole
tweet clicked if I click on this button
then first first of all the whole tweet
will be clicked and then this button
will be clicked so replied I look
clicked hold tweet click so we want to
prevent clicking the whole tweet when we
click on that button so for that we can
separate these things out so instead of
clicking the whole tweet we can
differentiate what we want to click so
this is the whole division this is the
whole text division and we can only make
this thing clicked that's what I'm
saying and we can use this all fancy
animation over here so now our problem
is gone and we should be able to fix
this so let me open my browser as well
localhost this is our console now you
can see we are getting something and if
I click on this whole it clicks if I
click on this reply dialog clicked so
there is no conflict in clicking between
these things now if this is clicked what
we want now if this is clicked this is
opening reply this is okay this is
totally fine if this is clicked we want
to open a new timeline where the user
can see all the replies of a tweet for
that we can route this to whole
different router so for that we can use
next router const noter is equal to use
router import from next router here we
can redirect the user to tweet likes so
if you go to Twitter and if you click on
a single tweet like this if you click on
the street you can see this is opening
my username and then status and then the
Tweet ID and then we can see all the
tweets reply here
so the same thing we want to do but we
can make it a little bit of Easier by
doing something if we click on this we
can redirect the user to a nested route
in the app directory we will create a
new page and then we will redirect to
there so you can say outer dot push this
is spectix which means this now we can
stream interpolate and you can use logic
inside our string so we will say
redirect the user to this tweet ID so we
can set tweet slash the Tweet ID so
tweet dot tweet details dot ID so
redirect the user to this route and
where you can see all this stuff so
remove this now it is hang again I'm not
sure why it is okay we are not able to
see any of the tweets that's the part
comes this part happens when we are
building something new with the latest
tech stack let's open this is in Firefox
localhost 3000 we are getting empty over
here can we use a use router think or
can't I'm not sure
so there is something router dot refresh
yeah we have to use it from next
navigation that's the problem we are
getting here so now it should work it
has router dot back forward push good so
now it will work I think yeah it's
working open the whole thing now if you
click this you can see we are getting
redirected to this tweet if we go back
this is good if we click on this we are
seeing the new reply tab or the new new
reply dialog if you click this we are
getting redirected to the Tweet so now
we need to create a nested route and we
will fetch all the replies or to treat
building this part now if you search
Dynamic routes next yes you will learn
on this page routing in the routing you
have Dynamic routes you can create a
folder name inside folder name you can
create page.tsx
for your Dynamic routes
just like here so if you now go to our
application so if you go to Source in
the app router and in the app you have
page which is our main page let's create
a new thing actually we don't need any
API so we can we can delete this whole
folder we can delete this whole thing
here you can create a new folder which
is tweets or tweet yeah tweet is good
and inside the Tweet you can create a
new folder called ID and inside the ID
you can create page dot TSX it will
render over tweet and basically what you
can do we need the layout also we need
the layout also so we can use this over
here I think it will work just like
charm so this is our layout and in the
layout we need here left sidebar and
right sidebar both all the things we
need here so if you go to
layout.tsx here in the body inside the
body we can remove this component and we
can import this left sidebar and we can
import our right sidebar both links and
if we go to our main page here we can
remove this and we will render only one
component which is main component save
this thing save this thing now we have
this left sidebar and right sidebar
everywhere okay
so if you go to here if you refresh this
let's go to localhost 3000 and see if
this is working and here we can Define
our rafce here you can see this is home
page here we will call it to it page
this is tweet page save this now we can
you can see this is working just like
previously if you click here we can
reply if you click here it will redirect
us to the thesis tweet page you can see
it's good so now if you go to the main
component here we can copy the whole
this thing over here which is this this
is manageable and here we will render
all our twists not all the tips here we
need only one tweet which is we are
getting from const router is equal to
use router which is from next navigation
that's console.log the okay so we need
this ID basically we need this router
query so can we do this from next router
I'm not sure let's look to Theory out
and we will see okay so we can't use
router here we can use the navigation
but we want the queries so how can we
get the query okay so we can get the
query from use path name and all the
things available here so navigation here
we have some things where you use params
as you selected okay so you can use this
use params and let's log this out and
see what it gives us use programs only
works in client components is a use
cleaning okay so it is saying that it
only works in client components so now
what we can do can we get the use server
okay okay so we need the query basically
so we are directly getting the query
here that's totally awesome we don't
need anything we are getting like this
so in the here we have ID and that's
good see that generating generate static
params page to learn how to generate
parents that's totally good but this is
let's remove this and now we will lock
the parents and we we should see the ID
over here you can see we have ID which
is a tweet ID and now we can render our
tweet here for that const tweet we will
import our DB we will say select Dot
from when we need from tweets basically
we need the Tweet we need to join
something as well we need to do a lot of
things but for now let's join let's get
the tweet and show the Tweet over here
we need to show the tweet from the
client component it accepts something it
accepts his liked or not so we need to
find out his liked as well and also we
need we need one thing which is this
user ID over here import everything we
need and we can make it a sync as well
here we can Define the things we need
here we can say yeah so DB await don't
forget the await here we are saying DB
to select and just like in the get
tweets here we can select what we need
basically we need to copy the whole
thing we need to copy the whole thing we
are saying that the current ID this user
the current ID is user data dot user dot
ID if this exists yeah if user
data.user.id exists then do this
otherwise not we have to import all the
likes table all the profiles as well and
we don't need the order by but we need
one thing and equal equal current user
ID is user to this thing import exist as
well so you can see we are importing a
lot of things and we are joining we are
joining profiles who has the submitted
this state everything but we need a few
more things here what we need we need to
find out this tweet only single tweet
basically you can see we have params.id
inside the patterns so we don't need the
all tweets from select this from tweets
but basically instead of saying limit
dot you can say where equal just like it
where the equal is fields.id is equal to
params.id like that so it will give us
the current rate only so now if you lock
this tweet console Dot Lock to it here
we will see what we are getting to be
taught yeah now we have the Tweet to so
we are only getting the single why it is
to limit select from left join so we can
do the where here that's good it will
only return us one tweet so let's
comment this out for now and see what we
are getting yeah we got this we got one
tweet we code our one tweet which is
this profiles has like true because we
have like this so if you go to our home
page this is localhost 3000 if you
refresh this let's close this you can
see this is a new trade let's go to this
state we have liked this to it let's
remove our like click click here we are
on to this page here we can see we have
not liked this to it likes Arnel because
likes are zero the user who is the
author of the street and the Tweet
details we are getting all the details
of this tweet that's okay that's good so
here what we need we need the first
element of the street zeroth element
then we can say dot has liked or not and
here we can do this instead of this
sometime it may return so we can say
Boolean has liked we need the likes
count so we can set to it 0 tote likes
if it is null then zero then we can show
the Tweet detail as well tweet tote
tweet zero thought that tweets okay it
is saying the Tweet is all the details
of ya so we need to specify what is the
it needs to is detail which is tweet
zero dot tweets it needs user profile
which is tweet 0 dot profiles now it
needs one more thing which is current
user ID so we can pass the current user
ID as user data dot user dot ID it is
not required yeah that's good you can do
this it is still saying that okay so we
can count the number we can say likes
dot so it is giving us a lot of things
so we haven't joined all the tweets here
so it's not a big thing to let's not
show let's go to Twitter and see how
Twitter works so this is our Twitter if
you click on this we can see all the
things here as well so okay that's not a
problem let's do that thing as well so
if you go to our queries here we are
getting queries and here we are getting
all the things here so we need the same
thing here we can modify this tweet as
well if you want one tweet or not so
what we can do we can modify this same
row as well or we can use this function
to get the rows
cut this whole thing we will export this
export cost modify response is equal to
it will get the rows and it will return
the rows let's do it any
and here we have rows
it is saying untyped function calls may
not accept type arguments if we remove
this thing yeah but we need the type
result okay okay so we need to modify a
lot of types here I don't want that I
want to make it easy so we can get the
one tweet from here instead of getting
10 bits instead of limit so we can
Define the limit here as well and the
Tweet ID as well so we can we can say
get single tweet which is basically this
is Boolean we can say get single tit is
Boolean so if this is true what we can
do here instead of awaiting we can we
can say query we can modify this query
mode and we can say this is let query DB
dot select all to this all things order
this and we can also pass order by
Boolean so what we can do we can say if
over by is available then query is equal
to query tote this thing query dot order
by this here we can say if single tweet
if we only want to get the single tweet
which we want then we should have the
Tweet ID here basically get single tweet
and the Tweet ID so if this is true
which means we have a string which is
get single tweet ID so if this is true
then we can say query is equal to query
dot where dot where and we can pass down
the equal thing we can say tweets dot ID
is equal to get single tweet so this is
the ID so instead of get single tit we
can say get single date ID like that and
that's totally awesome and if this is
limit is default is if limit is defined
I can say limit and this is a number
limit is number so we can remove this
thing here we can say if limit is
defined query is equal to query tote
limit and we can pass down the limit
just like it it is very easy and after
all we can say row is equal to await
query const now it will give us all the
things we need that's how it will work
so if you want to get a single date we
can get it from this whole thing we are
modifying a single query to use here as
well so instead of get tweets copy this
thing get bits and yeah here we will go
and we will remove the whole thing we'll
say get tweets and here we will Define
the current user ID the user data dot
user dot ID the second thing we need is
get single tweet ID yeah so we need the
kit single ID and what is the ID payarms
dot ID which is single ID order by we
and we don't need anything and it will
give us the Tweet we don't want so now
we can remove this thing and we should
all get the thing here
tweet.30 dot hash select tweet is
possibly undefined so here we can say if
to it exist then render this otherwise
render something like division no tweet
found just like that and we can do this
tweet zero thing for all the Tweet here
total length dot tweet profile and it
will work I'm sure it will work yeah you
can see likes is an array and everything
is like perfectly charm you can see we
are also able to show this tweet over
here so we are showing one tweet if we
go to localhost when we click on home we
should be redirected to home so for that
if we go to our left sidebar here we are
sending the user to home page so instead
of item title lowercase we can send the
user to home page so here we can say if
item tote title is equal to home then
send the user to home page otherwise
send the user to their respective title
page so let's go to previous page which
is our single tweet you can see we are
getting the new tweet we can like this
to it as well and we are getting the
updated tweet if we click on Home Market
is still not working why is that left
sidebar if item dot title is capital
home basically so to fix it we can set
to local lowercase and it will work like
for now if I click on home you can see
we are getting all the tweets if we
click on this tweet we will get this to
it and we click on again then it will
send us to the Tweet again but we don't
want that to fix this go to the Tweet
here we are sending so instead of this
we can use this so if we go to previous
our tweet if we click here nothing
happened if I click on home yes this is
my first tweet click on this you can see
we are getting everything nice and easy
and we are showing now what we need to
do we need to show all the replies here
a sheet of tweet we need to show all the
replies here reply is also a kind of
tweet so basically we will fetch the
reply same as we fetch a tweet okay so
as you can see how to face them so it is
pretty simple with fetching the replies
we can say replies is equal to await DB
dot query dot what we want to fetch we
want to face the replies and we want to
fetch the many replies here we can
specify the extra columns we need for
pitching you can say we want to fetch
the profile as well so if we console.log
now console.log replace we will be able
to see all the replies you can see we
are getting all the replies with the
profile ID that's totally awesome okay
but it is it is fetching all the replies
we don't want all the replies we want a
very close here we can say we want only
replies with discrete page so we can say
the so we can specify some things here
dot DB dot query let's find out in the
drizzle aurum documentation how we can
use the query in the documentation index
has SQL operator where is this we can
directly use the select but I want to
use the query thing which is new so
where is this query tv.q yeah testing
rational query so like this can we
select and we can filter it or not yeah
so we can filter it just like it so you
can save where the equal operator import
the equal operator which we have already
imported we want to say that replies dot
here you can see user dot ID just like
that we are saying you reply is dot Okay
so
it replies response let's do it we want
to say replies dot ID note ID we want to
say the Tweet ID is equal to the parents
dot ID so now it will fetch only one
reply with the current Loop ID not one
reply with it will fetch all the replies
which the current tweet ID so let's log
this out and we will see what is
happening over here now you can see we
are only getting one reply which I have
created for this tweet if we go to home
and you can configure this home thing if
you go to Left sidebar here we are
saying that if the item dot title is
home then we are sending the user to
backslash which means home now here
let's create a new date new fresh tweet
hit enter this is our fresh tweet we
will click on this if we go here you can
see over array is empty which means our
replies are empty if we create a new
reply so this is a new reply and click
reply now you can see we so this is a
new reply here and if you go to the
mutation here we are revalidating our
path that's why we have our reply just
like that now what we need to do is we
need to render this whole thing over
here so we can use the same code just
like it we can use the same code over
here and we can render all the
applies.map we can say reply replies
response I think yeah and now we can
render the whole thing here let's create
a fragment and do this instead of
fragment let's create a division with
key of reply dot ID and paste everything
we have copied from that tweet so this
is our Circle this is a whole tweet okay
so we can specify the Tweet ID here we
can remove this extra division this is a
tweet tote so here we have our reply so
instead of tweet what we will do we will
cut everything and we will paste reply
dot profile dot full name reply dot
profile dot username import this thing
we can say reply tote when this is
created so we don't have this filter so
we can remove this thing as well what I
would suggest you currently we are
saving all the replies in a new reply
table but you can save the whole thing
in the tweetable as well you just need
to create it a new column in the Tweet
table so if you can go to schema you can
create a new column which is is reply
and you can say this is a Boolean so you
just need a Boolean field which will say
if this tweet is a reply then if it is a
reply don't show on the home timeline it
show on the Tweet page otherwise if it
is a reply then it's good so we can do
that that's totally up to you how you
want to save this if you created a new
table but that's not necessary at all
now this is our tweet text so here we
will render our reply dot text now we
don't need to click this and we can
remove everything from here we can
remove this as well and that's how we
are rendering all of our replies here so
now if you go to here you can see this
is a new reply and we are getting this
reply over here and we can remove our
cursor pointer over thing as well that's
totally awesome if you go to home if you
click on this you can see this is a
reply another reply which is built which
belongs to this tweet if you go here if
you go to this this doesn't have any
reply submit a reply hit reply and here
you can see we have our reply and it is
being rendered nice and easy go to here
this also has doesn't this hasn't any
reply this has two replies this tweet
has no replies I'm just finding out if
it is looking cool or not let's submit
another reply another reply this is so
cool it's good so let's hit reply and
here you can see we are rendering
replies here as well okay and it is from
Club of quarters let's submit a reply
from another account I will go to my new
account which is new page I will go to
localhost I will go here I will see two
tweets I will apply I am replying to
another from another account like this
if you hit reply you can see YT bro box
this is our current username and we are
reply and here you can also see okay hit
note here here you can see we are
getting everything nice and easy so
that's all that's all for this video we
have built a lot of features we have
built a lot of things we can also like
this tweet and this is stop everything
is looking good to me yeah this is now
one this has now 2 likes so we have
learned how to fetch the tables using
drizzle orm we have learned how to reply
to a tweet how to show the tweets how to
do everything now if you want to learn
more check out my course on
cluboforders.com check out some more
advanced courses where you can learn how
to handle all the more complex stuff as
well but yeah if you want to learn for
free I also have some tutorials on my
channel where you can learn everything
for free but that's all for now and this
is our Twitter clone and that's all we
are creating okay if you want some more
features you can Implement basically
this is a simple approach where you can
do all this stuff this is a similar
approach so we will end our Twitter
series here and I will see you in some
another tutorial or seeing some another
series thank you very much